BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
ONE THE HEARING OF MAY SIXTH.
I WANT TO WELCOME ALL OF YOU IT
AND AS YOU NOTE WE HAVE A VERY
LONG AGENDA HOW OVER WHATEVER I
DID WANT TO BE ABLE TO GIVE ALL
OF THE MEMBERS AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
A CHANCE TO PRESENT THEIR
PROPOSALS.
WE FIND THAT VIRTUALLY ALL OF
THE MANY PROPOSALS THAT ARE
SUBMITTED TO SOMEONE ARE
MERITORIOUS THE COMPELLING OTHER
WORTHY OF OUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION.
ALL OF THEM SEEK TO ADDRESS
CRITICAL HEALTH CHALLENGES THAT
OUR STATE FACES.
I'M ONLY SORRY THAT WE CAN'T
APPROVED THE FUNDS FOR ALL OF
THEM.
IN FACT WHILE THE ECONOMY IN THE
STATE'S FISCAL CONDITION ARE
BOTH STRONG.
THERE ARE MANY LIMITATIONS ON
STATE SPENDING.
MOREOVER WHILE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
HEALTH CARE MAYBE OUR COLLECTIVE
HIGHEST PRIORITY IN THE BUDGET.
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR.
HAVE HAVE TO BALANCE THE STATE'S
HEALTH NEEDS WITH MANY OTHER
SIGNIFICANT POLICY AREAS.
SUCH AS EDUCATION CRIMINAL
JUSTICE TRANSPORTATION CHILD
CARE ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AND OTHERS.
GIVEN THESE CONSTRAINTS AND
GIVEN THE GOVERNOR'S SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN HEALTH IN HIS
PROPOSED BUDGET.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE
A FEW KEY ADDITIONS TO OUR
HEALTH CARE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
BUDGETS.
I APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WITH TODAY'S HEARING
AND IN ORDER TO NOT BE HERE.
ALL NIGHT I DO ASK THAT WOULD
FOLLOW JUST A FEW RULES. FOR THE
MEMBER AND STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS
EACH PROPOSAL MAY HAVE ONE
SPEAKER OR PRESENTER.
AND THAT PERSON MAY HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
I SHOWED IN THE AGENDA.
WE WILL GROW PUBLIC COMMENT BY
DEPARTMENT.
AND GIVEN THE LENGTH OF THIS
AGENDA WE WILL ASK THAT ALL
PUBLIC COMMENT BE LIMITED TO
GIVING YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION.
STATE THE ISSUE NUMBER YOU'RE
SPEAKING ABOUT.
AND WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE IT.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT.
I ASK FOR SOMEBODY MEMBER LEóN
[inaudible] TO PRESENT.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
I AM PROUD TO STAND HERE -- OR
SIT HERE WITH THE S. SUPPORT OF
FELLOW CAUGHT THIS FROM THE
COMMITTEE FROM BIG BEAR BALDWIN
PARK IN SANTA ROSA -- ALONG WITH
SEVENTEEN OTHER ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
TO URGE THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT A TEN MILLION DOLLAR ONE
TIME BUDGET REQUEST TO FIND
ALZHEIMER'S OUR REACH AND EARLY
DIAGNOSIS.
TODAY TWENTY TWO POINT THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE LIVING
WITH OR CARING FOR A LOVED ONE
WITH ALZHEIMER'S.
IT'S A TOP CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG
WOMEN IN OUR STATE AND THE
DISEASE HITS COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR HARDEST.
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND LATINOS
HAVE HIGHER PROVIDE PREVALENCE
HIGHER COST AND IF THEY ARE
DIAGNOSED IT'S MUCH LATER IN THE
DISEASE PROCESS.
IT IS CLEAR TO ME THAT WE CANNOT
AFFORD TO WAIT ANOTHER BUDGET
CYCLE TO DO SOMETHING
SIGNIFICANT FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS
WERE SUFFERING IN SILENCE. FOR
TOO LONG WE HAVE TACKLED
ALZHEIMER'S AT THE BACK END
WHERE THE COSTS ARE THE HIGHEST
HOSPITAL'S EMERGENCY ROOMS AND
NURSING HOMES.
AND THIS SUBCOMMITTEE KNOWS BEST
WE CANNOT SUSTAIN THIS TODAY.
AND WE CERTAINLY CANNOT THE
STANDING IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WHEN WE WILL SEE A 25% INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS
WITH ALZHEIMER'S.
OUR STATE HAS THE LARGEST NUMBER
OF PEOPLE AFFECTED BY THIS
DISEASE.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO LEAD
THE NATION TO SHOW THE WAY
FORWARD.
TOGETHER WE CAN INVEST IN THE
HEALTHY BRAIN INITIATIVE AND
BEGIN SHIFTING RESOURCES AND OUR
MINDSET FROM THE BACK INTO THE
FRONT END OF THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS.
THIS BUDGET REQUEST WILL ALLOW
US TO CREATE A STATEWIDE PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN TARGETS OUT
REACH TO UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
FOCUS ATTENTION ON EARLY
DETECTION AND PARTNER WITH
COUNTIES AND LOCAL SOLUTIONS ON
LOCAL SOLUTIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO JOIN
IN SUPPORTING THIS TEN MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME BUDGET ASK.
THANK YOU MISLI MON THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR MS Là MON.
VETERANS.
ARE YOU WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO
DETERMINE HOW BEST TO DO THIS
MISS LIVE ON SO I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU CAME BACK.
ACTUALLY THIS IS NOT A NOT A
QUESTION I JUST WANT THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD RIGHT
INTO THE EARLY DIAGNOSIS IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL -- THE
POTENTIAL FOR OF A BETTER
QUALITY OF LIFE -- FOR BETTER
LINKAGE OF TREATMENT --
ESPECIALLY EARLY ON IS ACTUALLY
CRITICAL I'M HUGE SUPPORTER AND
I I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING A CO AUTHOR MY
PLEASURE.
THANK YOU MISLIM ON MR ALMOST
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT A
REQUEST FOR A CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS.
ON PENN STATE HOSPITALS GROUNDS --
IN OUR AREA WHICH I KNOW -- THE
CHAIRS FAMILIAR WITH THE AREA.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD UTILIZE
CURRENTLY UNUSED AREAS AT THE
STATE HOSPITALS GROUNDS TO
DEVELOP A CRISIS STABILIZATION
UNIT FOR THE WHOLE REGION.
CRISIS STABILIZATION UNITS HAVE
BEEN EFFECTIVE AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL IN REDUCING THE USE OF
RESOURCES ON INCARCERATION AND
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES AND
DIVERTING THOSE RESOURCES
TOWARDS MORE EFFECTIVE
STABILIZATION.
WHEN PEOPLE EXPERIENCE CRISIS
WOULD OTHERWISE BE BROUGHT TO A
JAIL OR A HOSPITAL?
FACILITIES OF THIS KIND PROVIDE
LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH A FURTHER
TOOL ALLOWING THEM TO GET BACK
ON THE STREET AND BACK ON JUST
KEEP IN OUR COMMUNITY SAFE.
THE EXISTING LAND IN
INFRASTRUCTURE -- RESOURCES THAT
THIS FACILITY FACILITY PROVIDES
WILL EXPAND AN ALREADY EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM BEYOND ITS EXISTING
FACILITIES IN THE COUNTING TO
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES.
FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING CRISIS
IN OUR COMMUNITY.
BEFORE LEAVING THE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS WE WERE ABLE TO
GET A CRISIS STABILIZATION UNIT
OUT IN THE JOSHUA TREE AREA AND
CEREMONIAL COUNTY.
WE SEEN THE THE AFFECTS OF HOW
THAT CAME FORWARD AND HELPED
WITH DESTABILIZING THE SITUATION.
RATHER THAN HAVING INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE TO GO TO A COUNTY JAIL
OR EMERGENCY ROOM THE CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS SERVED THERE
IN JOSHUA TREE WOULD TWELVE BEDS.
KEPT PEOPLE TO GIVEN THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED IT.
THESE ARE BIG AT THE BIG THINGS
THAT START TO LOOK AT THE MENTAL
HEALTH PICTURE THAT'S OUT THERE.
THIS TODAY WITH THE PRESENTATION
BEFORE YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
IS -- FIRST HAND KNOWLEDGE THAT
THESE OF CRISIS STABILIZATION
UNITS DO WORK.
ALTHOUGH SOME WOULD ARGUE THAT
THEIR COSTLY IN THE BEGINNING I
WOULD ARGUE THAT THEY SAVE MONEY
IN THE LONG RUN.
LIKE YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS TO
THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER ROSS QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IS THAT AYE RECOMMENDATION.
SINCE THIS IS.
BILL.
IS THE ONLY IT ITEM ON IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA.
I WILL ALLOW PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME.
MA'AM CHAIR MEMBERS GO WITH HIS
IDEA WITH CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS
SOMEWHERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER VICE CHAIR MISTER MATHIS
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT A
REQUEST BEFORE YOU.
WHICH WOULD FURTHER FUND HAD THE
FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE PARTNERSHIP
THIS PROGRAM WHICH IS RUN
THROUGH THE TULARE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION WAS ESTABLISHED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR WAS CREATED
AS A HIGH SCHOOL PROGRAM.
DESIGNED TO REDUCE UNDERAGE
DRINKING AND DRIVING.
AND TO PROMOTE A TEENAGE
LIFESTYLE FREE FROM ALCOHOL AND
OTHER DRUGS.
IT IS THE MISSION OF FRIDAY
NIGHT LIFE. TO BUILD POSITIVE
AND HEALTHY YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
THAT ENGAGE OTHER USE.
AS ACTIVE LEADERS AND RESOURCES
IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
THE FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE PROGRAM
GREW FROM A PILOT PROGRAM IN
THREE COUNTIES. TO A STATEWIDE
MOVEMENT.
THAT AT ITS PEAK.
OPERATED IN FIFTY FIVE OF OUR
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
AND HAD JUST OVER ONE THOUSAND
CHAPTERS.
AT SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY SITES.
HOWEVER SINCE THE DOWNTURN OF
THE ECONOMY THE FRIDAY NIGHT
LIVE PROGRAM AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVELS.
HAS SEEN DRAMATIC REDUCTIONS.
IN FUNDING.
RESULTING IN LESS CAPABILITY TO
SERVE YOUNG PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY NEED CONTINUES TO GROW?
TODAY THE FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE
PROGRAM CONTINUES TO OPERATE.
IN FIFTY OF OUR FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WITH JUST OVER FIVE
HUNDRED CHAPTERS [inaudible] ONE
PROGRAM.
THAT WAS DECIMATED.
WITH THE ELIMINATION OF FUNDING.
WAS THE FRIDAY NIGHT LIFE
MENTORING PROGRAM.
THE FRONT AND I LIVE MENTORING
PROGRAM IS A CROSS AGE MENTORING
PROGRAM THAT CONNECTS HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS AS POSITIVE ROLE
MODELS FOR MIDDLE SCHOOL
STUDENTS TO PREPARE THEM FOR A
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION INTO HIGH
SCHOOL.
WHAT THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN ABLE
TO RETAIN SOME OF ITS ORIGINAL
SERVICES?
THE BENEFITS OFFERED TO THE
STUDENTS SHOULD BE EXPANDED.
TO THEIR ORIGINAL LEVELS.
PLEASE PROGRAMS HAVE AN EVIDENCE
BASED PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF
BENEFITING THEIR PARTICIPANTS
EXPRESSION WITH REGARD TO
REDUCING ABUSE OF ALCOHOL
TOBACCO DRUGS.
AND VIOLENCE.
THIS PROGRAM HELPS YOUNG PEOPLE
STAY IN SCHOOL INCREASING
SCHOOLS.
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE AND
HELPS FOR MO A SAFE SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTS [inaudible]
AS SUCH.
WE SHOULD EXPAND THE CAPACITY OF
THE FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE SYSTEM.
IN THE FIFTY COUNTIES BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT AND ENHANCE THE
QUALITY OF LOCAL.
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION.
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THIS AND I
AM REQUESTING SIXTY MILLION
ANNUALLY BE TRANSFERRED FROM THE
GENERAL FUND.
AND TO DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR THE PURPOSES OF
FUNDING THE CALIFORNIA FRIDAY
NIGHT LIFE PARTNERSHIP.
AT THE TULARE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
WE ARE OFTEN FACED WITH FUNDING
REQUEST THAT ADDRESS IMMEDIATE
TRAUMA.
THIS REQUEST A SINGLE.
IS TO INVEST.
IN FRIDAY NIGHT LIFE. TO PREVENT
TRAUMA FROM HAPPENING.
WHERE AREAS THAT IT'S HONESTLY
NEEDED THE MáS [inaudible]
OUR YOUTH.
AS WE KNOW MOST OFTEN GET IN
TROUBLE.
DURING THOSE LITTLE BITS OF
HOURS AFTER SCHOOL BETWEEN WHEN
MAMA GET THAT GETS HOME.
IN.
YOU KNOW THIS THESE PROGRAMS
THEY PROVIDE THAT MENTORSHIP.
THAT HELPS OUR KIDS NOT GET LOST
IN THE WEEDS AS THEY TRANSITION.
THAT HELPS THEM.
BY GIVING THEM GOOD ROLE MODELS
IN BY TEACHING THEM HOW TO BE
GOOD ROLE MODELS.
MEMBERS ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WORST MATHIS QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
DOCTOR WOULD
.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO ADD TO SUPPORT A BUDGET ASK
OF ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS FOR A
PILOT PROJECT. TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO SPECIALTY CARE THROUGH HE
CONSOLE TECHNOLOGY.
CALIFORNIA IS FACING A WERE SEEN
SHORTEN IT SHORTAGE OF
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONS WHICH
GREATLY DIMINISHES THE ABILITY
OF PEOPLE TO GAIN ACCESS TO THE
QUALITY OF HEALTH CARE NEEDED
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL COMMUNITIES.
IN PARTS OF MY DISTRICT ONE IN
FIVE ADULTS FIND IT DIFFICULT TO
MEET THEIR HEALTHCARE NEEDS
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF PHYSICIANS.
ADDITIONALLY IN ORDER TO ACCESS
SPECIALTY CARE PEOPLE MAY HAVE
TO TRAVEL OVER A HUNDRED MILES
IN MY DISTRICT THAT MIGHT BE AN
ADVENTURE.
ECON SALTS ARE THE ARE FAR FOR
MEDICINE TELEMEDICINE THEY CAN
BE USED TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
SPECIALTY CARE.
IN RURAL DISTRICTS LIKE MINE
HOWEVER THERE ARE TECHNICAL
BARRIERS TO ADOPTING ECON SO
SERVICES SUCH AS TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THE WORK FLOW DEVELOPMENT
NECESSARY FOR EFFECTIVE USE OF
THE CONSOLES THE PROPOSED PILOT
PROJECT WE GIVE HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE NECESSARY. TO ADOPT
ECON SO PROGRESS PROGRAMS THIS
PILOT PROJECT WOULD IMPROVE
ACCESS TO SPECIALTY CARE THROUGH
INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH CARE FOR
MEDI CAL PATIENTS IN LARGELY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
THIS PILOT PILOT PROJECT BUT
ALSO ENABLE THE MUCH NEEDED DATA
COLLECTION ON THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF USING ECON
SOULS IN THESE REGIONS TO ACCESS
SPECIALTY CARE.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
AND I'M AND I ASKED ONCE AGAIN
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BUDGET
MASK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SAYING NONE
.
MR RIVAS I'M SORRY I DIDN'T SEE
YOU.
IN THAT CORNER
[inaudible]
MADAM CHAIR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALSO AS MANY OF YOU MAY OR MAY
NOT KNOW PRIOR TO MY TIME IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY -- I SERVED EIGHT
YEARS AS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR --
AND I ALSO WORKED AS AN ADJUNCT
INSTRUCTOR AT A LOCAL -- A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I WORK
FULL TIME AS A STUDENT SUPPORT
MANAGER AT A VERY LARGE -- HIGH
SCHOOL -- HIGH SCHOOL THAT HAS
STUDENT POPULATION BY THREE
THOUSAND AND SO MY TIME IS IS A
POOR MEASURES VERY REWARDING
EXPERIENCE VERY EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE.
AND IN MY CAPACITY AS A MANAGER
I WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR STUDENT
DISCIPLINE -- WORKING WITH
CHRONICALLY TRUANT STUDENTS.
PREPARING OUR SCHOOL SAFETY PLAN
AND ALWAYS ALWAYS WORKING TO
ASSESS AND IMPROVE OUR SCHOOL
CLIMATE A CHANGING CLIMATE AT
THAT.
IT'S I WORKED WITH -- STUDENTS
EVERY SINGLE DAY -- FROM
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS FROM --
CERTAINLY -- FROM THE DIFFERENT --
EDUCATIONAL -- EXPERIENCES AN
ACADEMIC -- EXPERIENCES -- AND
IT WAS THE STUDENTS IN THE AND
THE INTERACTION I HAD WITH THEM
THAT HELP ME REALIZE A SCHOOL
CLIMATE WAS ABOUT EMPOWERING AND
WELCOMING ALL STUDENTS TO CAMPUS.
STUDENTS WITH.
THE DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS IN NEEDS
AND IT WAS ABOUT.
PROVIDING THEM WITH SUPPORTS AND
INTERVENTIONS.
AND SO CERTAINLY THIS SOUNDS
EASY TO DO BUT MAKING SURE THAT
WE CREATE SUCH A POSITIVE SCHOOL
CLIMATE WAS AND IS VERY VERY
TOUGH TO DO.
HAVING A RELEVANT -- THE DATE ON
SCHOOL CLIMATE I WILL CERTAINLY
HELP YOU TO HELP OUR STUDENTS
ARE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND IT'LL
HELP EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA
PERIOD.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY
FOUR AND THIS FUNDING IS ALL
ABOUT -- IT IS -- YOU KNOW
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK NOW NOT
ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
MINISTERING -- COMMON SURVEY
QUESTIONS QUESTIONS THAT ARE
NEEDED TO YIELD ACCURATE
REGIONAL AND LOCAL DATA -- TO
EFFECTIVELY MONITOR AND ADDRESS
DRUG USE SCHOOL CLIMATE AND
STUDENT ENGAGEMENT -- AND ALL OF
WHICH THESE THESE -- THESE.
PRIORITIES ARE ARE ARE ALL ON
PRIORITIES UNDER THE LOCAL ON
THE CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
AND SO CERTAINLY -- THIS BILL
SIX TWENTY FOUR REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS OF EDUCATION
HEALTH CARE SERVICES PUBLIC
HEALTH TO DEVELOP A PLAN TO
PROVIDE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES -- WITH THE TOOLS AND
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
ADMINISTER ANNUAL SERVICE TO
STUDENTS PARENTS AND TEACHERS.
HAVING THIS NON.
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE DATA
AVAILABLE TO OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND TO THEIR
RESPECTIVE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AGENCIES WILL HELP INFORM THE
LOCAL PLANNING PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT ACTIVITIES.
AND CERTAINLY GO A LONG WAY TO
HELP OUR SCHOOLS GREAT POSITIVE
SCHOOL CLIENTS AND I SHOULD NOTE
MADAM CHAIR THAT EARLIER THIS
YEAR I SUBMITTED A REQUEST FOR
TEN MILLION ON GOING FROM PROP
SIXTY FOR THE YOUTH EDUCATION.
PREVENTION EARLY INTERVENTION
TREATMENT ACCOUNT WE NOW BELIEVE
THAT -- PROGRESS CAN BE ACHIEVED
WITH AS LITTLE AS THREE POINT --
FIVE MID MID EXCUSE ME THE
MILLION DOLLARS SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
REAVIS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU.
I SEE MR TRUE -- THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
A BUDGET ASKED TO QUOTE AN THE
EPIDEMICS -- THIS IS A COMMITTEE
THAT KNOWS THAT WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC HEALTH CRISES
WITH REGARDS TO HIV.
HEPATITIS C. AND STDS IN
CALIFORNIA JUST A COUPLE OF
STATISTICS OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ARE
LIVING WITH HIV IN OUR STATE HAS
THE HIGHEST ANNUAL NUMBER.
OF NEW HIV DIAGNOSES IN THE
COUNTRY OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS CURRENTLY
LIVE WITH HEPATITIS C..
MOST OF WHOM DO NOT KNOW IT.
AND THERE ARE MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND REPORTED STT
CASES IN CALIFORNIA AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHICH WAS A
45% INCREASE SINCE.
TWENTY THIRTEEN OUR STATE HAS
THE ABILITY TO AND THESE
EPIDEMICS BUT WE HAVEN'T MADE
THE NEEDED INVESTMENTS IN OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS TO
ADDRESS THIS EFFECTIVELY.
WE ALSO KNOW THESE EPIDEMICS OR
IN A RELATED AND NEED TO BE
TREATED IN AN INTEGRATED MANNER.
OVER A HUNDRED FORTY
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE SIGNED A
COMMUNITY STATEMENT CALLING ON
THE GOVERNOR AND THOSE OF US IN
THE LEGISLATURE TO IMPLEMENT AN
AND A STRATEGY TO AN HIV
HEPATITIS C. AND R. STD
EPIDEMICS.
I AM ON BEHALF OF THESE HUNDRED
FORTY ORGANIZATIONS REQUESTING A
ONE TIME ALLOCATION.
OF TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF
GENERAL FUND TO ESTABLISH AN ND
EPIDEMICS TASK FORCE TO CREATE A
STRATEGIC.
CROSSED APARTMENT ALL AND
COMMUNITY INFORMED BLUEPRINT TO
END THESE EPIDEMICS IN OUR STATE.
THIS APPROACH HAS PROVEN TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN NEW YORK STATE FOR
EXAMPLE -- THEY ESTABLISH A TASK
FORCE TO END THE AIDS EPIDEMIC
BY TWENTY TWENTY THE STATE
COMMITTED OVER TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES DEVELOPED BY THE TASK
FORCE.
AND NEW HIV DIAGNOSES HAVE
DECREASED 20% IN THAT STATE.
WITH THE SMALL ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OUR STATE COULD BUILD
UPON THE EFFECTIVE MODELS WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND HELP LEAD THE NATION ONCE
AGAIN AND DEVELOPING A FOR
STATEWIDE STRATEGY TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY ADDRESS THESE
EPIDEMICS AND WITH THAT.
I HAVE A WITNESS TO SAY JUST A
FEW WORDS AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY NEVER MIND I WAS TOLD THAT
YOU COULD.
BUT HERE IN CASE YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS RIGHT QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
NUMBER OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
THREE SHARE YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANKS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY
.
ALL RIGHT I DO KNOW THAT SOME OF
OUR ISSUE -- THREE ARE BEING
PRESENTED BY NON MEMBERS THE
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH DROP IN
CENTERS. TWENTY MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS TOBY EWING ON BEHALF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION --
SPEAKING ON THIS HOWEVER
GIBSON'S PROPOSAL FOR THE YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH DROP IN CENTERS
THE REQUEST IS FOR TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. TO
SUPPORT A SERIES OF INTEGRATED
SERVICES FOR YOUTH.
HI THIS IS A PROJECT THAT HAS
BEEN DEMONSTRATED EFFECTIVE IN
OTHER COUNTRIES AND AUSTRALIA
AND CANADA.
IN EUROPE AND THE INTENT IS TO
BRING THIS MODEL TO THE UNITED
STATES STARTING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE MODEL ACTUALLY ENGAGES YOUNG
PEOPLE TO DESIGN SERVICES AROUND
THEIR NEEDS LOOKING AT MENTAL
HEALTH PHYSICAL HEALTH EDUCATION
SOCIAL EMPLOYMENT SUPPORT.
IS PREMISED ON THE IDEA OF
WORKING WITH YOUNG PEOPLE TO
REALLY.
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN TAILOR AND
INTEGRATE SERVICES IN WAYS THAT
ARE RESPONSIVE TO THEIR NEEDS.
THE MODEL HAS BEEN SHOWN
EFFECTIVE IN THE ABILITY TO BOTH
LEVERAGE OTHER FUNDS AND TO
REDUCE ON GOING NEEDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT THEIR ABILITY
TO SUCCEED IN SCHOOL. SIXTEEN
EMPLOYMENT AVOID CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT AND OTHER
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES THE COMMISSION
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS AND OTHER
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS TO DESIGN
A MODEL PROGRAM STARTING IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
THE PROPOSAL IS TO MAKE FUNDS
AVAILABLE THAT WOULD ALLOW THIS
MODEL TO BE EXTENDED STATEWIDE.
RECOGNIZING THAT SO OFTEN OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE NOT ADEQUATELY
SERVE BECAUSE THE NATURE OF OUR
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM CLASHES
WITH WITH WHO THEY ARE INTO IN
TERMS OF THAT.
OFTEN MEDICAL MODEL AND AND
WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE IN THEIR
IN THEIR SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND
VERY MUCH -- ASKING FOR SUPPORT
FOR THIS PROPOSAL AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER EWING.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS RECRUITING
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AND YOUR PLEASE BE PRESENT THE
PROJECT -- MISTER O'DONNELL AS
WELL AGAIN TOBIN HEARING ON
BEHALF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND KIND OF
THE COMMISSION PRESENTING FOR
MISTER O'DONNELL ON THIS
PROPOSAL FOR EDUCATION BASE
METAL HEALTH SERVICES.
I THINK I'VE TESTIFIED BEFORE
MANY OF YOU IN HEALTH COMMITTEE
AND AND BUDGET COMMITTEE ON THE
WORK THAT THE COMMISSION HAS
BEEN DOING AND THE NEED TO
REALLY IMPROVE OUR UNDERSTANDING
OF THE SERVICES THAT WE HAVE --
WE'VE DEMONSTRATED TO THE WE'VE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN TELLING A
LIMITED STORY OF DOLLARS
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS.
AND BEING ABLE TO TRANSLATE THAT
INFORMATION INTO STRATEGIES TO
DRIVE TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE.
THIS PROPOSAL IS TO PROVIDE
FUNDS TO THE COMMISSION TOOK TO
BUILD UPON THAT BASS.
NAMELY IN TERMS OF STRENGTHENING
OUR FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY WE WANT TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE SYSTEM IN IN THE IN THE
BROADER MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
SPECIFICALLY IN AREAS RELATED TO
CHILDREN IN SCHOOL.
AND AS PART OF THAT -- PUT IN
PLACE A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
A FACILITATION STRATEGY SO THAT
WE CAN REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
WORKING IN SOME COMMUNITIES AND
EXTEND THOSE AFFECTED PRACTICES
AND OTHER COMMUNITIES.
ON TOP OF THAT TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THE STATE'S POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES AND PRACTICES CAN
IMPEDE THE ABILITY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
NEEDS OF OUR OF OUR CHILDREN
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES.
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT ARE
RESULTING IN -- OUR INABILITY TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH AN APPROPRIATE
EDUCATION AND HELP CHILDREN
THRIVE AND SO WITH THAT VERY
MUCH ASKING YOUR SUPPORT. TO
EXTEND THE WORK THAT THE
COMMISSION'S DOING FOCUSED ON
CHILDREN HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
YES DOCTOR WITH JUST A JUST A
REQUIREMENT IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL -- I PARTICULARLY --
PLEASED TO SEE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PIECE OF THIS TO BE
ABLE -- TO HELP.
OTHER OTHER -- SCHOOLS AND AND
GROUPS -- TO BE ABLE TO LEARN
FROM OTHERS I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY VALUABLE AND JUST
THE GENERAL -- CHALLENGES WERE
FACING -- WITH TRIED TO BY.
TRYING TO PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE TO YOUNG PEOPLE HAS
BECOMING A GREATER AND GREATER
CHALLENGE FROM A WORKFORCE
PERSPECTIVE THROUGH
IMPLEMENTATION IN SCHOOL SO --
I'M I'M SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL
ON A THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF MR
O'DONNELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ALRIGHT I UNDERSTAND
YOU WERE PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
MR TING AS WELL.
NOW THERE'S ANOTHER ALL RIGHT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
APPARENTLY NOT.
IS C. CAM HERE [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LINDA TOMORROW WHAT'S ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK WE ARE A
STATE WIDE HEALTH ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
PROMOTE.
HEALTH EQUITY FOR HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
I WOULD THINK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OUR
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL TO IMPROVE
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN MARCH WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT RECENT MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITY DATA BEFORE THE POLICY
COMMITTEE.
IN PARTICULAR WE HIGHLIGHTED THE
FACT THAT MENTAL HEALTH
UTILIZATION CONTINUES TO VARY
WIDELY BY REESE PRIMARY LANGUAGE
AND THAT MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES ARE NOT IMPROVING
OVER TIME.
IN FACT THESE GROSS INEQUITIES
PERSISTENCE BY A FOR ITS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE.
GIVEN THIS WE ARE URGING THE
STATE TO MAKE A CONCRETE
INVESTMENT INTO THE REDUCTION OF
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES.
C. PEN BELIEVES THAT ADDRESSING
THESE PERSISTENT INEQUITIES WILL
REQUIRE A FOCUSED AND MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH.
WE MUST INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY
OF THE SYSTEMS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND WE MUST BE WILLING TO INVEST
DOLLARS TO DRIVE THOSE OUTCOMES.
WE SURVEYED OVER A DOZEN
COUNTIES ABOUT THEIR CHALLENGES
WITH MAKING PROGRESS ON MENTAL
HEALTH EQUITY.
THE TEAMS THAT EMERGE INCLUDED
ANY FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
NEED FOR A BETTER DATA TO INFORM
DECISION MAKING.
AND A LACK OF COLLABORATION
BETWEEN SECTORS -- AND A LACK OF
STATEWIDE ACCOUNTABILITY.
THEREFORE WE ARE SEEKING TO
TACKLE THESE CHALLENGES WITH AN
INVESTMENT OF FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FROM THE MHSAA
ADMINISTRATION FUND TO SUPPORT
COUNTIES.
IN REDUCING THE MENTAL HEALTH
INEQUITIES AMONG VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
THIS FUND CURRENTLY HAS OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN SURPLUS.
OUR PROPOSAL IS FOR FUNDS TO BE
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE OAC IN
CONSULTATION WITH A STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. FOR
ALLOCATION TO COUNTIES AND OTHER
ENTITIES.
PROVIDING COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR FOR
DIFFERENT PURPOSES TO
EFFECTIVELY EXECUTE STRATEGIES
ON DISPARITY REDUCTION.
SPECIFICALLY THE FUNDS WOULD BE
USED.
FOR COUNTY SUPPORT WITH DATA
COLLECTION TO ACCURATELY CAPTURE
WHAT DISPARITIES EXIST BASED ON
RACE LANGUAGE AGE GENDER
IDENTITY SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
DISABILITY STATUS.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
COUNTIES TO DEVELOP TRAUMA
INFORMED A COMMUNITY DRIVEN
STRATEGIES WITH FIELD EXPERTS TO
REDUCE THOSE DSPARITIES.
ADDITIONALLY THE ALWAYS SEE
SHALL FACILITY CROSS COUNTY
LEARNING COLLABORATIVE TO SHARE
BEST PRACTICES.
THIS FUNDING WOULD ALSO GO
TOWARDS INNOVATION GRANTS TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES
COMMUNITY BASED WORKS SCHOOLS
AND OTHER ENTITIES TO IMPLEMENT
PROJECTS TO RESPOND TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES --
LASTLY -- WE HAVE -- BUILT A
COMPANY THIS MEASURE AB FIVE
TWELVE WHICH CREATES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND AN
ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISM -- FOR
THIS BUDGET REQUEST AND PROVIDES
RESOURCES TO COUNTIES TO
SUCCESSFULLY REDUCE THOSE
DISPARITIES -- FIRST THOSE
REASONS I WE HOPEFULLY FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BUDGET BUDGET
REQUEST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR PRESENTING
ON BEHALF OF MR TEAM.
THIS IS THE END OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION
PRESENTATIONS SO WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE.
ON THESE.
THREE ISSUES.
I MARK QUITE VOLUNTEER THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION HERE
REPRESENTING MY WIFE CAROL WHO
DIED TWO DAYS BEFORE
THANKSGIVING LAST YEAR I HEARD
YOUR SUPPORT. FOR THE FOR AB.
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT FOR ISSUE
FIVE HEALTHY RENDITION OF YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON NICOLE DAHLKE
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WE ARE
SPONSORS OF HEALTHY BRAIN
INITIATIVE ISSUE FIVE IN STRONG
SUPPORT TEAM CAN GO TO STOP FOR
JUST A MOMENT.
ON ISSUE FIVE WE'RE NOT TAKING
IT THIS IS ONLY ADDS TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
SO THE LAST THREE PRESENTATIONS
ON MENTAL HEALTH THEY WERE GIVEN
ON MISTER GIPSON STIRRED DONALD
MISTER TANKS PROPOSALS MY
APOLOGY.
THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
IT'S A NEW PROCESS WE'RE TRYING
HERE.
ROBLIN WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION ON
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE GIPSON
DROP IN CENTERS WERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
EVERY ARE I MEAN IS ON THE HAVE
THE LET THE NO COLLISION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE TALL C. PENS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
DANIELLE MAILLET CALIFORNIA
LINES OF JOHN FAMILY SERVICES
AND SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH DROP IN
CENTERS AND EDUCATION BASED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
HI AMANDA MCALLISTER BONNER
WITHOUT FOR MENTAL HEALTH AT
PRIDE TO CO SPONSOR MR KING'S --
PROPOSAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS FORGIVE SINS DROP IN
CENTERS A ISSUE.
THREE THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION SUPPORTING
THE MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
REDUCTION EFFORTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SHERRI DALY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONAL SUPPORTING ISSUE
NUMBER THREE GIPSON YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ADRIN SHELTON WITH THIS OF THE
CYBER INSTITUTE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR MR TING IS PROPOSAL
REGARDING I DISPARITIES
REDUCTION EFFORTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY PLEASE TO
SUPPORT A TING AT SEA PENS
PROPOSAL ON DISPARITIES
REDUCTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
FLOWS ON CO FOR WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEAMS PROPOSAL IS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY DAD BUT AS WITH THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP A PROUD
TO SUPPORT DISPARITIES
PRODUCTION EFFORTS AS WELL AS
EDUCATION BASED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HOLY MICHON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLYMAN GIBSON'S PROPOSAL
AND DROP IN CENTERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ERIN FOX LOS ANGELES LGBT CENTER
IN SUPPORT OF CHAIRMAN KINGS
PROPOSAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER ONE HAS
BEEN COMPLETED.
LET'S GO BACK TO ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO ANY MEMBERS PRESENT.
IS THERE SOMEBODY PRESENTING FOR
A MEMBER [inaudible]
ISSUE. FOUR FOR SIMPLY MEMBER
STONE JOURNEY HOUSE IS
PRESENTING.
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO ON BEHALF OF WHICH MEMBER
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMAN -- NIGERIAN.
SO I'LL QUALITY CARE.
YES IRON [inaudible]
OF THIS.
PROFESSOR CHARLENE HARRINGTON AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND WE'RE PROPOSING.
THE CAL QUALITY CARE WEBSITES
THAT WAS JUST SIGNED.
AT THE UNIVERSITY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION --
BE -- MOVED TO THE OFFICE OF THE
PATIENT ADVOCATE.
AND OF FUNDED OUT OF THE OPA
TRUST FUND.
AND I JUST WANT SAY OF THAT THIS
WEBSITE HAS A LOT OF IMPORTANT
BENEFITS.
BUT ALL NAME FIVE OF ONE IS SET
PRODUCES VALUABLE USER FRIENDLY
LONG TERM CARE INFORMATION.
ON AVAILABILITY QUALITY AND COST
FOR THE OVER TWO MILLION
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO USE LONG TERM CARE EVERY
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA?
IT ALSO GIVES PROVIDERS AN
INCENTIVE TO PROVIDE THE HIGHEST
QUALITY CARE.
AND THREE IT PROVIDES A VALUABLE
TOOL FOR DISCHARGE PLANNERS TO
HELP CONSUMERS SELECT THE
HIGHEST QUALITY CARE PROVIDERS.
AND IN THAT REGARD IT CAN HELP
WITH REDUCING LENGTH OF STAY.
AND REDUCING READMISSION RATES.
IT ALSO PRIOR PROVIDES VALUABLE
INFORMATION -- FOR HEALTH CARE
PLANS. TO HELP THEM IN SELECTING
LONG TERM CARE PROVIDERS.
AND OF IMPROVING THEIR HEALTH
PROVIDER NETWORKS SO -- WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT IT WOULD BE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS -- OUT
OF THE OPIATE TRUST FUND.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTING.
SEEING NONE I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION
.
WHAT IS YOUR?
FOR YES ON HEALTH MISTER STONE
UP YES VERY GOOD.
PROCEED ARE YOU READY HIGH UP
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JESSE
AGUILAR AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE ON FOSTER CARE JOURNEY HOUSE.
BUT WE ARE DIRECT SERVICE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA PURSUING HIGHER
EDUCATION.
WE APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP INCLUDING FIFTY
MILLION -- THE FIFTY MANY LONG
INVESTMENT IN THE EXPANSION OF
CALIFORNIA'S.
CRUCIAL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
PROVIDERS -- IT IS OUR HOPE THAT
THAT ARE PROPOSAL CAN BE
INCLUDED.
AS PART OF THE FINAL ALLOCATION
TO AUST PET MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS.
LOAN FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS ARE
EFFECTIVE AT RECRUITING AND
RETAINING PROFESSIONALS.
WITH PARTICIPANTS MORE LIKELY TO
WORK IN UNDERSERVED AREAS IN THE
LONG RUN.
CURRENTLY THE MENTAL HEALTH
PRACTITIONER EDUCATION FUND
PROVIDES LOAN REPAYMENTS OF UP
TO FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO
COMMIT TO SERVE.
IN A SHORTAGE AREA FOR AT LEAST
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY
SIX OH EIGHT LAST YEAR AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
THERE IS NOW AN ACCOUNT WITHIN
THE FUND YOUR MARK SPECIFICALLY
FOR MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH.
UPON APPROPRIATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
OUR REQUESTED A ALIGNS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S INTENT TO STRENGTHEN
THE STATE'S MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE.
BY STE PACIFIC A PROVIDING
FORMER FOSSE YOUTH.
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITIES TO JOIN
THE FIELD OF SOCIAL WORK.
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
WHO HAVE EARNED A GRADUATE
DEGREES IN SOCIAL WORK?
ARE UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO TRUST
THAN CALIFORNIA'S TROUBLE FOR
SYSTEM AND IMPROVE OUTCOMES
GIVEN THE PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
CLOSELY UNDERSTANDING THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND EMOTIONAL
REALITIES.
OF HAVING BEEN REMOVED FROM YOUR
FAMILY.
AND THEREFORE PROVIDE MOST
CULTURALLY COMPETENT SERVICES
POSSIBLE.
WHILE MANY CALIFORNIA FOSTER
THIS BAR TO GO TO COLLEGE JUST
MORE THAN 50%.
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL.
APPROXIMATELY 4% GRADUATE
COLLEGE.
WITH AN EVEN SMALLER PERCENTAGE
TO COMPLETE A MASTER'S REPEATS
THE PROGRAMS SUCH AS THESE
PROVIDE HOPE INCENTIVES.
AND A PIPELINE OF SUPPORT -- FOR
FROM THE SEES TO TRANSITION INTO
MEANINGFUL CAREERS IN A LIFE OF
SELF SUFFICIENCY.
LOW WAGES AND HIGH DEGREE COSTS
DISCOURAGE MANY PEOPLE FROM
ENTERING SOCIAL WORK WITH
TURNOVER RATES FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS UP 275%.
IN SOME CALIFORNIA COUNTIES.
WE URGE THE SUPPORTER OF THIS
SEVEN OF THIS SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
DOLLAR ALLOCATION.
INTO THE SUB FUND ESTABLISHED TO
SUPPORT FROM A PHARMACY.
IN CAREERS A SOCIAL WORKERS AND
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
CLEARLY THERE'S A SHORTAGE WE
DID HEAR TESTIMONY FROM SOME OF
THE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND THAT
HAVE ENTERED THIS.
FIELD I THINK THERE'S LOTS OF
GREAT HOPE IN THAT REGARD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
THANK YOU.
OTHERS PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF A
MEMBER.
ON ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE WHAT MEMBER YOU PRESENTING
ON BEHALF [inaudible]
DO [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TRUE [inaudible]
WAIT.
ALL RIGHTS ON ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
IS TONY GONZALEZ HERE.
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF MR
GIPSON.
IS THAT CORRECT.
MANAGER TONY GONZALEZ I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE A DOCTOR DIANE
NUGENT TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF
THIS ONLY MEMBER GIPSON.
VERY GOOD.
CHAIR WOMEN AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR HERE IN OUR DESCRIPTION OF
AB.
ELEVEN OH FIVE AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF OUR SICKLE CELL
COMMUNITY IN THE PAST -- TWENTY
THIRTY YEARS I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE LANCE JONES WHO'S
JOINING ME TODAY IS A PATIENT
ADULT PATIENT WITH SICKLE CELL
DISEASE.
AND I'M HERE TO SHARE WITH YOU
THE CRISIS TRULY A CRITICAL
CRISIS IT'S OCCURRING IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE AN EXCELLENT PROGRAM I'M
A PHYSICIAN WHO TAKES CARE OF
CHILDREN AND ADULTS WITH SICKLE
CELL.
AND WHAT WE SEE IN CALIFORNIA IS
AN EXCELLENT NEWBORN SCREENING
PROGRAM WE TAKE CARE OF OUR
CHILDREN.
UNTIL THEY BECOME ADULTS 95% OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH SICKLE CELL
REACH ADULTHOOD -- UNFORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS THE LAW
SHORTEST LIFE EXPECTANCY -- FOR
PATIENTS WITH SICKLE CELL
NATIONAL -- SICKLE CELL LIFE
EXPECTANCY IS SIXTY ONE YEARS.
IN THE UK AND EUROPE IT'S
SEVENTY THEY HAVE VERY SEVERE
DISEASE IN EUROPE IN CALIFORNIA
THIS YEAR THE AVERAGE IS.
FORTY THREE AND I'M HERE BECAUSE
AS A PERSON TAKING CARE OF
CHILDREN WITH SICKLE CELL TO SEE
OUR PATIENTS DYING. EIGHT NINE
TEN YEARS AFTER THEY LEAVE OUR
PEDIATRIC HOSPITALS IS TRULY A
TRAGEDY THERE ARE NONE PRATE
MAIN PROBLEM IS THAT THEY HAVE
NO ACCESS TO CARE.
THERE ARE NO ADULT CLINICS
AVAILABLE AND SO WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING WITH THIS BILL.
IS A THREE YEAR ALLOCATION OF
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO SET
UP A SPOKE AND HUB PROCESS.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS
WITH OUR PATIENTS BEING FOLLOWED
JUST IN THE E. R. OR IN THE
HOSPITAL WHICH MEANS THEY HAVE
NO CONTINUITY OF CARE THEY ARE
BEING MANAGED.
FOR THEIR CO MORBIDITIES THEY
ARE DYING BECAUSE HE OUR
PHYSICIANS AND HOSPITAL
INDIVIDUALS DON'T KNOW A
RECOGNZE THE EARLY SIGNS OF
DEATH.
IN SICKLE CELL.
ARE.
FUNDING WOULD -- DIVIDED IN FOUR
AREAS THE FIRST ISABEL UP -- AND
ADVANCED PRACTICE MODEL FOR
INDIVIDUALS ARE EXCELLENT NECK
WHEN NETWORK OF PRIMARY CARE AND
AND HOME TO ELEVATE THE PRACTICE.
IN THOSE IN THOSE AREAS WE'VE
BEEN -- TO INLAND EMPIRE INTO
KERN COUNTY AND THE LEADERS OF
THOSE HEALTH CARE -- NETWORKS
ARE REALLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS --
FOR A THREE YEAR ALLOCATION WILL
MAKE A DIFFERENCE OF THIRTY
YEARS IN THE LIFE EXPECTANCY OF
OUR PATIENTS.
IF THIS WERE A CANCER DRUG -- WE
WOULD BE JUMPING UP AND DOWN IT
AMOUNTS TO TEN CENTS PER PATIENT
OVER A PERIOD OF THIRTY YEARS.
BUILT INTO IT IS A LOT OF
TECHNOLOGY BEST PRACTICE ECHO
AND WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THE
COMMUNITY WHO SUPPORTED US MY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT WHEN I RANT.
WHAT THE STATISTICS WERE?
IRATE I HONESTLY COULD NOT
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA WAS SO
FAR BEHIND THAT WE WERE LETTING
OUR YEAH PATIENTS DIE DOCTOR
GILBERT IS ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
FANS SO WE'RE HOPING TO START
THIS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
FIRST AND FOREMOST THING CLEARLY
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S NEEDED I
KNOW A MISTER THURMOND WAS A
YEAH CHAMPION I APPRECIATE THE
MISTER GIBSON'S CHAMPION.
IN THIS ISSUE AS WELL WE THANK
YOU ALL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
ON ISSUE SIX LEANDRO HARVEY
CLARK
.
AFTER NEARLY UNDER CLICK HARVEY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCIES AND WE'RE
PLEASED TO JOIN CB HD EIGHT
CHILDREN NOW AND LADY GAGA'S
BORN THIS WAY FOUNDATION TO CO
SPONSOR OF BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
ONE POINT SIX EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS.
THE PILOT YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
PER SE TRAININGS IN SCHOOLS IN
NORTHERN CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
SIMILAR TO CPR TRAINING YOU'VE
BEEN A HOPE FOR STATE IS A SIX
HOUR IN PERSON TRAINING DESIGNED
FOR ANYONE TO LEARN ABOUT MENTAL
ILLNESSES ADDICTIONS INCLUDING
RISK FACTORS AND WARNING SIGNS.
IT IS A LOW COST AND HIGH IMPACT
TRAINING AND THERE ARE OVER ONE
THOUSAND TRAINERS ALREADY
CERTIFIED IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA HAS IN FACT RECOGNIZE
THE IMPACT OF THIS PROGRAM WAS
THE RECIPIENT OF A TWO YEAR
SAMPLER GRANTED IMPLEMENTED IN
SCHOOLS.
THE OUTCOME WAS POSITIVE IN THIS
BUDGET REQUEST IS TO ALLOW FOR
THE EXPANSION OF THIS TRAINING.
MEMBERS NEARLY ONE IN THREE HIGH
SCHOOLERS REPORTED FEELING SAD
OR HOPELESS EVERY DAY FOR TWO OR
MORE WEEKS IN A ROW.
SUICIDE IS THE SECOND LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH FOR YOU FIFTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD YEARS
OLD AND THE THIRD LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH AMONG YOUTH AGE TEN TO
FOURTEEN YEARS OLD.
WE CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE ANYMORE
OF OUR CHILDREN OR TO SEND STAFF
INTO SCHOOLS WITHOUT TRAINING ON
HOW TO RECOGNIZE WHEN YOU THERE
IN CRISIS AND HOW TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM C. B. HDA IS
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ON HOW THE COUNTIES
WILL ALLOCATE THE FUNDS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING NOT I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
[inaudible]
MS EGGMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON IS THIS ON ISSUE
SIX AB FIVE SEVEN SEVEN EARLY
PSYCHOSIS FUNDING TO RE
DIRECTION THAT'S CORRECT ALL
RIGHT.
THIS IS -- THIS IS A WHAT ARE
START RACING GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S
NOT MIDDLE IT'S FOR MEN NEVER
LEARN HOLES PARDON.
POST PARTUM YES.
I THOUGHT YOU CALLING IT
SOMETHING DIFFERENT I WAS GOING
TO I THOUGHT IT WAS WRONG TO
DISAGREE WITH THE CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT -- AB FIVE
SEVEN SEVEN IS ONE OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS PRIORITY BILLS.
THIS SO CURRENTLY IF A WOMAN IS
ON MEDI CAL AND DELIVERS A BABY
THAT CHILD IS THEN -- ABLE TO
STAY ON MEDI CAL FOR TWO YEARS
POST WOMEN ARE ONLY ALLOWED TO
STAY ON FOR SIX MONTHS SO IF IT --
SIXTY DAYS SO IF THEY COME BACK
THEY HAVE A DIAGNOSIS CAUSE SOME
KIND OF MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER.
AND THEN MADE TO HAVE TO FIND
DIFFERENT PATHS IN ORDER TO GET
TREATMENT WE KNOW THAT THE BEST
WAY FOR CHILDREN TO BE HAPPY.
AND HEALTHY IS FOR THEIR PARENTS
TO BE HAPPY AND HEALTHY SO --
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES OR SOME
OF THE MOST DRAMATIC THINGS FOR
CHILDREN TO DEAL WITH OF THEIR
WORKERS BUT SHE AS YOUNG INFANTS.
TO THIS WITHIN -- PROVIDE UP TO
A YEAR OF MEDICAL FUNDING FOR
WOMEN WITH A POST PARTUM A
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTING.
YES MISTER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MS EGGMAN -- THIS IS
KIND OF A SEGUE FROM THE BILL
THAT I HAD LAST YEAR THEY
REQUIRED HOSPITALS TO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR POST PARTUM --
SCREENINGS AFTER OF THE PATIENT
WAS.
DISCHARGE SO.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU PICKING
UP THE BALL AND I'M.
HOPING OUR COLLEAGUES UNDERSTAND
HOW IMPERATIVE IT IS ONE HOW
MANY PEOPLE WE LOSE. TWO SUICIDE
AND THE LOSS OF MOTHERS HI TO
DEPRESSION POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION
SO.
YOU KNOW I'M GONNA BE FULLY
SUPPORT OF A YOU KNOW YOU NEED
ANY HELP FROM ME I'M ALL IN ON
THIS ONE THANK YOU MISTER
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
AFTERWARD I SUPPOSE SAID THANK
YOU FOR BRING THIS BOARD WE WERE
SUPPORTIVE IN -- WHEN YOU
BROUGHT THE IDEA THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND I CONTINUE TO BE
SUPPORTIVE FRIENDS HI JOHN THIS
THING?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ALL AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
[inaudible]
MISTER KALRA.
REVENUE MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT THIS BUDGET
QUEST FOR YOU TODAY.
I'M HERE TO RESPECTFULLY ACOSTA
BUDGET COMMITTEE INCLUDE IN THE
BUDGET A ONE TIME ALLOCATION OF
THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS. TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OVER A FOUR YEAR PERIOD.
TO INCREASE THIS IS A LIVING
WAIVER PROGRAM TO INCREMENTALLY
EXPAND EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED SLOTS BY MARCH FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THREE IT IS
ESTIMATED THIS STATEWIDE
EXPANSION WILL RESULT IN A NET
SAVINGS OF OVER FORTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE STATE.
THIS IS THE RIVER SYSTEM LIVING
WITH HER PROGRAM PROVIDES
CRITICAL COMMUNITY BASED
ALTERNATIVES TO INSTITUTIONAL.
TO INSTITUTIONALIZATION FOR
ELIGIBLE OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES I MEDIC HOW.
EXPANDING THIS PROGRAM IS ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO THE OLMSTEAD
DECISION.
BY AT THE UNNECESSARY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES IS A VIOLATION
OF AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES
ACT THERE BY ESTABLISHING THE
RIGHT OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES TO RECEIVE SERVICES
IN THE MOST INTEGRATED SETTING.
BY ALLOCATING THIS MONEY WE CAN
KEEP PACE WITH OUR GROWING AGING
POPULATION STATEWIDE THE OVER
FOUR THOUSAND ELIGIBLE ENROLLEES
ARE CURRENTLY WAITING FOR A SLOT.
BECAUSE THE AVERAGE ANNUAL
PARTICIPANT COST THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES A SOON TO BE
SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS WHILE
THE AVERAGE COST PROVIDING
WAIVER SERVICES AND COMMUNITY
SETTINGS.
IS SIXTEEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN DOLLARS THIS
INVESTMENT PRODUCED SIGNIFICANT
COST SAVINGS FOR THE STATE. TO
FURTHER ENSURE THIS IS LIVING
WAIVER PROGRAM RESULTS COSTUMES
THE STATE.
THE PROGRAM REQUIRE 60% OF NEW
ENROLLMENTS BE RESERVED FOR
INDIVIDUALS TRANSITIONING.
INSTITUTIONAL AND MORE COSTLY
SETTINGS.
THIS BUDGET REQUEST SUPPORTED BY
A VARIETY OF CONSUMER PROVIDER
GROUPS THAT SEE THE FULL
UNTAPPED POTENTIAL OF THE
PROGRAM INCLUDING SIX BEDS.
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM.
CALIFORNIA'S HIS LIVING
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION
LEADING EDGE CALIFORNIA AND
JUSTICE AN AGING.
THIS REQUEST IS JOINTLY BEING
REQUEST BY SENATOR DIED IN THE
SENATE AND I HOPE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
CAN APPROVED NECESSARY FUNDING
TO EXPAND THIS IS LIVING WITH
HER PROGRAM THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME CONSIDERATION ON THIS
IMPORTANT COST SAVING PROGRAM.
YES DOCTOR WOULD.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
COVER FOR YOUR CONTINUED --
EFFORTS IN THIS IN THIS REGARD
IT'S VERY RARE THAT WE SEE A
BUDGET I REQUEST COME FORWARD
THAT ASK FOR MONEY THAT WILL
LEAD TO A SIGNIFICANT NET
SAVINGS FOR US IN THE IN THE
FUTURE -- REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
NOT ONLY OBVIOUSLY IS IT WILL
LEAD TO A NET SAVINGS THE
INCREASED QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO WOULD NOW BE ABLE
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR A SYSTEM
LIVING VERSUS -- BEING
INSTITUTIONALIZED IN ANOTHER WAY
SO -- IT'S FIVE I FULLY SUPPORT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING I WISH WE
COULD TO EXPAND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S MORE PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT NEED IT THIS IS A GREAT
START AND ONCE AGAIN.
LIKE I SAID IT'S VERY RARE THAT
WE SEE SOMEONE COME FOR WITH THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT'S GOING TO
LEAD TO LET TO TO A SAVINGS BUT
ALSO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR PEOPLE -- WHO DO REALLY IN
MANY CASES DON'T NEED TO BE IN
THE SETTINGS AND I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH?
THANK YOU TALKED WITH YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
AND THE OTHER MEMBERS.
IS JOHN BATRES [inaudible]
PRESENT.
MISSION NUMBER.
SIX GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
JOHN BOWERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE CENTER.
OCT.
COLLABORATIVE PARTNER THAT CAN
YOU OFFER DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HERE TODAY WITH A
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR ASK FOR
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND. TO FUND
ACES SCREENING AND TRAINING.
THE ASSEMBLY TOOK THE LEAD IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHEN IT
PASSED ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY
WHICH CREATED A STATE WORKGROUP
ON TRAUMA SCREENING AND ASUS
SCREENING. FOR CHILDREN AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE CALENDAR
YEAR OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
DEPARTMENT CONVENED A VERY BROAD
STAKEHOLDER GROUP.
OF COUNTY MEDICAL MENTAL HEALTH
AND A STAKEHOLDER -- ADVOCATES
TO DISCUSS -- IS A SCREENING AND
HOW TO IDENTIFY GAPS AND FILL
THEM.
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSES FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING TO SUPPLEMENT --
SCREENINGS IN PEDIATRIC IN
PRIMARY CARE SETTINGS TO ALLOW
FOR TRAUMA SCREENINGS UTILIZING
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WORK
GROUP CREATED WE'RE HERE TODAY
TO ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY
CONTINUE THE GOOD WORK IT'S
ALREADY DONE.
AND SUPPORT THE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR -- GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
ALLOCATION TO PROVIDE FOR
PROVIDER TRAINING TO PEDIATRIC
IN PRIMARY CARE SETTINGS TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN HELP IDENTIFY --
ACES EARLY IN CHILDREN -- USE
BUS REFERRAL PRACTICES AND HELP
LINK -- THE CAUSES OF MANY OF
THE CONDITIONS THE CHILDREN ARE
EXPERIENCING IN CALIFORNIA -- TO
THE ROOTS AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING THAT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
IT'S RANDALL HAGER HAGER HERE.
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
YES MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RENTAL HAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION -- PRESENTING FOR
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN -- THIS IS A
BUDGET REQUEST FOR FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME STATE GENERAL
FUND -- IT'S A PROGRAM WITH THE
STIPULATION THAT THIS INCREMENT
BE USED EXCLUSIVELY FOR MEMORY
PAYMENTS FOR PSYCHIATRISTS.
THE SAMPLE DATA THAT LONGER
PAYMENT AS A TOOL IS A RECRUIT
RETAIN MECHANISM THAT REALLY
WORKS -- NEXT DECADE WE'RE GOING
TO BE FACING FORTY ONE PRESENTS
A FEWER PSYCHIATRISTS.
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO TRAIN THEM
DESPITE CAPACITY CONSTRAINTS IN
THE TRAINING SYSTEM.
WE NEED -- TO TO FACE THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF AGING OF PSYCHIATRISTS --
INCREASING POPULATION RISING
DEMAND FOR PSYCHIATRIC SERVICES
ALL KIND OF MIX.
AND WE NEED MORE PEOPLE TO
PRACTICE IN OUR PUBLIC COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM IT'S JUST
NOT AFFECT ON THE IT'S JUST A
FACT.
SO AGAIN SEIZE RISING COSTS AS
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE A VERY ROBUST INCENTIVE
TO GET PSYCHIATRIST NOT ONLY
INTO UNDERSERVED AREAS USING THE
ROBUST CONDITIONS OF THE PROP
FIFTY SIX PAPER REPAYMENT
PROGRAM.
BUT IT WILL ALSO ENCOURAGES --
MEDICAL STUDENTS TO GO INTO
PSYCHIATRY AND SIX AND SIX
PSYCHIATRIC TREE NEEDS TO
CONSIDER PUBLIC PSYCHIATRY AS A
AS A POSSIBLE SUBSPECIALTY.
SERVER THESE REASONS WE THINK
THIS WILL STRENGTHEN THE SIZE
THE DISTRIBUTION OF THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR WORK FOR US AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
VERY GOOD SING THAT I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
[inaudible]
SCARLETT HUGHES.
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO. TO NO NO OKAY.
YOU KNOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN RASKIN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M SCARLET
HUE.
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS GUARDIANS
AND CONSERVATORS.
IN COLLABORATION WITH C. SACK
SEIU AND THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH RECORDS ASSOCIATION WE
ARE ASKING THE STATE TO PARTNER
WITH COUNTIES IN PROVIDING
DESPERATELY NEEDED FUNDING. FOR
PA PEACHY PC'S BY ALLOCATING
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS AND
ONGOING STATE FUNDING TO AUGMENT
NOT SUPPLANT COUNTY FUNDING FOR
THESE SERVICES.
OUR MEMBERS ARE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE APPOINTED BY THE COURTS
TO ASSUME ALL THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS AND SEVERE
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS.
WHO'S RIGHT TO SELF
DETERMINATION HAS BEEN REMOVED
DESPITE THE VARIOUS MANDATES PUT
FORTH IN STATE LAW WE RECEIVED
NO DIRECT STATE FUNDING.
IN FACT AS NEAR AS WE CAN TELL
WE ARE THE ONLY MAJOR HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAM.
THAT DOES NOT RECEIVE ANY
DEDICATED STATE FUNDING OUR
SERVICES ARE FUNDED THROUGH
COUNTY JOURNAL FUNDS AND WE DO
NOT RECEIVE ANY DEDICATED
REALIGNMENT MONEY.
COUNTIES ARE SPENDING A HUNDRED
AND NINETY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR ON THE SERVICES AND STILL
OUR MEMBERS ARE STRUGGLING TO
MANAGE OVERWHELMING CASELOADS.
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE NOT IN A
POSITION TO TURN DOWN CASES OUT
WILL.
AS THE COURT OFTEN DICTATES WHEN
WE MUST ACT BASED ON RECENT
LEGISLATIVE MANDATES.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE TARGET
POPULATIONS WE SERVE HAVE GROWN
APPROXIMATELY 30% IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS.
THIS 30% INCREASE OF CASES IS
DUE TO CHANGES IN STATE LAWS AND
POLICIES WHICH HAS RESULTED IN A
DRAMATIC RISE IN REFERRALS.
AND IT INCREASE IN THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE CASES WE
RECEIVE.
THESE LEGISLATIVE CHANGES
INCLUDE THE OMNIBUS ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX AND RECENT
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES THE PENAL
CODE SECTION.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY AS THE
LEGISLATURE DEBATES FURTHER
REFORMS IN POLICIES TO DEAL WITH
THE GROWING NUMBERS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HOMELESS.
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL SEVERELY
COGNITIVELY IMPAIRED AND WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF SEVERE PHYSICAL AND
FINANCIAL ABUSE THE NEED FOR PHP
GPC SERVICES IS CERTAINLY
GROWING.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- QUIRK SILVA
.
YOU'RE PRESENTING ON UNDER IT
ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX ALMOST MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
SERVICES.
YES THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ARE ACTUALLY GOOD
ALMOST EVENING -- WOMAN MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND I'M OUT ACTUALLY THE SELECT
CHAIR OF THE CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS IN ORANGE COUNTY --
SO TODAY PRESENT -- IT THE
PROPOSAL THAT I BELIEVE IS ONE
OF TYPE OF PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
USE MANY COORDINATORS AN ORANGE
COUNTY TO TO REALLY ADDRESS WHAT
WE'VE SEEN AS A CRISIS.
AND WE'VE SEEN.
WITH THE POINT IN TIME COUNT
SEVEN THOUSAND ALMOST SEVEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN ORANGE COUNTY
THAT ARE HOMELESS.
WE'VE SEEN OVER THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE DIE ON THE STREETS OF
ORANGE COUNTY.
AND WE'VE BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL
JUDGE JUDGE DAVID CARTER CARTER
WHO HAS STEPPED UP IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND DONE WHAT OTHERS HAVE
NOT BEEN BOLD ENOUGH TO DO WHICH
IS BRING CITIES TO THE TABLE TO
ACTUALLY -- NOT ONLY PROVIDE
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND SHELTERS
LOOK TOWARDS A PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE PERMANENT SORT PORT OF
HOUSING.
BUT IN THE MEAN TIME THERE IS.
A MAJOR -- NEED TO LOOK AT USING
DATA AND YOU LOOK AT
COORDINATION SO WITH THIS I'D
LIKE TO PRESENT A REQUEST FOR
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION. TO ESTABLISH THE
ORANGE COUNTY CRISIS RESPONSE
NETWORK THAT PARTNERS WITH THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE STAR COUNTY
SUPERVISORS WHICH WE ARE GLAD
THAT THEY ARE AT THE TABLE.
AND WARNING TO WORK ON THIS CAL
OPTIMO WHICH IS OUR LARGEST --
MEDICAL -- PROVIDER FOR OUR MOST
AT NEED MINDO SEE WHICH IS A
COLLABORATION OF ALMOST A
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE
SAID THAT WE NEED TO SOLVE THIS
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
AND THE ORANGE COUNTY SERVICE
PROVIDERS WHICH WOULD CREATE A
REGIONAL NAVIGATION SYSTEM
FOCUSED ON DIVERSION.
EARLY INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION FOR AS I SAID ALMOST
SEVEN THOUSAND ORANGE COUNTY
HOMELESS.
AND THOUSANDS WHO ARE NEAR RISK
OF FALLING ONTO THE STREETS HAN
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW -- WE AND
HAS BEEN SAID BEFORE.
MANY ARE ONE PAYCHECK AWAY FROM.
BEING HOMELESS AND THOSE ARE
TYPICALLY SINGLE MOTHERS WITH.
CHILDREN.
THIS SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST WOULD RATE DOWN INTO
THIS METHOD NUMBER.
ONE ESTABLISH A REGIONAL
NAVIGATION AND CALL CENTER WITH
INTEGRATED DATA MANAGEMENT.
NOW WE KNOW THROUGHOUT COUNTIES
AND THROUGHOUT MANY SYSTEMS
WHERE THEY ARE HOSPITALS OR
PUBLIC SAFETY EVEN SCHOOLS THEY
ALL HAVE DATA BUT THEY'RE NOT
SPEAKING TO EACH OTHER.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF THERE IS -- IN
ON PUBLIC SAFETY A CALL FOR
SOMEONE THAT NEEDS SERVICES FIVE
OR SIX CALLS MAY HAVE TO BE MADE
TO FIND THE RIGHT PROVIDER OR TO
FIND EVEN IF THERE IS A BIT BAD.
SO REALLY FOCUSING ON HAVE A
NAVIGATION SET CENTER THAT IS
OPERATING -- BE ON REGULAR WORK
HOURS THAT WOULD BE -- WHAT
TIMES THAT WE KNOW THAT -- MANY
OF OUR THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE ACTUALLY
CALLING WHICH IS AFTER HOURS
EARLY EARLY IN THE MORNING AND
SOMETIMES THROUGH THE MIDNIGHT
HOURS.
A HIRD PARTY BEHAVIORAL PROGRAM
HEALTH ASSESSMENT ASSISTANT
PROGRAM SO AGAIN WORKING WITH
OUR COUNTY AND OUR MHS FUNDS BUT
ALSO OTHERS THAT CAN GET OUT. TO
WHERE WE KNOW HOMELESS.
PEOPLE ARE AT SOMETIMES PUBLIC
LIBRARY SOMETIMES PARKS
SOMETIMES IT IN HIDDEN PLACES
WHETHER THEY BE AN INDUSTRIAL
AREAS OTHER PLACES SO THAT --
THEY CAN ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
PLACE TO STAY WITHOUT BEING
ASKED TO BE MOVED TO MOVE ALONG.
AND THEN AGAIN -- WORKING ON THE
TWO ONE ONE PROGRAM THAT IS
ALREADY ESTABLISHED TO MAKE IT --
NOT ONLY A CONNECTION BUT SO
THAT THERE IS A PLACE THAT --
THEY CAN ACTUALLY GO -- TO SO
THIS TYPE OF PROJECT IS I I
DON'T THINK IT'S UNIQUE THERE'S
MANY MANY GOOD PROVIDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS.
BUT WHAT I DO THINK IS THIS IS
ACHIEVABLE IN THIS SENSE OF WE
KNOW THAT WE NEED ABOUT -- THREE
THOUSAND NEW TYPES OF HOUSING
AND BEING ABLE TO GET THEM IN
THE PIPELINE BEING ABLE TO GET
TO THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS -- READY FOR THAT
TYPE OF HOUSING THIS WOULD BE A
TWO YEAR PROGRAM.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MS QUIRK SILVA
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I DO WANT TO TELL YOU THAT YOUR
PRESENTATION CLEARLY IS VERY
WELL THOUGHT OUT.
THE COORDINATION THE NAVIGATION --
OFTENTIMES THE MONEY IS GIVEN
BECAUSE YOU'RE SUCH AN ISSUE IN
HOMELESSNESS -- LOTS OF MONEY IS
BEING GIVEN FOR THE ISSUE BUT IF
WE DON'T COORDINATE.
ALL THE SERVICES FOR THE PEOPLE
WERE TRYING TO HELP.
I THINK SOMETIMES THE MONEY IS
NOT USED IN THE BEST WAY
POSSIBLE.
I DO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND I WOULD JUST
ADD JUST THERE'S ALSO FROM A LOT
OF DUPLICATION WHEN YOU ACTUALLY
DRILL DOWN AND TRY.
TO LOOK AT WHERE WE CAN
ELIMINATE AND SAVE MONEY AND I
THINK IT IS THAT COORDINATION
THAT HAS TO BE DONE WHEN A
PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE USED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
UNDER ISSUES ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX TAYLOR EIGHTY H. C. CAMP
FIRE DAMAGE YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN I WILL -- TRY TO BE
BRIEF HERE -- BUT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE WERE ASKING FOR
A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE PEG
TAYLOR CENTER. FOR ADULT HEALTH
ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE IF THIS IS
AN BUTTE COUNTY -- IT'S IN A
VERY UNIQUE SITUATION POST
CAMPFIRE AS THEY'RE THE ONLY
PROVIDER.
OF ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE AND
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
AND ALL BUTTE COUNTY -- PARADISE
WAS KNOWN AS A RETIREMENT
COMMUNITY AND THEY LOST MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY BEDS.
AND HUNDREDS OF LONG TERM CARE
BEDS.
ALONG WITH ALL OF PARADISES
SUPPORTERS SERVICES FOR
CAREGIVERS AND FAMILIES THERE'S
A LARGE NEED FOR RESPITE CARE
AND DIRECT ASSISTANCE.
IN ORDER TO NAVIGATE THE
CAMPFIRE RECOVERY PROCESS.
TAYLOR CURRENTLY SIR IS FIFTY
FOUR VULNERABLE AT RISK ADULTS
WITH SERIOUS HEALTH CONDITIONS.
HOWEVER WITHOUT SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING THEIR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
FIRE IS IMPACTED.
OVER THE PRIOR CALENDAR YEAR
THERE'S BEEN A 45% INCREASE IN
REFERRALS TO THE CENTER.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE HIGH RISK
POPULATION AND THE DISASTER WILL
HAVE SERIOUS IMPACTS ON THEIR
HEALTH AND WELL BEING SUCH AS A
LOSS.
OF ESTABLISHED HEALTH CARE
ARRANGEMENTS AND INCREASED
MEDICAL ISSUES. FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS WOULD PROVIDE
FIFTY NEW PARTICIPANTS ACCESS TO
THE CENTER.
THIS REQUEST IS ALSO SUPPORTED
BY THE BUTTE COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND THE
ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THE SUPPORT REQUEST SAID ASK
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION WHEN IT
COMES TIME TO MAKE THE FINAL
BUDGET.
THANK YOU SHE GALLAGHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS PRESENT.
LET'S GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ALL OF THE MEMBER PRESENTATIONS.
SO IF YOU GIVE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
TELL ME WHICH ISSUE AND OR
MEMBER.
AND WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE PRESENTATION.
MADAM CHAIR AND OTHER MEMBERS
PAUL YODER -- ON BEHALF OF THE
VIEW COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
FOR THE ITEM THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER JUST BROUGHT UP
THE ITEM.
SIX THE PEG TAYLOR CENTER -- THE
BOARD HAS A SUPPORT POSITION US
CONSENT AGENDA TOMORROW MORNING
ANYTHING THIS LEGISLATURE CAN DO
TO HELP YOU COUNTY IS DEEPLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'M BOB PANZER OF IN FACT A BILL.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF IN A AB
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON A QUARTERBACK
GOOD AFTERNOON NICOLE DOLL SKI
ON BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE HEALTHY BRAIN INITIATIVE
ISSUE FIVE I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE GIVENS
WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA HERE TO SUPPORT A FEW
DIFFERENT ITEMS -- THE FIRST
THING THE HEALTHY BRAIN
INITIATIVE UNDER ISSUE.
FIVE THE MEDICAL BENEFITS FOR
POST PARTUM WHEN WOMEN IN THE
ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER EXPANSION
BOTH UNDER ISSUE SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LINDA MARTIN I'M
AN ADVOCATE WITH THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION I ADVOCATE FOR MY
FATHER IN LAW.
I WANT -- TO LET MY SUPPORT TO
THE HELP THE BRAIN INITIATIVE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SAM COUNTY I'M AN
ADVOCATE FOR THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION THAT I ALSO I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT.
THE TEN MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
FOR A ONE TIME BUDGET ALLOCATION
TO SUPPORT.
EARLY DETECTION TIMELY DIAGNOSIS
AND INITIATE THE HEALTHY BRAIN
INITIATIVE.
THANK YOU.
CAN I ASK THE REST OF YOU JUST.
COURT OR OPPOSE.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME IS
GIOVANNI DOOR SELL A FROM LOS
ANGELES WITH YOU TO MAKE YOUR
CONNECTION SUPPORTING THAT YOU
THREE INVESTMENT GRANT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CAROL SO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING IN SUPPORT
OF THE ALZHEIMER'S HEALTHY BRAIN
INITIATIVE WITH THE P. A. P. G.
P. C. ADDITIONAL FUNDING REQUEST
AND FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL WAS
ASSISTED LIVING FUNDING REQUEST.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON IN A WHILE HER
WELL WITH A OR P. WE STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THE CAL QUALITY CARE
WEBSITE ASK AS WELL AS THE
OUTSIDE MEMBERS HEALTHY BRAIN
INITIATIVE.
THANK YOU.
SET SHORT ON BEHALF OF LOMA
LINDA UNIVERSITY HEALTH AND
FAVOR OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER GET
SINCE PROPOSAL AROUND SICKLE
CELL DISEASE CLINICS.
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE ON ISSUE
FIVE THAT THE HEALTHY BRAIN
INITIATIVE IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF THE TRI COUNTY ON ISSUE --
SIX VENTURA COUNTY IS SUPPORTING
THE ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER
PROPOSAL AND ALSO -- THE PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC GUARDIAN
AND PUBLIC CONSERVATIVE PROPOSAL
IS BEING SUPPORTED BY THE BOARDS
OF SUPERVISORS OF LOS ANGELES
RIVERSIDE SANTA CLARA SANTA CRUZ
AND VENTURA COUNTIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MAYOR MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE SICKLE CELL PROPOSAL THE
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID PROPOSAL
AND A SCREENINGS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON FAIR IMITATING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES -- IN
SUPPORT OF TWO PROPOSALS UNDER
ISSUE FIVE THE HEALTHY BRAIN
ALZHEIMER'S INITIATIVE AND IN
ISSUE SIX THE PUBLIC GUARDIANS
PUBLIC OF CONSERVATISM PUBLIC%
ITS MINISTERS BUDGET ASK THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADRIAN SULTAN
WITH THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT OF TWO ITEMS UNDER ISSUE
SIX THE YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
FIRST A PROPOSAL.
AND THE PROP FIFTY SIX POSITION
LOWER PAYMENT PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
BARBARA GLAZER THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
TODAY OF THE COUNTY PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATOR PUBLIC GUARDIAN
FUNDING PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THREE ITEMS UNDER ISSUE --
SIX THE MEDI CAL BENEFITS FOR
POST PARTUM WOMEN WOMEN.
THE SIX MILLION DOLLAR --
FUNDING FOR THE FRIDAY NIGHT
LIFE PARTNERSHIP AND THE SPOUSE
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION OUR ON GOING
FUNDING FOR THE COUNTY PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATOR GUARDIAN AND
CONSERVATIVE FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SURE IT IS CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT OF
TWO ITEMS UNDER ISSUE SIX
ARAMBULA MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID
FOR YOUTH AND MATHIS FRIDAY
NIGHT LIFE PARTNERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR JIM COOPER
THE CALIFORNIA FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE
PARTNERSHIP ON BEHALF OF YOUNG
PEOPLE IN FIFTY COUNTIES WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT THE MENTAL
HEALTH FOR STATE.
AND THE FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE
PROGRAM TO SAVE MONEY IN ALL
AREAS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
KRISTIN CAME IN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT
DAY SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
FIVE THE ALZHEIMER'S.
HEALTHY BRAIN INITIATIVE IN THE
PIC TAYLOR ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE
BUDGET REQUEST AN ISSUE SIXTY
SYSTEMS LIVING WAIVER PROPOSAL
THANK YOU.
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE
PROPOSAL IN ISSUE FIVE THE AND
THE EPIDEMIC TASK FORCE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. THIRTY SIX ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT
UNDER ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLOOR
AS PRIMARY CARE STUDENT LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM AND UNDER
ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN'S
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH.
ITEM AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOODS --
ITEM FOR EACH CONSULS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LOAD UP ON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TELE HEALTH NETWORK --
CHIN THE CALIFORNIA TELE HEALTH
RESOURCE CENTER IN SUPPORT OF
DOCTOR WHAT'S HE COUNCIL
PROPOSED UNDER ISSUE.
SIX THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ARE BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN IS
DISTRICT -- NINE IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER SIX THAT DR AGNES
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH PROPOSAL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
ISSUE TO THE CAL QUALITY CARE --
WEBSITE AND ISSUE SIX THE
EXPANSION OF THE ASSISTED LIVING
WAIVER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ROBERT HARRIS ON THE HAVE AS
HERE YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLYMAN SANTIAGO SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS
CRITICAL IF YOU WANT TO ACTUALLY
SOLVE THE HOMELESS PROBLEM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF ANYONE WITH THAT THERE YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE CAL
QUALITY CARE DOT ORG PROPOSAL AS
WELL AS THE AS THE ASSISTED
LIVING PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I THINK EVENTS
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE'RE
PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR ON THE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
REQUEST FOR THE ASUS SCREENING
TRAINING.
ALSO UNDER ISSUE SIX WE SUPPORT
THE REQUEST FOR ON FUNDING FOR
THE PUBLIC ADMINISTRATOR
GUARDIAN CONSERVE OUR PROGRAMS.
THE PROPOSED EXTENSION OF MEDI
CAL -- BENEFITS TO POST PARTUM
WOMEN AND THE PROPOSED EXPANSION
OF THE ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING DANIELLE MAILLET
CALIFORNIA LINES OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES WERE IN SUPPORT
OF ECON SALT PROP SIXTY FOUR
ANNUAL SURVEYS.
MENTAL HEALTH PRACTITIONER
EDUCATION GRANTS FOR FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH THE ASUS SCREENING
A YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID
AND PROPERTIES EXPOSITION LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON AMANDA
MCALLISTER WONDER WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA OIL TO BE TWO Q.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
NETWORK OUR IN SUPPORT OF AT AND
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOOSE AND IN THE
EPIDEMIC TASK FORCE.
AND UNDER ISSUE NUMBER SIX AT
THE MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID
TRAINING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CORRECT PULSE FROM A HALF OF A
KELLY HEALTH IN THE CALIFORNIA
HIV ALLIANCE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
US AYE AMBER CHOOSE PROPOSAL TO
CREATE A STATEWIDE TASK FORCE ON
HIV HEPATITIS C. AND STDS.
THANK YOU.
AARON FOX LOS ANGELES LGBT
CENTER IN SUPPORT ISSUE -- FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE ENDING
THE EPIDEMIC TASK FORCE.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS STEVEN MARTIN I AM
A CANCER PATIENT ACTIVISTS
CURRENTLY SURVIVING CANCER I
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE ON
ISSUE FIVE ENDING THAT EPIDEMIC
TASK -- ATTACK ENDING THE
EPIDEMIC TASK FORCE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
AND ON MY SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION AND CALIFORNIA
HEPATITIS ALLIANCE ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOOSE ENDING THE
EPIDEMIC AND ALSO ALREADY HEARD
ISSUE THREE THE MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITY REDUCTION EFFORT.
THANK YOU.
LISTIA MCNEIL BLOCKADES
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOOSE -- TO ASK FOR THE
IN THE EPIDEMIC TASK FORCE.
THANK YOU.
KATHY MUSTER GROUPS IN CENTRAL
ACCESS HEALTH AND SUPPORTING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE AND THE
EPIDEMICS TASK FORCE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
JAMIE MARK IN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION AND ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON SICKLE CELL DISEASE
PROGRAM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO MAY HAVE OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE. FOR
FOR FOR MENTAL HEALTH
PRACTITIONER EDUCATION FUND
GRANTS FORMER FOSTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINDA TENER WHAT'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER TO THE OFFICE OF SAFE AND
HEALTHY HEALTHY COMMUNITIES.
AND ISSUE NUMBER SIX ON ASUS
SCREENING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY ON ISSUE FOR IN
SUPPORT OF THE STONE JOURNEY
HOUSE PROPOSAL FOR MENTAL HEALTH
GRANTS FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
UNDER ISSUE FIVE A GIPSON THE
SUPPORT.
FUNDING FOR SICKLE CELL CENTERS
OF EXCELLENCE -- AND UNDER ISSUE
SIX SUPPORT BOTH THAT THE A
SCREENING TRAUMA AS WELL AS THE
ASSISTANT LIVING WAIVER
EXTENSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALIENWARE CHILDREN NOW IT FIVE
PRO CO SPONSOR AND IN SUPPORT OF
THE YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH FIRST
AID.
ALONG WITH ASUS SCREENING THANKS
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN TO MORRIS
ON BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION PROUD SPONSORS OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EARLY MONTHS
HEALTHY BRAIN INITIATIVE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER GALLAGHER'S PEG TAYLOR
CENTER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
AS ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU -- FOR THINK THE
SPONSOR WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMóN.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AN ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF ISSUE SIX THE PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATOR GUARDIAN AND
CONSERVATORSHIP MONEY.
THANK YOU FOR COMING FROM SAN
BERNARDINO.
OR FOR REPRESENTING SAN
BERNADINO.
MY NAME IS LAMAR BANKS LOS
ANGELES HERE ON BEHALF OF YOU
MISS OUR CONNECTION AND I
SUPPORT THE YOUTH WE INVEST.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M TREASURED
HERE IS AND I AM HERE FROM USE
MENTION CONNECTION AND THEN
LATER AS WELL.
AND I'M IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
REINVESTMENT YOUTH PROGRAM THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARTY
ESTRADA FROM AN AGENCY CALLED
MID TOWN FAMILY SERVICES.
IN THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE REPRESENT A BUNCH OF
FOLKS ARE BEHIND US THAT SUPPORT.
OF THE YOU TO BERMAN DIVERGENT
DIVERGENT PROGRAM.
AND THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS AUDREY CONTRAST
MID TERM FAMILY SERVICES WE ARE
HURT TO SUPPORT -- I'M SENSORS
ON THE WRIST A WE ARE HERE HERE
SUPPORTING AS SOME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S.
CHOOSE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE I HOPE IT'S NOT YOUR LAST
TIME -- MY NAME IS SHANNON
WILLIAMS AND I'M AND FRIEND
MIDTOWN FAMILY SERVICES AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHEESE YOU HAVE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
HI MIKE THIS CAN CHAIR CENTER
FOR THE FROM THE MIDTOWN.
FAMILY SERVICE AND WE'RE HER
SUPPORT.
MEMBERS CHOOSE YOU YEAH THE HELP
[inaudible]
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
I'M SURE THE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT TO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOE LINCOLN TERRACE
AND I'M FROM MIDTOWN FAMILY
SERVICES.
WE ARE.
HERE TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
CHOOSE.
YOU YOU DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE YEAH.
HI MY OUR ALVAREZ WITH THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP UNDER
ISSUE TILL WE WE SUPPORT OFFICE
I HOP IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
UNDER ISSUE FOR THE JOURNEY
HOUSE PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH INTERESTED IN
BECOMING MENTAL HEALTH
PRACTITIONERS.
AND UNDER ISSUE SIX THE ASUS
SCREENING TRAINING AND DATA
COLLECTION MENTAL HEALTH FIRST
AID AND THE MEDICAL BENEFITS FOR
POST PARTUM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HOLY MEASUREMENT HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL DRUG PROGRAM EXECUTIVES
RE SUPPORT ISSUE -- FIVE AND THE
EPIDEMIC AND ISSUE SIX THE
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID AND
FRIDAY NIGHT LIFE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON VICTOR CHRISTY
WITH CALIFORNIA HELPLESS
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS -- IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE FIVE INDIA EPIDEMICS TASK
FORCE THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CHRISTIE FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD EVENING DEANGELO MAP WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES --
SUPPORTING ISSUE FIVE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT DIVERSION PROGRAM
AND ISSUE -- SIX ACES SCREENING
AND MENTAL HEALTH FIRST DAY.
THANK YOU.
I'M KATHY KELLY ON WITH --
DIRECTOR OF FAMILY CARE YOUR
RELIANCE ON THE NATIONAL CENTER
AND CARE GIVING I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE.
TO THE CAL CALL THE CARE DOT ORG
WEBSITE AND THE HEALTHY BRAIN
INITIATIVE ISSUE.
FIVE THANK YOU.
NANCY POWERS STONE I'M
REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTER SUPPORTING -- ISSUE TO
CAL QUALITY CARE WEBSITE AND AND
ISSUE FIVE THE HEALTHY BRAIN
INITIATIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JOHN BLUETOOTH HEALTH PROJECTS
SENATE IN THE DEL MAR CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTER HERE TO SUPPORT
CAL QUALITY OF CARE DOT ORG.
THE ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER AND
HEALTHY BRAIN INITIATIVE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
RANDALL HAGER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION WE'RE
HERE ON ISSUE SIX SUPPORTING THE
MEDI CAL BENEFITS FOR POST
PARTUM.
WOMEN FROM DOCTOR EGGMAN AS WELL
AS THE PUBLIC -- ADMINISTRATOR
GUARDIAN AND CONSERVATORSHIP
FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ON MEMBERS
PREP PROPOSALS.
SEEING NONE OF BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO STAKEHOLDERS I SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TRUE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SAM
MEMBERS FOR CONSIDERING THIS
PROPOSAL I AM SPEAKING ON AND
YOU THROUGH.
WHERE'S MY USUAL WHICH IN THE
OFFICES OF YOUTH DEVELOPMENT A
DIVERSION PILOT PROGRAM THAT'S
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M
ASKING FOR TEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THROUGH THE SEVEN ISSUES
STREET.
TWO FIVE LOCAL OFFICES OF USED
DEVELOPMENT AND ARE VERSION
CENTER TO PROVIDE USE WAS
SUPPORT.
PRIOR TO THAT AND INSTEAD OF
THEM ENTERING INTO THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THIS PROPOSAL IS TO FUND THE
BILL SB FOUR THIRTY THREE THAT
I'M WORKING WITH SENATOR BILL
MONNING TO PASS.
THE PILOT PROGRAM WILL FOCUS ON
COUNTIES KNOWN TO HELP HIGH USE
ARREST RATE AND ESPECIALLY HIGH
RATE OF DISPARITY WHEN IT COMES
TO A REST RATE. FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
IN AND GOES TO UNNECESSARY
CONTACT WAS A JUSTICE SYSTEM
ESPECIALLY OF SUCH A EARLY AGE
CAN CHANGE OF HOUSE OFF
SOMEONE'S
LIFE IN A VERY BAD WAY HAVING
THIS KIND OF RESOURCES LOCALLY
WERE REALLY HELP THE PROBLEM.
IN THE PILOT PROGRAM TAKE THE
MODEL FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND THAT -- HOPE WAS TO SKILLED
IT UP TO STATEWIDE OF THE
PROGRAM.
YEAH I KNOW I WILL ADD THE DEBT
THAT THE COST OF RUNNING THIS
PROGRAM -- WOULD IT WILL TAKE
JUST A FRACTION OF THE COST
READY YOU WILL TAKE TO
INCARCERATE.
AND PROSECUTE ON PEOPLE -- BUT
THIS IS OF ALL THIS IS ABOUT
MORE THAN JUST DOLLAR IS THIS --
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUE.
AND ALSO A POINT OUT THE CONTE
SO LIKE THAT WILL HAVE TO
PROVIDE MATCHING FUND UP 225%
OFF THE PART OF THE PROGRAM.
IS -- WAS SURE THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER [inaudible]
TO QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING THAT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION OR THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WILL MOVE NOW TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
SEVEN MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR TOBY
EWING ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSE
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION --
RECOGNIZING THAT OUR I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF -- THE COMMISSION IS
ASKING -- FOR THE FUNDING FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF PROPOSALS
THAT ARE VERY WELL OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS -- IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH THAT MY COMMENTS EARLIER IN
THE MEETING IN TERMS OF THE TWO
MEMBER PROPOSALS THAT WERE
PRESENTED.
THE COMMISSION IS SEEKING TO
MILLION DOLLARS WITH STAFF TO
SUPPORT OUR DATA AN OUTCOME
REPORTING WORK AGAIN THAT'S TO
EXTEND THE WORK THAT THE
COMMISSION HAS DONE.
OUR ARGUMENT IS THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO TELL TO THE PUBLIC AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHERS A LOT
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING AND OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
COMPONENT OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE VERY LIMITED KNOWLEDGE
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
OTHER THREE QUARTERS OF THE
DOLLARS AND OTHER ANY OTHER
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT ARE
FUNDED WITH THOSE DOLLARS.
CONSISTENT WITH THAT WE'RE
SEEKING FUNDING TO SUPPORT OUR
ABILITY TO FACILITATE HOW
COUNTIES INVEST THEIR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
INNOVATION FUNDING THROUGH THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
WERE -- ASKING FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDS TO SUPPORT OUR
ABILITY AGAIN TO HELP ENGAGE THE
COUNTIES AND CONNECT THEM WITH
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS ON TOPICS
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED THROUGH
OUR DATA AND ANALYSIS.
AND FUNDING TO SUPPORT WE CALL
FISCAL INCENTIVE DOLLARS WE'RE
ACTUALLY ASKING FOR HERE IS --
TO REPLACE FUNDS THAT WERE TAKEN
OUT OF THE TRIAGE FUNDING
PROGRAM LAST YEAR.
AND TO ALSO TO TO REPLACE THAT
MONEY TO MAKE IT MORE FLEXIBLE
CURRENTLY UNDER THAT PROGRAM
DOLLARS ARE ONLY AVAILABLE TO
COUNTIES.
LIMITED DEFINING PERSON NOW AND
FOCUS ON CRISIS AND WE'RE
SUGGESTING THAT IT'S IN THE
STATE'S INTEREST TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES FOR COUNTIES TO AMONG
OTHER THINGS FOCUS ON THINGS
LIKE SCHOOLMENTAL HEALTH.
OR IN SOME INSTANCES AS CAME UP
TODAY MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
POST PARTUM EPRESSION A NUMBER
OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU'VE JUST
HEARD OUR ISSUES THAT THE
COMMISSION WOULD LIKE.
TO INVEST IN IN SUPPORTING
COUNTIES IMPROVING THOSE
PROGRAMS.
WE SEE THOSE FOR INVESTMENTS AS
PART OF A PACKAGE WHERE WHERE
AGAIN LINKING OUR ABILITY TO
ANALYZE AND UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN TERMS THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM. TO OUR ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE COUNTIES IN
IMPROVING THAT SYSTEM OVER TIME.
HAPPY TO STOP THERE AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS OR MOVE ON TO THE
SECOND SET OF PROPOSALS ON THE
AGENDA.
AT YOUR DIRECTION.
MOVE ON TO THE TO THE SECOND SET
THANK LESS AND LESS AND PART OF
FINANCE REALLY WANTS TO COMMENT
ON THIS PART.
OKAY.
THANK YOU THE SECOND SET OF
PROPOSALS SO -- LAST YEAR THE
COMMISSION RECEIVED SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY DOLLARS IN OUR
BUDGET TO SUPPORT ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
INVESTMENT THE STATE HAS MADE
AROUND ADVOCACY WE MAKE THESE
FUNDS AVAILABLE TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO ADVOCATE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND STATEWIDE ON
ISSUES OF PRIMARY CONCERN TO
THESE POPULATIONS.
THE FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
VETERANS REDUCING THE HEALTH
DISPARITIES NO HEALTH CONSUMERS
CHILDREN TRANSITION H. YOUTH AND
OTHERS.
THIS YEAR AS WE WENT OUT AND
LISTEN ACROSS THE STATE TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF REFUGEES
AND IMMIGRANTS IT BECAME VERY
APPARENT.
THAT THE NEEDS ARE TREMENDOUS
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE POLITICAL
CLIMATE NEAR OUR BORDER AND AND
AND AND COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE'VE MADE THOSE FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO FIVE ORGANIZATIONS
ONE REPRESENTING EACH REGION OF
THE STATE.
BUT THAT THE IN THE
CONVERSATIONS WE PROBABLY HAD
THREE HUNDRED TO FOUR HUNDRED
PEOPLE COME AND TALK TO THE
COMMISSION ABOUT TREMENDOUS
UNMET NEEDS.
BECAUSE OF THAT ISSUE AND
RECOGNIZING THE CULTURAL --
DIVERSITY AMONG THE IMMIGRANT
REFUGEE POPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA THE COMMISSION IS
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING SO
WE CAN AND STANDING STAND THOSE
DOLLARS TO MORE ORGANIZATIONS
DOING THIS WORK AND SUPPORT AN
ORGANIZATION TO PROVIDE STATE
LEVEL SUPPORT. FOR THOSE EFFORTS.
I ITEM BE AN ADDITIONAL
PROPOSALS CURRENTLY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THERE IS A
PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT EARLY
PSYCHOSIS FUNDING TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WOULD
PROVIDE GRANTS TO THE COUNTIES.
THAT'S A PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO PUT THOSE
FUNDS INTO THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES LAST YEAR THE
COMMISSION LAUNCHED AN EARLY
PSYCHOSIS PROGRAM UNDER THE
UNDER LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION.
AND WE'RE SUGGESTING THAT EITHER
SHIFT THOSE DOLLARS INTO THE
PROGRAM THAT THE COMMISSION HAS
LAUNCHED OR SHIFT.
THAT WOULD BE OUR IDEAL ASK BUT
IF THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE'S NOT INTERESTED IN
THAT THAN TO SHIFT THE PROGRAM
TO THE HOME HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
IT'S INCONSISTENT WITH THE
PUBLIC'S UNDERSTANDING OF THE
ROLE OF THE STATE TO HAVE A
PROGRAM AT THE COMMISSION THAT
DESIGNED FUNDED ON A PROGRAM OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
AND FINDING IT DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WITHOUT A PROGRAM.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE LIMITED
RESOURCES AND AND ENGAGE UCSF UC
SAN FRANCISCO YOU SEE -- LA AND
UC DAVIS TO CREATE A LEARNING
COLLABORATIVE AROUND EARLY
PSYCHOSIS PROGRAMS THAT'S BEEN
ABLE TO GENERATE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF STATE DOLLARS ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO
BRING TOGETHER ABOUT EIGHT AND A
HALF MILLION OF COUNTY FUNDS AN
ADDITIONAL MILLION AND A HALF OF
PHILANTHROPY AND ARE WORKING TO
SECURE AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF FEDERAL MONEY.
OUR ASK IS THAT THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS BE INVESTED IN
THAT EXISTING PROGRAM SO THAT WE
CAN STRENGTHEN THE NUMBER OF
COUNTIES THAT ARE ACTUALLY
DELIVERING EARLY PSYCHOSIS CARE
AN EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES.
OUR THIRD REQUEST IS ABOUT SIX
AND A THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL STAFFING TO
DO THE WORK THAT WE WERE
DIRECTED TO DO UNDER SB TEN OH
FOUR WHICH IS TO PUT TOGETHER A
STRATEGIC INITIATIVE AROUND
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
STATE.
SO AGAIN THE ANALYSIS RIGHT TO
THE VERY NICELY IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
THESE PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HELLO.
SPRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
I KNOW THE TO ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE'RE HEARING A LOT ABOUT
IS ACCESS. TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND THE WAIT TIME -- IN
COLLECTING DATA -- AS YOU'VE
TALKED ABOUT BEGINNING IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO HELP
YOU WITH -- FINDING OUT BETTER
WAYS TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
ABSOLUTELY SO THE COMMISSION HAS
REGULATORY AUTHORITY OVER
INNOVATION PROGRAMS AND P. E. I.
FIND PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION
FUNDED PROGRAMS.
AS PART OF THAT EFFORT WE'VE
REQUIRED EVERY PROGRAM TO REPORT
TO THE STATE DETAILED
INFORMATION ON WHO IS SERVED BY
RACE ETHNICITY LANGUAGE SPOKEN
VETERAN STATUS DISABILITY STATUS
WE'VE ALSO REQUIRED A REPORT ON
SOMETHING CALLED THE DURATION OF
UNTREATED MENTAL ILLNESS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT HASN'T
BEEN DOCUMENTED IN THE PAST AND
THERE'S SOME CONTROVERSY THERE
BUT HOW WE WOULD MEASURE THAT.
THE COMMISSION'S ARGUMENT IS
THAT WE NEED TO GET A HANDLE ON
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE EVEN IF THE
DATA ARE NEW AND AND AS THAT AND
THAT'S SERVICE OF THE QUALITY OF
THAT DATA EMERGES.
WE HAVE AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
WE BUILT A WEBSITE.
THAT ALLOWS ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC TO ACCESS INFORMATION ON
ABOUT TWENTY TWO HUNDRED M. TO
SAY FUNDED PROGRAMS OVER TIME AS
COUNTY SUBMIT INFORMATION ON WHO
THEY ACTUALLY SERVE.
INCLUDING TIME TO SERVICE WILL
ADD THAT INFORMATION INTO THAT
WEBSITE OUR INTENT IS AS WE
SUPPORT A COMMUNITY PLANNING
PROCESS.
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS MEDIA
POLICYMAKERS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT PROGRAMS ARE
AVAILABLE.
WHO WAS ACTUALLY BEING SERVED
AND THE OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE
SEEING INCLUDING THE ABILITY TO
TALK ABOUT ACCESS TO CARE IN
TIME TO CARE SO THIS IS THIS IS
REALLY AN?
EMERGING STRATEGY WE'VE WE'VE
LAID THE FOUNDATION FOR THAT
THIS FULL PROPOSAL IN THE
INCLUDING THAT THEIR ABILITY TO
ACCESS MORE DATA TO LINK DATA TO
MAKE THAT AVAILABLE IS SO WE CAN
EXPAND UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THOSE OUTCOMES MIGHT LOOK LIKE.
THE LAW PRIORITIZES REDUCING
SCHOOL FAILURE REDUCING
UNEMPLOYMENT REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS SO WE'RE WORKING TO
BE ABLE TO GIVE YOU AND THE
PUBLIC THAT INFORMATION ON A
COUNTY BY COUNTY BASIS.
IT'S NOT GOING TO ALLOW YOU TO
SAY MY LOVED ONE VISITED THIS
PROGRAM AND THEY GOT THIS
INDIVIDUAL OUTCOME IT'S INTENDED
TO HAVE TO FACILITATE A
DISCUSSION WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
THE COMMUNITY LEVEL.
SO THAT SUPER BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CAN ENGAGE AROUND ARE THE
DOLLARS BEING WELL SPENT.
ARE THEY PRIORITIZED IN WAYS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO ME.
ARE WE CREATING MORE DISPARITIES
OR REDUCING DISPARITIES THUS THE
THE NEED FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WE TALKED ABOUT.
THEIR NUMBER OF CHALLENGES IN
THERE THE DEMOGRAPHIC REPORTING
ONLY APPLIES TO P. E. I.
INNOVATION PROGRAMS.
THE REST OF THE PROGRAM'S FALL
INTO THE REGULATORY AUTHORITY OF
THE DEPARTMENT AND WE'RE WORKING
AND URGING THE DEPARTMENT TO
ADOPT REGULATIONS THAT ARE
PARALLEL TO WHAT THE COMMISSION
HAS IN PLACE.
AGAIN SO THAT WE CAN TELL YOU A
MORE COMPLETE PICTURE.
OF WHO IS BEING SERVED ACCESS TO
CARE AND THE OUTCOMES ACHIEVED.
IF YOU'RE SPECIFICALLY AND
ACCESS TO CARE.
ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT
TAKES.
FOR THERE'S SOMEONE WITH.
MENTAL ISSUES ARE REQUIRING
MENTAL HEALTH.
TREATMENT.
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT IT TAKES
FOR THAT PERSON TO BE SEEN OR TO
BE REFERRED TO THE THE NEXT
APPOINTMENT TO TO BE SEEN.
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT IS GOING
TO BE REVIEWED IN THIS STUDY --
THE AS AS IT IS PROPOSED NOW THE
INTENT IS TO UNDERSTAND THE
OUTCOMES SO THAT WE CAN THEN
INVEST MORE EVALUATION BECAUSE
THE FOCUS OUR RESEARCH AND
EVALUATION DOLLARS INCLUDING THE
ABILITY TO LOOK AT THAT ISSUE.
THE SCALE OF THAT PROBLEM IS
BEYOND THE RESOURCES THAT WERE
ASKING FOR TODAY THE RESOURCE
ADDRESSING FOR TODAY -- REALLY
HELP US UNDERSTAND WHERE WE
SHOULD LOOK IN TERMS OF THOSE
ISSUES FOR EXAMPLE WE RECENTLY
RELEASED INFORMATION ON OUTCOMES
ASSOCIATE WITH PEOPLE AND FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS AND THE
DATA ARE SUGGESTING THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF CHALLENGES IN THAT
PROGRAM.
IN RESPONSE WE'RE BRINGING
TOGETHER ABOUT FIFTEEN COUNTIES
TO LOOK AT THEIR INDIVIDUAL DATA
AND TO STRENGTHEN THEIR ABILITY
TO IMPLEMENTED ADMINISTER THESE
PROGRAMS INCLUDED IN THAT.
WOULD BE THINGS LIKE -- DELAYS
IN ACCESSING CARE BUT IT IT'S
THE REASON IT'S CHALLENGING IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE FIVE THOUSAND
SOME ODD PROGRAMS AND THEY'RE
ALL VERY DIFFERENT IT'S IT'S
VERY HARD TO LOOK AT THAT
STATEWIDE.
IT'S THE INTENT OF UNDERSTANDING
WHERE THERE ARE CHALLENGES AND
THEN BEING ABLE TO DRILL DOWN IT
ISSUES SUCH AS ACCESS AND TIME
TO ACCESS.
I I HOPE THAT THERE WILL BE
SOMETHING THAT THE IT IS AN
ISSUE THAT COMES UP OFTEN IN
DISCUSSIONS -- THIS ACCESS OR
LACK OF ACCESS TIMELY ACCESS
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE'S A CRISIS --
OR WIND EVEN WHEN IT'S
DEPRESSION DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE
A CRISIS SO THIS PERIOD OF TIME
FROM WHEN THEY COME IN TO
REQUEST TREATMENT AND THE TIME
THEY ACTUALLY GET THE REFERRAL
ACTUALLY GET THE TREATMENT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT THANK THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
A QUICK BEFORE YOU LEAVE.
LET'S OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE.
ISSUE NUMBER
.
SEVEN GOOD AFTERNOON ADRIN
SULTAN WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE -- VOICE IN OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE COMMISSION'S
PROPOSALS PARTICULARLY IN THE
AREA OF THE EARLY PSYCHOSIS WORK
WITH ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN AND ALSO WITH
THE SB -- TEN FOR PREVENTION
EARLY INTERVENTION
IMPLEMENTATION IS REALLY ARE
ESSENTIAL STRATEGIES TO
TRANSFORM OUR SYSTEM OF CARE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT OF
THE COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATION
ON FUNDING FOR IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES AS WELL AS EARLY CYCLES
FUNDING THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON AMANDA
MCALLISTER WILDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LGBT Q. HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES NETWORK -- IN
SUPPORT OF THE COMMISSION'S
PROPOSAL ON IMMIGRANT REFUGEE
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
HI MY ROW OVER AS WITH THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT OF THE COMMISSION'S
PROPOSAL FOR IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE.
THANK YOU.
IRVING ALVAREZ YOU'VE JUSTICE
COALITION I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
YOU COULD JUST AS THE I MEAN
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT.
INITIATIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS WILL IT BUT AS THE
CZECHO AND I'M FROM THE FRONT
AND THEN YOU'RE TO TAUGHT IN
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT THE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT AND DIVERSION
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS A STONE
PROCEDURE GO AND GET JOHN GO TO
WHICH ALL AND ON SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT AND IN SAY THAT
RIGHT.
YOU SAID IT PERFECTLY WELL THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE.
DR MAKAMBA WALK FAR FROM THE
FRONT AND DANIEL TO TAVIA BEEN A
MISSION INDIANS FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOOSE YOUR DEVELOPMENT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL HARRIS NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW IN SUPPORT OF THE
YOUTH THE VERSION AND
DEVELOPMENT PILOT PROGRAM THANK.
ERICA FRIEDMAN NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE OFFICE FOR YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
AND VERSION PROGRAM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I LEARNED MY STRIP NATIONA
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW AND SUPPORT
OF THE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT A
DIVERSION PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I I WILL SAY THAT THIS
IS ANOTHER ANOTHER ISSUE HOWEVER
WE APPRECIATE THAT YOU WERE HERE
SO WE WILL WELCOME YOUR COMMENTS
I DO ASK THAT.
AFTER THIS WE'RE GOING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT AND COMMENTS
WILL ONLY BE ON ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT BUT BECAUSE YOU MISTER
OPPORTUNITY AFTER THE A MISTER
CHIU PRESENTED.
LET'S OF WILL HEAR YOUR COMMENTS.
MY LAUNDRY ROBLESS WHAT THE
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION AND THIS
IS ANOTHER BUDGET REQUEST THE
YOUTH EVER -- DEVELOPMENT
REQUEST ANOTHER QUESTION
ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY IN THE LONG
RUN SO STRONGLY SUPPORT SOMEBODY
WAS IMPACTED IF I HAD THESE
PROGRAM TO FOLLOW DIVERTED I
WOULD END UP WITH A FOUND
AMERICAN AND DEEPER INTO THE
SYSTEM SO THIS WILL ACTUALLY
SAVE MONEY IN THE LONG RUN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BROWN IS I'VE LEARNED STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT A DIVERSION PILOT
SITES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DARIA THE REASON DAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT AND DIVERSION BILL
BECAUSE KIDS DESERVE A SECOND
CHANCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
DOC MEGA FINDING IT ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT DIVERSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
LINDA TO NARROW IT TO THE
CALIFORNIA PAN AT THE COP THAT
WORK IN SUPPORT OF THE
STAKEHOLDER ADVOCACY FUNDING FOR
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS THOSE OF US OUT
AS PART OF THE WATCH THE CNN FOR
SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH.
DEVELOPMENT AND REIMBURSEMENT.
THANK YOU.
CREATE COMMENTS WITH THE YOUNG
WOMAN'S FREEDOM CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
A DIVERSION PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CAN MIGUEL ALSO WITH YOU JUST AS
COALITION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
DEVELOPMENT DIVERSION FINE THANK.
THANK YOU.
ANNA JOHNSON I WAS A TEACHER FOR
EIGHT YEARS AND HAD A ONE
SCHOOLS I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THESE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HELEN ROTH THOUSAND TEACHERS FOR
HEALTHY KIDS IN SUPPORT OF THE
COMMISSION PROPOSALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THAT CONCLUDES PUBLIC COMMENT --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT CALIFORNIA HEALTH
FACILITIES FINANCING AUTHORITY
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
AGAIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
[inaudible]
READING IS.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
MY NAME IS FRANK MORE AND I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH FACILITIES
FINANCING AUTHORITY OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS CHAPTER.
AND WITH ME I HAVE CAROLINE AND
WHICH ARE A WHO IS OUR GET THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR -- WE'VE
PRESENTED THIS ITEM IN MARCH --
INITIALLY -- WE PRESENT
BACKGROUND ON OUR CHILDREN IN
USE -- GRANT PROGRAM ANY
APPLICATIONS THAT WE HAD
RECEIVED FOR THAT PROGRAM -- FOR
YOUR REQUEST THE STAFF WE PULLED
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES TO SEE
WHY THEY DIDN'T THOSE IT DIDN'T
APPLY.
DO NOT APPLY AND RECEIVE BACK A
RESPONDENTS RATE RATE OF ABOUT
47% TO TWENTY SEVEN COUNTIES
RESPONDED TO OUR POLL.
ALMOST HALF OF THOSE RESPONDENTS
SAID THAT THE SHORT APPLICATION
PERIOD WAS AN IMPEDIMENT TO
APPLYING.
A 60% SAID THAT THE SHORT TIME
LINE TO EXPAND FUNDS WAS AN
IMPEDIMENT TO APPLYING TO OUR
PROGRAM.
AND ALMOST 70% SAID THAT LACK OF
GRANT WRITING STAFF ON HAND WAS
AN IMPEDIMENT TO APPLYING FOR
OUR A GRANT PROGRAM -- SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE IMPEDIMENTS
CAN BE ADDRESSED BY ALIGNING AND
EXTENDING THE FUNDING SOURCES
FOR THIS PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION 30% OF THE
RESPONDENTS SAID THAT LACK OF
FLEXIBILITY -- WAS A IMPEDIMENT
TO APPLYING SO WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT THIS CAN BE ADDRESSED BY
PROVIDING EXPLICIT BUDGET
LANGUAGE ALLOWING US.
TO PROVIDE GRANTS FOR ANY OF THE
FOR INTENDED USE IS -- FOR THIS
PROGRAM -- THE TREASURE CAME
BEFORE YOU LAST MONTH PRESENTED
SOME CONCEPTS -- AND WE HAVE PUT
THOSE CONCEPTS INTO BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE AND THAT IS WHAT YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU ON PAGE.
TWENTY I WOULD BE HAPPY.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE IN THAT LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU NOT.
NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT WITNESS.
NOTHING TO ADD ANYTHING HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS VERY GOOD.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT GOOD EVENING DANIEL A
CALIFORNIA LINES OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING FOR MAKE DATING ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN YOU OFFER THE MONEY AND
NOBODY APPLIES THIS PROBLEM?
IT IS AND WE BELIEVE THAT THESE
TEXAS WOULD BE ABLE TO HELP US
BETTER ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THOSE WHO ARE SENDING AN
APPLICATION I THINK SO TOO WITH
THE EXTENSION AND THE
FLEXIBILITY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION -- YES DOCTOR WOULD
THIS IS JUST A QUICK QUESTION
AND THAT'S YOU YOU MENTIONED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE -- IS THAT
A IS THAT A STATEWIDE ISSUE IS
THAT SMALLER COUNTIES RURAL
COUNTIES IN THEM.
DO YOU MEAN THE A LACK OF THE
GRANT WRITING.
YES IT'S A STATEWIDE ISSUE --
IT'S NOT JUST THE SMALL COUNTIES
AND ALSO THE LARGE COUNTIES
THERE ARE SO MANY PROGRAMS OUT
THERE THAT -- IN THE LARGE
COUNTIES DON'T HAVE THE STAFF ON
HAND -- TO APPLYING FOR
SPECIALLY FOR THE SMALLER
PROGRAMS WAS TRIPPING ON THE
IT'S WORTH THEIR WHILE THIS I'D
CONSIDERS TO BE ONE OF THE
SMALLER PROGRAMS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M RELATED THAT WHEN WE WORKED
ON THE THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE --
THE FOR THE FOR THE WILD FIRES.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP IS THE FACT THAT.
WE HAVE AN IDEA WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN THAT
CASE IT WAS VERY SPECIFIC TO THE
AREAS.
THAT WERE SUBJECT TO THE WILD
FIRES.
AND OFTENTIMES WE ASKING PEOPLE
TO APPLY BUT WE DO HAVE AN IDEA
WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE.
AND FINDING WAYS. TO TO PROVIDE
MORE THAN JUST A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BUT TOTO REALLY HELP
THEM.
BECAUSE THEY DO NEED THE FUNDING
THEY DO NEED TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES BUT AS YOU SAY THEY
DON'T HAVE THE GRANT WRITERS
THEY DON'T HAVE THE THE THE
TECHNICAL SAVVY TO TO KNOW.
HOW TO APPLY IT HOW IMPORTANT
THESE THESE -- THESE
APPLICATIONS ARE.
RESPONDING TO THE OUR PEACE.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT AT SOME POINT
IT'S JUST THAT IT WAS SO CLEAR
DURING OUR CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
THAT IT WAS.
WE NEED TO FIND A BETTER WAY.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE MONEY WENT
TO THOSE WHO MOST NEEDED IT NOT
THOSE WHO KNEW HOW TO APPLY FOR
THE FUNDS.
FIND THAT THAT IS A PROBLEM NOT
JUST HERE BUT IN SO MANY OTHER
PROGRAMS GREEN.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION.
BRINGSUS TO ISSUE NUMBER. NINE
TO ME THE CLINIC VISION
INTEGRATION PROJECT.
THE CALIFORNIA UP TO METRIC
ASSOCIATION.
THANK CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TERRY MCHALE WITH ERIN
READ NO SO SEE IT'S REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE AN AGING POPULATION -- WE
ARE -- SEVERAL YEARS AGO THIS
LEGISLATURE ALLOWED OPTOMETRY TO
EXPAND THEIR SCOPE TO DEAL WITH
GLAUCOMA ISSUES -- WE'RE
UNIQUELY SUITED TO DEAL WITH
RETINAL -- RETINOPATHY HER
DIABETIC RETINOPATHY -- WE'RE IN
A SITUATION WHERE THERE ARE MORE
OPTOMETRIST -- THAN OTHERS WHO
TREAT I DISEASES -- THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR THOSE OF US WERE
INTERESTED MAKING SURE THAT THE
VULNERABLE AND THE DISPOSSESSED
ARE GETTING MORE CARE.
THIS IS AN IDEAL -- A SITUATION
WE KNOW WHERE IT'S NEEDED WE
KNOW THE MONEY WILL BE USED WE
KNOW THAT PATIENTS WILL BE TAKEN
CARE OF SO WE'RE ASKING FOR THIS
ONE TIME TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND -- TO CREATE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS -- FOR THOSE
COMMUNITY CLINICS THAT ARE NOT
PRESENTLY OFFERING UP TO METRIC
CARE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE YES DOCTOR WOULD JUST
TAKE A LONGER.
JUST JUST A COMMENT TO SAY --
I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS I
THINK IT'S IT'S LONG OVERDUE AND
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
CLINICS IT JUST SIMPLY DON'T
HAVE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE SO THIS
IS A THIS IS I AM VERY SUPPORT
THIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOU SAYING IT BECAUSE
THE OTHER.
THING AS WE GET OLDER THE ONE
THING THAT DOES DROSS TO CARE IS
THE FACT THAT WE'RE LOSING OUR
VISION.
AND SO IT IT IT CREATES A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
REACHING THOSE WHO ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED.
I KNOW IN IN OUR DISTRICT WE
HAVE DONE SOME -- VISION
SCREENINGS -- THROUGHOUT THE
DISTRICT AND IT'S AMAZING HOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE COME OUT TO
THOSE AND WHAT A LIFE CHANGING
EXPERIENCE IT IS TO BE ABLE TO
SEE I THINK WE TAKE THAT FOR
GRANTED MANY TIMES BUT WE ARE
TRYING TO SUPPORT.
OUR WORK FORCE WERE TRYING TO
GET A BETTER EDUCATION QUALITY
OF LIFE THESE IT IS A BIG DEAL
AND SO I THINK YOU AND I I'M
VERY SUPPORTIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
PATTERSON I JUST WANT TO ECHO --
DOCTOR WOULD -- AND I APPRECIATE
IT AND I DO HOPE -- WILL ACT
FAVORABLY UPON THIS -- ONE THIS
ONE OF THOSE THAT I THINK HAS
REAL MERIT. FOR THE OBVIOUS
REASON STATE AND I JUST WANT TO
CHIME IN THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR ACRE
CENTER.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER --
NINE GOOD AFTERNOON VICTOR
CHRISTY WITH CALIFORNIA HELP
WITH ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS AND
WHEN SUPPORT OF THE COMMITTEE
CLINIC VISION INTEGRATION
PROJECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE NUMBER.
NINE VERY GOOD SEEING NONE LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER.
TEN CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
EXCHANGE COVERED TO CALIFORNIA.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AM J. D. AS HERE ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE HEALTH
CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION.
PLEASE TO SUPPORT OUR TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE REQUEST FOR COVER
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY ON THIS
SINGLE PREMIUM INVOICE AND
BRONZE HIGH DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH
PLANS.
ON THE SINGLE PREMIUM INVOICE
PROPOSAL THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES COVERAGE A
FULL RANGE OF MEDICALLY
NECESSARY SERVICES.
BUT A PENDING FEDERAL RULE BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES WOULD MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS TO COMPLY WITH AND THE
FEDERAL RULE.
THE RULE WOULD REQUIRE INSURERS
TO SAND AND CONSUMERS TO PAY TWO
ENTIRELY SEPARATE BILLS FOR THE
AMOUNT OF THE PREMIUM.
ADDITIONALLY THIS PURPOSE THIS
PROPOSED RULE CHANGE WOULD MAKE
IT DIFFICULT FOR HEALTH PLANS
AND INSURERS TO COMPLY WITH BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION.
AND ALSO THE PENDING FEDERAL
RULE WE ARE PROPOSING LANGUAGE
THAT SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT A
CONSUMER RECEIVED ONLY ONE
INVOICE AND SUBMITS ONE PAYMENT.
ON THE BRONZE H. D. H. P. OR
HIGH DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH PLAN FOR
YOUR VALUE THIS ISSUE CAME TO
THE ATTENTION OF ADVOCATES
HEALTH PLANS.
INSURERS AND COVERED CALIFORNIA
DURING THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
STANDARD BENEFIT DESIGN PRODUCTS
IN LATE TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOR PLAN
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY WHICH OPEN
ENROLLMENT STARTS THIS OCTOBER.
TWENTY NINETEEN THE IRS RULES
FOR SIX SETTING THE MAXIMUM OUT
OF POCKET LIMIT OR MOVE.
IS LOWER FOR BRONZE HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH PLANS THEN THE
RULES FOR THE MOVED FOR OTHER
EXCHANGE MEADOW HEALTH PLANS. TO
MEET THE IRS RULES FOR THESE
PRODUCTS THE LEGISLATURE WILL
NEED TO CHANGE STATE LAW IN
ORDER FOR THE CONTINUED OFFERING
OF SIXTY TWO POINT 2%.
AB BRONZE HIGH DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH
PLANS IN THE MARKET.
THERE ARE OVER TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WITH THIS TYPE OF
COVERAGE BECAUSE THE RULES APPLY
ON AND OFF EXCHANGE AND TO BOTH
THE INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
MARKETS.
THIS NARROW FIX IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE CONSUMERS CONTINUE TO
HAVE THIS TYPE OF COVERAGE.
IF THE LAW IS NOT UPDATED THEN
NEARLY A QUARTER OF A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE FORCED TO
CHOOSE AN ALTERNATIVE COVERAGE.
FOR BOTH ISSUES WE SEEK TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE BECAUSE IT IS
NURTURED URGENT ISSUE AND NEEDS
TO BE IN EFFECT BY JULY ONE
TWENTY NINETEEN SO THAT PLANS
AND INSURERS ARE ABLE TO SUBMIT
PRODUCTS. FOR REVIEW THIS JULY
TWENTY NINETEEN FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY PLAN RATE YEAR FOR THESE
REASONS WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
LET'S OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER ALI WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS AND WE SPOKE WE SUPPORT
BOTH OF THE PROPOSALS -- FOR
COVERED CALIFORNIA TO ALLOW --
FOR EASE OF ADMINISTRATION FOR
ONE INVOICE AND WANT PROCESSING
OF ONE PREMIUM PAYMENT -- ON THE
FIRST PROPOSAL THAN THIS THE
SECOND PROPOSALS WE AGREE WITH
THE ANALYSIS THAT THE JUST NEEDS
TO BE MADE -- FOR THE MOVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE ALSO SUPPORT
BOTH THAT PROPOSALS ON THAT THE
SINGLE PREMIUM INVOICE.
AS WELL AS THE HIGH DEDUCTIBLE
HEALTH PLAN ACTUARIAL VALUE
ALTHOUGH WE'RE NOT BIG FANS OF
BRONZE HIGH DEDUCTIBLE PLANS
THIS PROVIDES A MUCH NEEDED FIX --
FOR OVER A TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M NOT SURE IF THAT
WAS THE SUPPORTER OPPOSE.
WHERE WHERE IN SUPPORT THIS IS
THE BEST ALTERNATIVE?
I'M KIDDING.
YOU WERE CLEAR YOU WERE VERY
CLEAR.
IT'S JUST LATE.
YES SIR GOOD EVENING FELIX THE
WITH BLUE SHIELD CALIFORNIA.
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT WE DIDN'T
SUBMIT A FORMAL LETTER POSITION
BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF BOTH
PROPOSALS JUST DISCUSSED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ERIN FOX LOS ANGELES LGBT CENTER
IN SUPPORT OF BOLD PROPOSALS
THANK YOU THANK.
AMANDA MCALLISTER WONDER WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA LGBT Q. HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES NETWORK IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU.
DANIELLE MAILLET CALIFORNIA
LINES A CHILD FAMILY SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF SINGLE PREMIUM
INVOICES.
THANK YOU.
AND ONLY WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA
HEPATITIS ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT OF
BOTH PROPOSALS AND WE ECHO THE
CONCERNS ABOUT BRONZE PLANS.
YOU GOT THE MESSAGE DUE TO ALL
RIGHT.
BUT I BET YOU THOSE QUARTER
MILLION.
WILL ARE HAPPY THEY HAVE AT
LEAST THE BRONZE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
[inaudible]
ELEVEN ARE SPREAD.
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS SOCIAIS XIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MAYOR MARTIN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
I'M HERE TODAY TO REQUEST AN
AUGMENTATION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE FUNDING THE
SONG AROUND PROGRAM AT THIRTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
C. CJ'S RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OF
THIS APPROPRIATION BE INCREASED
TO THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR AND THAT AT LEAST THREE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF
THAT BE SET ASIDE. FOR PEDIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
AND THE SONG GRANT PROGRAM
PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAMS ARE
NOT CURRENTLY BEING FUNDED
EQUITABLY COMPARE TO OTHER TYPES
OF PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS.
THIRDS DUE TO A CHANGE TO THE
ALLOCATION CRITERIA FROM.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PRIOR TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS RECEIVED OVER 30% OF
THE FUNDING THAT WAS AVAILABLE
BUT IN THE MOST RECENT TWO
ALLOCATIONS AT A TIME WHEN THE
FUNDING HAS BEEN DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED.
PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAMS ARE
NOW RECEIVING LESS THAN 4% OF
THE FUNDING I HAVE SEEN NO
ACTUAL GAINS IN THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT THEY'RE RECEIVING.
WE'RE SEEKING TO ADDRESS THIS BY
ASKING THE LEGISLATORS
LEGISLATURE TO SET A SIDE
APPROXIMATELY 10% OF THE SONG
BROWN FUNDING GOING FORWARD
AFTER DOCTOR DEDUCTING FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND WE'RE
ASKING THAT THE EXTRA TWO
MILLION DOLLARS BE ALLOCATED.
SO THAT ARE. 10% DOESN'T TAKE
AWAY FROM ANYBODY WHO'S
BENEFITED FROM THE CHANGES TO
THE ALLOCATION FORMULA -- BUT I
JUST WANT TO CLOSE BY MENTIONING
TWO REASONS WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE REALLY DO INVEST IN
PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY IS AS A
STATE.
FIRST PEDIATRICIANS RECEIVE
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE TRAINING TIME
AND HOURS WITH CHILDREN AND
ADOLESCENTS AND ACUTE CARE
SETTINGS WHICH MEANS THEY CAN
HANDLE A LOT MORE ISSUES WITHOUT
HAVING TO RETURN REFER THOSE
CHILDREN NOT TO SPECIALISTS.
SO ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES THEY PROVIDE A VALUE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
ENOUGH OF THEM.
SECONDLY PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS RECEIVE SUBSTANTIALLY
LESS FEDERAL FUNDING THAN OTHER
TYPES OF RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WE DON'T SERVE ANY MONEY
ON MEDICARE.
MEDICARE FUNDS RESIDENCY SLOT OF
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL SEAT GME
FROM THE FEDERAL LEVEL ONLY
FUNDS ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A SLOT.
THAT LEAVES THE INSTITUTIONS
THAT PROVIDE THAT PROGRAM AND
THE STATE'S TO BACK FILL THAT
AND SO IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER THAT WE CONTINUE.
THAT COMMITMENT AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE HOPE YOU INCLUDE OUR
PROPOSAL IN THE BUDGET.
THANKS THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS --
MADAM CHAIR EXCUSE US IT IS LATE
WE JUMPED THE GUN WORDS WEREN'T
UP TO ITEMS FROM NOW.
ALL RIGHT.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS ON THIS FIRST
ITEM [inaudible]
YES.
PATTERSON.
AT THIS ONE UP.
IS IS IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
AND AN IMPORTANT TO US.
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA -- WE HAVE A
PREMIER BALLOT CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL AND I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF REPRESENTING IT BUT
I WAS.
TAKEN ABACK BY [inaudible]
HOW LITTLE?
GMAT IT.
THESE HOSPITALS ARE RECEIVING.
AND SO YOU KNOW WE DUG INTO IT
AND LOOKED AT IT AND ASK AS WAS.
PRESENT I I DON'T KNOW WHAT I
SHOULD.
PENSION.
INTENTION WAS BUT THE RESULT HAS
BEEN THIS ARE HORRIBLE A
SHORTFALL IN FUNDING THAT HAS.
REALLY UP. TO ME MAKES
ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE BECAUSE WE
HAVE SO MANY CHILDREN ON MEDI
CAL.
IS REALLY HAS TO BE SOMETHING OF
A HIGH PRIORITY I THINK SO I
THINK.
IT'S A REASONABLE REQUEST --
MAKES FUNDING FOR THE PEDIATRIC
SLOTS DISTRIBUTED EQUITABLY BUT
AT THE SAME TIME IT DOES NOT
TAKE AWAY FROM THOSE OTHER
PROGRAMS I THOUGHT THAT WAS AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT.
IN IT AS WELL SO I HOPE WE ACT
POSITIVELY ON THIS WHEN WE MAKE
THAT DECISION.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU.
YES DOCTOR WOULD JUST LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF FOR MISTER
PATTERSON THERE I THINK IT'S IT
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND I
THINK ABOUT ALMOST 60% OF OUR
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
MEDI CAL AND AND AND WE KNOW WE
ARE FACING -- A PRIMARY CARE
SHORTAGE -- PROVIDERS AND ONLY A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE LEGISLATURE
REALLY.
THINK ABOUT PEDIATRIC CARE AS
PRIDE AS PRIMARY CARE BUT IF IT
TRULY IS AND AND SO I I THINK
YOU FOR BRING THIS FORWARD AND
I'M.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THE NEXT ITEM THE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER WORKFORCE
FUNDING.
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS.
AUDIBLE CHAIR MEMBER SHEREE
DAILY WITH CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM
OBJECTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE LOST TWO
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED NINETY SIX
CALIFORNIANS TO OPIOID OVERDOSE.
ANOTHER FOUR THOUSAND PRESENTED
FOR OPIOID OVERDOSE IN OUR
EMERGENCY ROOMS.
IN ADDITION COCAINE AND
STIMULANTS DEATHS ARE AGAIN ON
THE RISE NATIONWIDE COCAINE
DEATHS INCREASED BY 52%.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND
SIXTEEN AND IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WE LOST TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE AMERICANS TO COCAINE
OVERDOSE THIS ALONE.
AND CALIFORNIA 8% OF OUR
CITIZENS MEET THE CRITERIA FOR
NEEDING A CITY SERVICES YET ONLY
ONE IN TEN RECEIVE SO SERVICES.
A MAJOR IMPACT TO THE ABILITY
SERVICES IS THE WORK FORCE.
WE HAVE AN ESTIMATED TWENTY
THOUSAND COUNSELORS TO SERVICE
THE NEEDS OF ADDICTION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THERE IS ZERO DOLLARS AT THIS
TIME FROM THE STATE ALLOCATED TO
FOR THIS WORKFORCE.
WE ARE PRECLUDED FROM.
THE I MIGHT JUST SAY WHAT FUNDS.
BECAUSE PROP -- SIXTY THREE HAS
PARAMETERS THAT ADDICTION
COUNSELORS CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN
THAT.
WORK FUNDING.
AND THERE'S ALSO REQUIREMENT
THAT SHOULD BE LICENSE WITH
WHICH THESE COUNSELORS NOT
LICENSED IN THE STATE SO THEY
CAN'T ACCESS THOSE FUNDS.
SO THIS BUDGET REQUEST IS A ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND ALLOTMENT AND IT
WOULD PROVIDE EDUCAIONAL
STIPENDS FROM THE MASTERS LEVEL
ALL THE WAY DOWN. TO THE
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION LEVEL.
IT WOULD REQUIRE THAT PROVIDE A
STATEWIDE NEEDS ASSESSMENT TO
SEE WHERE THE COUNSELORS ARE.
WHAT SKILL LEVELS THERE AT?
IT WOULD DO A SUNRISE REVIEW TO
DETERMINE IF THE CURRENT
REGULATORY FORMAT IS WORKING OR
IS NOT WORKING.
IT WOULD PROVIDE A STATEWIDE
MASS TRAINING SO THAT ALL
COUNSELORS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WE KNOW HOW TO USE PRESENT
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE SHOWN TO
HAVE THAT SEXY.
IT WOULD PROVIDE AN LGBT Q. TOOL
TO ASSIST ALL PROVIDERS OF
ADDICTION TREATMENT THE ABILITY
TO SEE IF THERE ORGANIZATIONS
ARE OF SHOULD BE TQ AFFIRMING OR
NOT AND HOW TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES.
AND LASTLY WOULD PROVIDE WAIVERS
FOR TEST PREPARATION TEST FEES
CERTIFICATION COSTS WHICH CAN
AMOUNT TO MORE THAN FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL.
WHO IN MOST CASES BEFORE
CERTIFICATION ARE WORKING AS
REGISTRANTS?
AND MAKING BARELY MINIMUM WAGE
SO THESE COSTS ARE INDEED A
BARRIER FOR THEM.
BECOMING CERTIFIED.
I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE
TO ALL OF THE LEGISLATORS WHO
ARE FOCUSED ON THE OPIOID CRISIS
IS HERE IN PARTICULAR FROM THE
DOCTOR WOULD FOR IS.
HIS HEARING ON THIS ISSUE THERE
IS WIDESPREAD CONSENSUS THE WORK
FORCE IS AN ISSUE AND AN
IMPEDIMENT. TO EXPANDING
TREATMENT PROCUREMENT OF USE AND
ABUSE OF OTHER DRUGS ASKING
POSITIVE CONSIDERATIONS I THANK
YOU QUESTIONS COMMENTS DR WOOD.
JUST JUST TO CLARIFY YOU LAID
OUT A VERY AMBITIOUS -- PROGRAM
THERE FOR ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS -- HOW MANY?
CAN YOU GIVE ME AN IDEA OF HOW
HOW MUCH YOU EXPECT AND HOPE THE
IMPACT THE WORKFORCE WITH THAT
THAT WE WERE HOPING THAT SO FOR
A VOCATIONAL SCHOOL EDUCATION TO
GET CERTIFIED THAT'S ABOUT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
FIFTEEN MONTH PROGRAM WE WERE
LOOKING INTO.
THOUSAND SCHOLARSHIPS FOR THAT
PROGRAM -- WE'RE LOOKING AT I
THINK IT'S TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR ALLOTMENT TO HELP PEOPLE
WITH THEIR TESTES ARE TAPPED
PROTEST PREPPY SNATCHERS CATION
FEES.
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
YOU SEE STUDY FOR THE SUNRISE
REVIEW ANOTHER HUNDRED THOUSAND
FOR THE NEEDS ASSESSMENT THAT
THE REST OF THE MONIES WOULD BE
FOR EDUCATION.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
HAPPY HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
REQUEST.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THE NEXT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA -- I'M SORRY BEFORE
WE TAKE THE NEXT ONE I SEE THAT
TO MY COLLEAGUE MISTER NAZARIAN
IS HERE.
MISTER IS AREA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND I KNOW YOU'RE
PROBABLY HAVE A VERY LONG NIGHT
AHEAD OR AT LEAST A LONG EVENING
AHEAD SO.
I'LL TRY.
TO GO THROUGH THESE TWO ITEMS AS
QUICKLY AS I CAN BUT I WANTED.
TO GIVE IT A FAIR HEARING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THAT
THANK YOU FOR STILL FOR ALLOWING
ME THE TIME TO SPEAK I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE ADOPT.
TEN MILLION DOLLARS AN ON GOING
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA.
PARKINSON'S DISEASE REGISTRY
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PARKINSON'S DISEASE IS A
CHRONIC DEGENERATIVE
NEUROLOGICAL DISORDER THAT
AFFECTS ONE IN EVERY ONE HUNDRED
PEOPLE OVER THE AGE OF SIXTEEN
THE REGISTRY WAS CREATED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WITH THREE
POINT SEVEN MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT. TO MEASURE IT THE
INCIDENCE AND PREVALENCE OF
PARKINSON'S DISEASE.
AND ULTIMATELY IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF THOSE AFFECTED.
UNFORTUNATELY FUNDING AND
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY FOR THE
REGISTRY EXPIRES THIS YEAR.
THERE HAVE ALREADY BEEN. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN PARKINSON'S DISEASE CASES.
SUBMITTED TO THE REGISTRY SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IN
ADDITION A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE INDIVIDUALS WITH
PARKINSON'S HAVE INDEPENDENTLY
REGISTER TO SUBMIT DATA TO THE
REGISTRY.
THESE FIGURES DO NOT EVEN
INCLUDE GROUPS AND HOSPITALS WHO
WILL BE REPORTING ON BEHALF OF
THEIR PHYSICIANS.
THOUSANDS OF CASES HAVE ALREADY
BEEN REPORTED TO THE REGISTRY
WITHIN THE LAST YEAR AND
THOUSANDS MORE ARE ARRIVING THIS
MONTH.
AS MEDICAL GROUPS AND HOSPITALS
BEGIN TO SUBMIT TEIR PATIENT
DATA.
SURPRISINGLY LITTLE IS KNOWN
ABOUT HOW PARKINSON'S DISEASE IS
DISTRIBUTED AMONG DIFFERENT
POPULATION GROUPS AND WHETHER
THE PATTERNS OF DISEASE ARE
CHANGING OVER TIME.
THIS RESEARCH HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO FURTHER.
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF PARKINSON'S
DISEASE INCLUDING ASSOCIATED
CAUSES AND RISK FACTORS.
THIS FUNDING REQUEST IS SIMILAR
TO THE FUNDING DPH RECEIVED TED
MINISTER ITS CANCER REGISTRY
WHICH IS NOW RECOGNIZED AS ONE
OF THE LEADING CANCER REGISTRIES
IN THE WORLD.
DUE TO THE SIZE AND DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION MORE CAN
BE KNOWN ABOUT THE OCCURRENCE OF
PARKINSON'S DISEASE AND DIVERSE
POPULATIONS.
THAN EVER BEFORE IF THIS
REGISTRY MAKE MEETS ITS FUNDING
NEEDS.
WHILE I'M THANKFUL FOR MICHAEL
J. FOX AND HIS FOUNDATIONS
COMMITMENT TO STATE LEVEL
RESEARCH ON PARKINSON'S DISEASE
INCLUDING AN INVESTMENT OF
ALMOST FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THIS
REGISTRY CANNOT RELY ON PRIVATE
PHILANTHROPY AND NEEDS ON GOING
STATE SUPPORT.
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN ADVANCE.
THAT WAS THE FIRST ITEM MADAM
CHAIR I CAN CONTINUE WITH THE
SECOND AYE YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THIS IS -- FOR TELL QUALITY WHAT
CARE WEBSITE.
I WILL TELL YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
THAT -- THERE WAS A PRESENTATION.
ON YOUR BEHALF -- AND IN THAT
PRESENTATION ALTHOUGH.
I I DO NOTE THAT -- OUR
DOCUMENTS SHOWED ONE MILLION THE
PRESENTATION IN THE PRESENTATION
THE AMOUNT OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WAS STATED [inaudible]
OKAY -- I'M I'M HAPPY TO JUST
LEAVE IT TO THE POINT WHERE THAT
AS AS CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON AGING AND LONG TERM
CARE -- AND AS A OF FELLOW
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE THE
USEFULNESS AND EFFECTIVE THIS
WEBSITE FOR AGING CALIFORNIANS
IS OF PARTICULAR INTEREST TO TO
ME AND I SIZE I KNOW TO YOU --
BECAUSE OF IT IF YOU'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY WITH THE
WEBSITE.
YOU'D SEE HOW USEFUL IT IS AND
THE SYSTEM IS ALREADY SET UP.
SO -- I THINK WE MAY HAVE ASKED
FOR A MILLION INSTEAD OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND SO THAT IF
THERE ARE ANY CHALLENGES OR ANY
ISSUES IN FULLY INTEGRATING THE
SYSTEM.
UNDER I BELIEVE -- DH CS IF I'M
NOT MISTAKEN I'M SAYING A
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY -- THAT THAT
THEY HAVE ENOUGH FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO TO SEE THROUGH AND
POTENTIALLY -- FOR MULTI YEARS
AS WELL SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION FOR THAT AS
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ON EITHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
RIGHT -- ALSO ON ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
OKAY.
I PROMISE WILL BE BACK.
TO NO IT I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WERE HERE AT THE VERY BEGINNING --
WE DID SAY THAT THE ONLY ONE
PERSON WOULD BE PRESENTING.
VERY GOOD.
YOU ARE HERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MARK PHùPART AND I'M A
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF POLICY ONLY
CAN COORDINATE THE ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR --
COALITION THAT -- INCLUDES OVER
TWO HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING TO TRANSFORM SYSTEMS
THAT FELL BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR
THEIR FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES --
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS
BUDGET REQUEST I'M HERE TO ASK
FOR SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR THE CREATION.
OF AN OFFICE OF HEALTHY AND SAFE
COMMUNITIES UNDER THE PURVIEW OF
THE SURGEON GENERAL.
THIS INVESTMENT WILL SUPPORT
CORPS STAFF TO CARRY OUT THE
FUNCTIONS OF THE OFFICE
INCLUDING THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
VISION AND STRATEGY AND
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN FOR VIOLENCE
PREVENTION THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WITH THIS REQUEST I'M MIX I'M
SEEKING TO ADVANCE A BOWL
PARADIGM SHIFT IN HOW WE DEAL
WITH VIOLENCE -- FROM POLICIES
THAT ARE MORE REACTIONARY BASE
TO ONES THAT ARE MORE FOCUSED ON
PREVENTION AND HEALING AND HOPE
AND PEACE.
THIS MODEST ONE TIME ALLOCATION
IS BOTH SOCIALLY AND FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE AS IS THIS NEW
OFFICE -- THIS OFFICE WILL WORK
TO ADVANCE COMMUNITY BASED
INTERVENTION STRATEGIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE RATHER THAN
HARMFUL AND EXPENSIVE MEASURES.
SUCH AS INVOLVING THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL AND CHILD WELFARE SYSTEMS.
FURTHERMORE COST SAVINGS COULD
BE EXPERIENCED THROUGH
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE OVERALL
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF FAMILY
AND COMMUNITY.
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT WILL BE
BOOSTED AS WELL AS EMPLOYMENT%
OPPORTUNITIES AND THEREFORE
ECONOMIC STABILITY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF VIOLENCE PREVENTION
IN THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET
REQUEST.
THIS OFFICE -- ONE OF THE GROUND
BREAKING -- INNOVATIONS
THROUGHOUT THIS -- STATE.
IS -- MIRRORED IN OTHER STATES
LIKE MASSACHUSETTS MARYLAND
WASHINGTON -- THE FUNCTIONS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE REALLY A
CENTRALIZED HUB FOR VIOLENCE
PREVENTION -- RIGHT NOW THESE
EFFORTS ARE DECENTRALIZED --
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS A PLAN
IN A STRATEGY THAT WOULD
CENTRALIZE THAT WORK AND ALLOW
FOR A MORE INTEGRATED SUPPORT OF
COMMUNITY SOLUTIONS THAT FOCUS
ON PREVENTION?
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
I THINK EVERYTHING THAT WE DO TO
DECRIMINALIZE.
AND AS YOU SAID TO BRING HOPE I
THINK IS ALWAYS A GOOD.
GOOD THING -- COMMENTS ON THE
TWO MEMBER PROPOSALS FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN AND THE
PROPOSAL ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
[inaudible]
SEC.
CAME IN DEAN OF ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AND POLICY
LINK PROUD CO SPONSORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
SIX FIVE SIX OR SEE ME THE
CORRESPONDING BUDGET REQUEST FOR
SIX MILLION.
THANK YOU.
DEANGELO MAC WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET MEASURE.
FOR THE OFFICE.
THANK YOU.
I THINK THERE ARE SOME BE HAVE A
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTING THE SIX
MILLION FOR THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTHY AND SAFE
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU.
HOWEVER AS WITH THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE OFFICE PREVENTIVE
COMMUNITIES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN THE DINNER WITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN I THINK HELP THE
ARC IN SUPPORT OF THE OFFICE OF
SAFE AND HEALTHY COMMUNITY
THINKING?
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
PUBLIC COMMENT VERY GOOD SEEING
NONE I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
NOW WE ARE BACK TO ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN THE THIRD PROPOSAL
PRIMARY CARE PSYCHIATRIC
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM SCHOLARSHIPS --
MADAM RENTAL HAGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION JUST HERE TO
INTRODUCE AS TWO POINT SIX FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSAL AND
ARE TESTIFYING.
HELLO MY NAME IS FORTY THREE
EMMA I'M A FAMILY NURSE
PRACTITIONER IN SACRAMENTO WHERE
I WORK WITH THE ELDERLY AND THE
HOMELESS.
IT RECENTLY GRADUATED FROM START
FROM ONE THE ONE YEAR YOU SEE I
YOU SEE DE TRAIN THE TRAINERS
PRIMARY CARE.
PSYCHIATRIC FELLOWSHIP OR TNT
PCP FELLOWSHIP WHERE I ALSO
TRAINED WITH POSITIONS IN P.
A.'S.
AS A PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER ON
THE FRONT LINES I
ENTHUSIASTICALLY ENDORSE THIS
INNOVATIVE PROGRAM AND THE
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO FURTHER EXPAND PSYCHIATRIC
WORK FORCE.
IN THE UNDERSERVED AREAS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA.
WELL OVER HALF OF THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DELIVERY TAKES PLACE IN
THE BUSY PRIMARY CARE SETTING
NOT BY PSYCHOLOGIST OR
PSYCHIATRIST I NEEDED THIS
FELLOWSHIP BECAUSE MY PRIMARY
CARE TRAINING INCLUDED VERY
LITTLE IN THE AREA OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE.
UNFORTUNATELY MOST PRIMARY CARE
TRAINING PROGRAMS TO HAVE
EXTREMELY LIMITED TRAINING AND
PRIMARY CARE PSYCHIATRY.
THIS TRAINING WAS VERY VALUABLE
TO ME.
DEPRESSION IS THE NUMBER ONE
CAUSE OF DISABILITY IN ALL AGE
GROUPS SUICIDE RATES OF INCREASE
BY ABOUT 25% IN THE LAST DECADE
WE JUST DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PSYCHIATRISTS AND THE SHORTAGES
CLEARLY PROJECTED TO GET WORSE
PARTICULARLY IN AREAS.
LIKE THE INLAND EMPIRE FRESNO
LOS ANGELES AND RULED.
COUNTIES THIS IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS IN OUR GREAT
STATE AND THIS TNT PROGRAM
SQUARELY IS ADDRESSING IT.
THEY TRAIN PROVIDERS AND TEACH
THEM HOW TO TRAIN OTHERS THEIR
RESEARCH OUTCOMES ARE IMPRESSIVE.
ONE THEY'VE INCREASED KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPERTISE IN PSYCHIATRIC.
PSYCHIATRY IN CHRONIC PAIN
MANAGEMENT DECREASE MENTAL
HEALTH RELATED STIGMA IMPROVED.
EARLY RECOGNITION AND DEPRESSION.
THEY'VE HELPED EARLY ABBOTT ARE
AT EARLY EVIDENCE HAS DECREASED
OPIOID PRESCRIPTION AMONG TNT
PCP GRADUATES AND INCREASED
CONFIDENCE IN TEACHING OTHER
PROVIDERS WITHIN THE REGION.
EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF TNT PCP
FELLOWS SHIPS AND TWO DAY
TRAINING SCHOLARSHIPS TO EVEN
MORE PROVIDERS INCLUDING PA N.
S. P.'S WILL MOST DEFINITELY
EXPAND AND IMPROVE PSYCHIATRIC
CARE FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
ARE GRADUATE STAY IN THEIR
UNDERSERVEDPRIMARY CARE
SETTINGS WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED
THE MOST THIS PROGRAM WORKS WE
CAN SUCCESSFULLY ADDRESS
PSYCHIATRIC WORK FOR SHORTAGE
AND EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
DEPRESSION SUBSTANCE DEPENDENCE.
OPIOID MISUSE AND MANY OTHER
COMMON HEALTH DISORDER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DISORDERS WITH
ON GOING AN INCREASE FUNDING
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE UC I UC DAVIS.
TRAIN THE TRAINERS PROGRAM AND
THE MANY PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS
WHO BENEFIT FROM THIS PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR WOULD.
JUST -- YOU SAID YOUR NEW YOUR
NURSE PRACTITIONER YES AND SO
YOU YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO TO
PRESCRIBE TO MEDICALLY ASSISTED
TREATMENT -- FOR OPIOIDS
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AS WELL -- IT'S
JUST A IT'S IT'S ACTUALLY A
PRETTY SMALL ASK REALLY IN THE
BIG PICTURE CONSIDERING THE HUGE
NEEDS WE HAVE FOR PSYCHIATRY
PSYCHIATRIC CARE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
I RECALL IN ONE OF THE EARLIER
HEARINGS WE WE TALKED ABOUT.
THE LACK OF PSYCHIATRISTS AND
STATE HOSPITALS I THINK WHAT
FORTY PLUS PERCENT -- VACANCY
RATES AND AND OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT ISSUE BUT
ONCE AGAIN IT JUST HIGHLIGHTS
CONTINUES TO HIGHLIGHTS THE HUGE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE WITH
WORKFORCE.
AND THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH CARE FOR PEOPLE IN
YOUR REQUEST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
WORKFORCE EDUCATIONAL TRAINING
TRUST FUND.
YOU'RE GOING TO PICK WHO'S GOING
TO SPEAK.
GOOD EVENING I'M DOCTOR LANDER
CLERK HERBIE THE DIRECTOR POLICY
AND LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS AT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES.
TOGETHER WITH OUR CO SPONSORS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PLANNING COUNCIL AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST --
WE REQUEST SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE WORK FORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING TRUST
FUND TO FUND ALSO PUTS FIVE YEAR
WORK FORCE PLAN.
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH WORKFORCE CRISIS IN OUR
STATE WE'VE HEARD PLENTY ABOUT
IT TONIGHT AND IN IN PRIOR
HEARINGS ALL SPORTS PLAN LAYS
THE FRAMEWORK TO SOLVING THIS
CRISIS BUT THERE'S NO ONGOING
FUNDING DEDICATED TO THE PLAN.
FUNDING WILL ALLOW FOR
STRENGTHENING THE WORK FORCE
PIPELINE IT WILL PROVIDE
INCENTIVES FOR PROFESSIONALS AND
IT WILL ENSURE THE CONTINUITY OF
CARE FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS WHO
ARE MEMBERS PROVIDE NEEDED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES.
TO I'D LIKE TO THINK SENATOR
CABALLERO FOR TAPPING THIS
BECAUSE SHE ALONG WITH SENATORS
HUESO AND GALGIANI AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GLORIA FLORA SALAS WE
MON AND RUBIO AND GRAYSON HAVE
DROPPED A LETTER OF SUPPORT FOR
THIS PROPOSAL WHICH HAS BEEN
SUBMITTED TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
MY CO SPONSOR FROM THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PLANNING COUNCIL IS HERE
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
COMMITTEE.
VERY GOOD I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
ARE SPREAD PUBLIC USE FILES
TRAILER BILL.
S. CI IN. TO WHICH W..
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SALAS HUDDLED
ON WHAT THE WIDENING GROUP HERE
REPRESENTING NESSIE I USE STATE
COUNCIL ON THIS ITEM -- FROM
NINETEEN NINETY THREE TWENTY
FOURTEEN SCA YOU AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS OBTAIN DATA STATES
FROM OFSHE PAD CALLED THE PUBLIC
USE FILES WHICH INCLUDED THE
IDENTIFIED PATIENT LEVEL DATA
FROM HOSPITALS AND AMBULATORY.
AMATORY SURGERY CENTERS.
THESE DATA FILES WERE THE ONLY
COMPREHENSIVE PATIENT LEVEL
PRODUCT.
PRODUCT THAT ADVOCATES COULD
RECEIVE FROM MáS PAD AND HAVE
BEEN AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
SCA USE WORK EXAMINED HEALTH
CARE YOU JUST UTILISATION
QUALITY AND DISPARITIES.
WITHOUT ACCESS TO THE FULL DATA
SETS SCA YOU AND OTHER ADVOCATES
DO NOT HAVE THE TOOLS TO
PARTICIPATE FULLY IN THE POLICY
MAKING AND REGULATORY PROCESS.
WELL SUMMARY DATACURRENTLY
AVAILABLE FOR MUCH BUT CAN HELP
US UNDERSTAND GENERAL TRENDS IT
IS INSUFFICIENT FOR
INVESTIGATING MORE COMPLEX
SITUATIONS FOR EXAMPLE.
USING THE ARCH BUT PUBLIC USE
FILES WE HAVE EXAMINED
DISPARITIES MATERNALLY CARE BY
PAYER.
AND SHOWN THE IMPACT OF
COMMUNITIES WHEN HOSPITALS
REDUCE OR ELIMINATE CRITICAL
LINES OF SERVICE.
HOWEVER US PET HASN'T
REINTERPRETED WHAT DATA MAYBE
PUBLIC YOUR RELEASE UNDER
EXISTING STATUTE THIS HAS LED TO
SCA YOU ANOTHER ADVOCATES LOSING
ACCESS TO THE DATA.
CONTAINED IN AUSCHWITZ PUBLIC
USE FILES.
THE INFORMATION ALL SPECIAL US
PET COLLECTS FROM HOSPITALS AND
AMBULATORY SURGICAL CENTERS CAN
BRING IN A POINT DATA DRIVEN
VOICE TO THE CURRENT
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT EXPANDING.
ACCESS TO CRITICAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IN IDENTIFYING THE
NECESSARY HEALTHCARE COSTS
DRIVERS.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD EXTEND AN
EXISTING DATA ACCESS PROCEDURE
THAT ALLOWS FOR THE RELEASE OF
SENSITIVE EDUCATION RELATED DATA.
TO ALSO ALLOW FOR THE RELEASE OF
HEALTH CARE DATA TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DEMONSTRATE
THE ABILITY TO FOLLOW ESTABLISH
SECURITY PRACTICES.
THIS PROPOSAL BUILT ON THE
COMMITMENT TO HEALTHCARE DATA
TRANSPARENCY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MADE LAST YEAR IN AB.
EIGHTEEN TEN THE HELP TRAILER
BILL WHICH PUT CALIFORNIA ON THE
PATH TOWARD CREATING A
COMPREHENSIVE CLAIMS DATABASE
HOWEVER THAT EFFORT.
WILL TAKE SEVERAL YEARS AND IN
THE INTERIM WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO WRIST RESTORE
ADVOCATES ACCESS TO THE DATA
CONTENT CONTAINED IN THE ARCH
BUT PUBLIC USE FILES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS YES DR.
QUESTION SO.
SO LISTEN YOUR PRESENTATION
PRIVACY CONCERNS AS THE REASON
FOR THIS NOW FIVE YEAR GAP IN
THE ABILITY TO GATHER THIS KIND
OF DATA.
HAS THERE BEEN NO.
I THERE MUST BE A WAY TO PROTECT
THE THE PRIVACY SO I WAS IT IS
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE OR WHAT IT
MIGHT WHAT AM I MISSING HERE
BECAUSE THE DATA IS OBVIOUSLY
HUGELY IMPORTANT.
AND IT'S I I WILL PRESENT
APOLOGIZE I WAS NOT AWARE THAT
THIS THIS IT GONE AWAY -- YEAH
SO.
SO THE COURT THERE ARE STAND YET
SO THERE ARE CONCERNS AROUND THE
PRIVACY -- AND THIS NOTED -- YOU
KNOW WE WOULD MAKE SURE THAT
ANYONE WHO ARE IS RECEIVING THIS
DATA.
HAS A SYSTEM IN PLACE WHERE THAT
DATA IS NOT GOING TO BE.
GOING OUT SO WHERE WAS WORD
DOESN'T HAVE TO GO FOR EXAMPLE
SCA USE INTERNAL SYSTEM IS HIPPA
COMPLIANT IF THE HIPPA COMPLIANT
SYSTEM SO THERE ARE CONCERNS I
MEAN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHOEVER IS RECEIVING THIS
INFORMATION.
PASS A CERTAIN MEASURE OF
COMPLIANCE.
SO FOR FIVE YEARS THERE THERE
HASN'T BEEN ANY WAY TO RESOLVE
THIS.
THIS IS THE STALEMATE WE'VE HAD
IT LIMITED ACCESS. TO THE
INFORMATION TO CERTAIN
INFORMATION.
WHICH IS UP TO ME IS A HUGE
IMPEDIMENT TO MAKING PROGRESS IN
MANY IN MANY OF THESE AREAS SO --
YEAH AND WE'RE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
YOU MORE INFORMATION HAVE A
DEEPER DIVE WITH YOU DOCTOR
WOULD OF COURSE WELL I I THINK
THAT THE OLD PLAYER ALL PEER TO
CLAIMS DATABASE MAY FACE SOME OF
THESE SOME OF THESE.
PRIVACY CHALLENGES AS WELL -- SO
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE RESOLVE
SOME OF THESE ISSUES EARLY -- AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE BUT WITHOUT
THE DATA WE CAN'T WE CAN'T SOLVE
A LOT OF THESE REALLY CRITICAL
ISSUES SO.
THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THAT'S THE LAST OF THE
PROPOSAL'S OWN.
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN SO LET'S
OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION -- WE SUPPORT THREE
OF THESE ISSUES -- SEE CAPS
PROPOSAL FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WORK FORCE FUNDING --
THE PRIMARY CARE PSYCHIATRIC
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM SCHOLARSHIPS
AND THE WORK FORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING TRUST FUND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT
HARRIS ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE THERE'S
THREE ONE ONE WEEK LATER A
PROPOSAL FOR WORKFORCE TRAINING.
BUT THE C. CAP ONE DEALS WITH A
CERTAIN SEGMENT THE WORK FORCE
AND IT'S REALLY CHEAP AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT -- THAT THE
THIS THEIR CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION OUR
PARTNER IN IN THIS AND HALF OF
OUR MEMBERS ARE JOINT MEMBERS.
ALSO SUPPORT TRAINING MORE
PEOPLE LIKE THIRTY AND PEAS AND
P. A.'S. TO HELP FILL THE GAP
AND AND PROVIDE US SOME CBS
MENTAL HEALTH.
TRAINING I MEAN WORK FORCE.
HELP.
THE CARD MAY SPARK.
SO WE SUPPORT THAT AND THE LAST --
ONE THE WET FUNDING THE ONLY
QUESTION WE HAVE IS WHAT FUNDING.
PREVIOUSLY WAS NEVER I'LL USE.
ALLOWED TO BE USED FOR PEOPLE
WHO WERE DOING SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
ON UNDER INTERNSHIP SO WE WANT
THERE TO BE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE.
THAT DATES BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INCLUDES OF ITS USE IN MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OF VICTOR CHRISTY WITH
CALIFORNIA HELPLESS ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
AND WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
PRIMARY CARE PSYCHIATRIC
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM SCHOLARSHIPS.
THANK YOU.
SHERRI DAILY TO SEE CAP
APPARENTLY I SHOULD'VE ASKED FOR
FOR MORE MONEY WITH MY PROPOSALS
ALSO YOU NEXT YEAR BUT WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE WORKFORCE EDUCATION
TRAINING TRUST THAT AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE HONOR HER CAREER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES WERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE PRIMARY CARE
PSYCHIATRIC FELLOWSHIP -- AND
ALSO THE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
WORKFORCE PROPOSAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD EVENING DANIEL A
CALIFORNIA LINES OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF
THE SONG BROWN FUNDING FOR
PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
TRUST FUND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ADRIAN HELP THEM WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
OF THE PRIMARY CARE PSYCHIATRIC
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SO MY AND HER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST IN
SUPPORT OF THE WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING TRUST
FUND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WHEN MEASURE MAY HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES WHO WE SUPPORT THE OF
A SUBSTANCE USE WORKFORCE
FUNDING AND THE -- WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING TRUST
FUND THANK YOU THANK YOU.
REGULATE YOUR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT THE SONG BROWN FUNDING
PROPOSAL THE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WORK FORCE FUNDING
PROPOSAL.
IN THE WORK FORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING TRUST FUND THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT BRINGS US TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS LET'S
BEGIN WITH THE STD PREVENTION
WITH AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION.
THE CENTRAL AXIS HEALTH.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
HERE BEYOND ON BEHALF OF AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AS WELL AS
OUR PARTNER -- IN IN THIS --
REQUEST ON SOCAL ACCESS HEALTH
I'M NOT GOING TO START WITH THE
RECITATION OF ALL THE DATA WE'VE
SEEN OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS ON
HOW THIS EPIDEMIC OF STDS HAS
GOTTEN WAY OUT OF CONTROL.
BUT I WILL POINT OUT FROM A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE THAT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE INCREASE IN
POPULATION CALIFORNIA COMPARED
TO AS HE DEEP -- GROWTH WE'VE
SEEN THIS -- SIX TIMES GROWTH
INCLUDE MEDIA SCENE TWENTY FIVE
TIMES A GROWTH AND GONORRHEA
SCENE TWENTY EIGHT TIMES THE
GROWTH AND SYPHILIS WE SEEM
FORTY TWO TIMES THE GROWTH IN
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS.
AND THE WORST MOST TRAGIC
OUTCOME OF THE LATTER IS THE
FACT THAT WOULD -- IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE HAD THIRTY
STILLBIRTHS -- FROM CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS IT'S AN EPIC IN
EPIDEMIC HAS GOTTEN WAY OUT OF
CONTROL AND IT'S FAR PAST TIME
FOR US TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT --
WE'RE HERE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO AUGMENT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF TWO
MILLION ON ON GOING AS TO THE
FUNDS.
I'M WITH ANOTHER EIGHTEEN
MILLION FOR A TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL -- IN ADDITION
TO THAT WE HAVE SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD GIVE MORE DIRECTION
TO THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH.
ON HOW THOSE FUNDS COULD BE
SPENT -- IF YOU LOOK AT CURRENT
STATUTE CURRENT STATUTE THE
GIVES DIRECTION IS ONE SENTENCE
LONG.
WE THINK THAT AS FAR IN ADEQUATE
TO GIVE DIRECTION TO THE
DEPARTMENT ON HOW THEY SHOULD BE
SPENDING THIS MONEY AND HOW THEY
SHOULD BE DOING IT IN THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY -- LOT OF
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE NEW THERE
AND A LOT OF NEW -- WAYS TO TO
DEAL WITH THIS EPIDEMIC ON THAT
WERE NOT CONSIDERED WHEN THAT
ONE SENTENCE WAS WRITTEN FIFTY
OR SIXTY OR SEVENTY YEARS AGO --
I DO WANT TO POINT OUT -- ONE OF
A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT WE HAVE --
TALK -- TO ACTUALLY I'M SORRY
THERE WAS SOMETHING I WON SAID
BEGINNING YOU SAID LAST WEEK
MADAM CHAIR TO L. A. L. ASK THEM
TO SEE IF THEY COME WITH SOME
ANALYSIS.
ON WHAT IS THE REAL PROBLEM OUT
THERE HOW BIG IS THIS WHAT ARE
WE DEALING WITH WE DID -- SORT
OF A BACK OF THE ENVELOPE
ILLEGITIMATE -- ANALYSIS LAST
WEEK WE SPEND ABOUT NINETY FIVE
DOLLARS PER PATIENT IT'S HEALTH
HEARD FOUNDATION DOES ON ONE OF
THE BIGGEST STD PROGRAMS IN THE
STATE -- CDC SAYS THERE ABOUT
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION NEW
INFECTIONS -- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR YOU
MULTIPLY THAT BY NINETY FIVE
WE'RE LOOKING ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL
TO TRYING TO GET OUR ARMS AROUND
THIS WE KNOW THE LEGISLATURE IS
NOT GOING TO APPROPRIATE.
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS -- BUT WE THINK IT PUTS
THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
CLEARLY IN PERSPECTIVE -- WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO ADOPT THE
TWENTY MILLION ONGOING FUNDS
WITH THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AND APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS JUST A
COMMENT I MEAN THIS THIS SPIKE
IS IS IS ACTUALLY SHOCKING WE
DON'T LIVE IN THE EIGHTEENTH OR
SEVENTEENTH CENTURY ANYMORE AND
AND TO SEE THIS -- THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY SHOCKING IS
[inaudible]
IS THERE.
IS WHAT IS THERE AN EXPLANATION
I'M IN MEAN I I REMEMBER AS A
STUDENT IN SCHOOL BEING EDUCATED
ABOUT THESE THINGS AND AND I THE
THE THE INCIDENTS WAS NOT NEARLY
WHAT IT IS NOW IS -- MAYBE I'M
ASKING THE WRONG PERSON BUT IS
PRETTY SHOCKING.
YES WELL I DON'T THINK I'M NOT
FOR THE WRONG PERSON.
OKAY I'M I'M REALLY NOT PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS OR OR SAID -- IN
THE S. P. D. WORLD I WILL SAY IN
TALKING TO A LOT OF THE FOLKS
WHO'VE BEEN GUIDING US ON THIS --
THERE WAS A HUGE EPIDEMIC IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES AND IT TOOK A
MAJOR INFUSION CASH TOWARDS THE
END OF THAT -- INTO THAT DECADE
I'M AND WE GOT IT DOWN THERE WAS
THERE WAS A PLAN THAT -- IN THE
NUMBER OF STDS THAT ARE JUST
STARTED GOING BACK UP IN IN IN
MAJOR WAYS THEY'RE JUST A LOT OF
REASONS FOR BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THAT WE DON'T SPEND ENOUGH
MONEY ON GOING MONEY.
I MEAN BLESSED THE LEGISLATURE
FOR APPROPRIATING TWO ONE TIME
ONLY APPROPRIATIONS THE LAST
THREE YEARS FIVE MILLION TWO MEN.
THAT WAS HELPFUL BUT AS LONG AS
YOU'RE ONLY PUTTING OUT ONE TIME
ONLY FUNDING CAN ONLY PURCHASE
STUFF WITH THE YOU CAN'T BUY ON
GOING STAFFING GAUGE WHEN.
IT'S JUST NOT DOING WHAT IT
NEEDS TO DO -- WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY INVEST I'M IN ONGOING
FUNDS.
I HOPE THAT WAS AN ANSWER.
AND AND YOU MAY NOT HAVE THE
ANSWER AND I HOPE THAT SOMEONE
FROM PUBLIC HEALTH IS LISTENING
UP OUT THERE THAT THAT MAYBE WE
CAN GET SOME OF THIS INFORMATION
IS SOME OF THIS TIED.
TO OTHER KINDS OF SUBSTANCE
ABUSE.
THAT'S BECAUSE HE KNOWS THE
SPREAD HERE OR OR MEAN SURELY
THERE IS SOME DATA OUT THERE
SOMEWHERE THAT'S POINTED TO
WHERE THE BECAUSE CAUSES ARE I
WILL TELL YOU ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CAUSES WE'VE SEEN JUST WITHIN
THE LAST DECADE.
IS THE ROCK THE RISE IN EASY
CONTACT FOR SEXUAL PURPOSES ON
THE INTERNET AND AND SOCIAL
MEDIA.
PEOPLE ARE HOOKING UP.
MORE QUICKLY MORE ANONYMOUSLY
THEY'RE ENGAGING IN UNPROTECTED
SEX -- IN THAT'S WHAT ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THERE'S BEEN SUCH A
SPIKE IN YESTERDAY'S ESPECIALLY
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE I MEAN THAT
THE HIGHEST RATE TO RECEIVING
SEEN OUR FROM FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
FOUR AND ESPECIALLY IN YOUNG
WOMEN.
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR AND A LOT
OF IS BECAUSE THEY'RE CONNECTING
ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND HOOKING UP.
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY ANSWER BUT
THAT IS A MAJOR.
ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION ON
BEHAVIOR RISK FACTORS SURVEY
FUNDING.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBER -- I'M SUSAN TO MORRIS
REPRESENTING THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION AND THIS IS ONE OF
THE UNIQUE ITEMS THAT HAS NO
COST ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
I WANT TO THANK THE STAFF FOR
INCLUDING THIS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY -- THE LAST TIME
CALIFORNIA PARTICIPATED IN THE
BEHAVIORAL RISK FACTOR
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM SURVEY WAS.
TWENTY FIFTEEN THIS IS A FORM OF
RESEARCH CONDUCTING SURVEILLANCE
IN FACT IT IS ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE CDC'S
HEALTHY BRAIN INITIATIVE THAT
YOU HEARD ABOUT EARLIER.
IN THE HEARING -- WE HAVE THREE
SOURCES OF REVENUE IN THE STATE
THERE WAS ALZHEIMER'S RESEARCH
FUNDING -- PUT AN ON GOING BY
GOVERNOR BROWN LAST YEAR THERE'S
A PROPOSAL THIS YEAR BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOME AND WE ALSO HAVE THE
STATE'S TAX CHECK OFTEN THAT
RAISES OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES BUT WE
DON'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY THIS
STAKEHOLDER REQUEST WOULD
PROVIDE -- AUTHORITY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
USE ALZHEIMER'S RESEARCH DOLLARS
FOR THE PURPOSES OF THING OF
CONDUCTING.
THE BREAKFAST QUESTIONS ON
COGNITIVE HEALTH.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH THE TOTAL COST OF
THE QUESTION IS LESS THAN FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND IT
ONLY HAPPENS EVERY FIVE YEARS.
SO WE'RE LOOKING TO THIS
COMMITTEE TO UP TO PROVIDE THAT
AUTHORIZATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
PROPOSAL.
THE AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
HYPERTENSION CONTROL PILOT
PROGRAM
.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JAMIE MORGAN
AND I'M WITH THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE REQUESTING FUNDING FOR
THE HYPERTENSION CONTROL PILOT
PROGRAM TO BE ADMINISTERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AS YOU MAY KNOW HEART DISEASE
AND STROKE ARE TWO OF THE
LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH.
IN FACT ONE PERSON DIES OF
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE ABOUT
EVERY THIRTY EIGHT SECONDS.
WITHIN THE TWO MINUTES I HAVE TO
SPEAK TODAY THREE PEOPLE HAVE
DIED. ONE OF THE MAJOR
MODIFIABLE RISK FACTORS FOR
THESE DISEASES IS HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE.
YET ONLY 53% OF ADULTS HAVE IT
UNDER CONTROL.
OFTEN CALLED THE SILENT KILLER
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE HAS NO SIGNS
OR SYMPTOMS.
AND A PERSON CAN LIVE YEARS
WITHOUT KNOWING THEY HAVE IT.
CALIFORNIA ALMOST ONE IN THREE
ADULTS HAVE HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
ESPECIALLY AFRICAN AMERICAN.
AND NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
WITH PREVALENCE RATES NEAR 40%.
WE CAN AND NEED TO CHANGE THE
STATISTICS YET THE STATE DOES
NOT PROVIDE ANY GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS FOR PREVENTION EDUCATION
OR TREATMENT OF HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE.
HEART DISEASE OR STROKE.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL CREATE
A FIVE SEVEN COUNTY PILOT
PROGRAM.
BASED ON NATIONAL GUIDELINES I'M
SELF MEASURE BLOOD PRESSURE
MONITORING WITH THE GOAL OF
REDUCING THE PREVALENCE OF
HYPERTENSION.
AND INCREASING THE COST CONTROL
RATE AMONG PARTICIPANTS.
THE DEPARTMENT WILL IDENTIFY THE
COUNTIES USING THE FOLLOWING
CRITERIA HIGHER RATES OF
HYPERTENSION.
HIGHER POPULATION OF THOSE GREAT
AT GREATER RISK AND GEOGRAPHIC
AND POPULATION SIZE DIVERSITY.
WHAT'S THE COUNTIES ARE
IDENTIFIED THE DEPARTMENT WILL
WORK WITH THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM WITH FUNDING PRIORITIZE
TO FQHCS AND COMMUNITY CLINICS.
SINCE DIAGNOSED WITH
HYPERTENSION WILL RECEIVE A
BLOOD PRESSURE DEVICE FOR SELF
MONITORING AT HOME.
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS WILL BE
EMPLOYED BY THE CLINICS AND MAKE
HOME VISITS TO ENSURE PATIENTS
ARE MARKED MEASURING THE BLOOD
PRESSURE.
CORRECTLY AND INSIST CAM
ASSISTING LIFESTYLE
MODIFICATIONS THEY WILL ALSO
PROVIDE OUTREACH AND FREE BLOOD
PRESSURE SCREENINGS IN THE
COMMUNITY WITH REFERRAL BACK TO
CONNECT IF NECESSARY.
AT THE END OF THE THREE YEAR
PILOT PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT
WILL EVALUATE AND REPORT THE
FINDINGS.
WE KNOW THAT SIMILAR PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVE IN BY
FUNDING THIS PILOT PROGRAM WE
CAN PROVE AND SAVE LIVES AS WELL
AS THE STATE MONEY IN THE LONG
TERM.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK
TODAY AND FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS PROPOSAL [inaudible]
Q. [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SAYING NONE I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION -- BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS BLACK WOMEN
OVERWHELMED FOR WELLNESS ON SAFE
COSMETICS PROGRAM.
IT'S JUST ME TODAY ALL RIGHT
THAT MEANS WE ARE ALL WE NEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF I GUESS IT'S
EVENING GOOD AFTER YOU GET IT
GOOD EVENING ASSEMBLY WOMAN
REYES AND ESTEEM TO MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JANET MIDDLEMAN AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF PROGRAM AND
POLICY OF BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS WE ARE
SPONSORING THE STAKEHOLDER
BUDGET PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY.
ALONG WITH BLACK WOMAN FOR
WELLNESS TO INCREASE FUNDING AND
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA SAFE
BECAUSE MEDICS PROGRAM.
DUE TO THE LACK OF FEDERAL
REGULATION OF THE EIGHTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR COSMETICS
INDUSTRY.
AND THE SEVENTY BILLION DOLLAR
FRAGRANCE INDUSTRY BECAUSE MEDIC
COMPANIES CAN AND DO LEGALLY
SELL.
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS KNOWN TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO CAUSE CANCER AND
BIRTH DEFECTS IN OUR STATE.
IN FACT IN A RECENT REPORT
ISSUED BY THE SAFE BECAUSE
MEDICS PROGRAM.
IT REVEALED THAT FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY TWO COMPANIES HAD
DISCLOSED THE SALE.
OF OVER SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA.
CONTAINING EIGHTY EIGHT UNIQUE
PROP SIXTY FIVE CARCINOGENS AND
REPRODUCTIVE TOXICANTS.
ILLUSTRATING THE VITAL PUBLIC
HEALTH INFORMATION SERVICE
PROVIDED BY THE CALIFORNIA SAFE
BECAUSE MEDICS PROGRAM.
THE TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE SAFE
COSMETICS ACT CREATED THE SAFE
COSMETICS PROGRAM WHICH REQUIRES
COMPANIES SELLING BEAUTY.
AND PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS IN
OUR STATE. TO REPORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE
PRESENCE OF ANY PROP SIXTY FIVE
CHEMICAL IN THEIR PRODUCTS.
THE SAFE BECAUSE MEDICS PROGRAM
THEN MAKES THIS INFORMATION
AVAILABLE VIA A PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE DATABASE THAT HAS
BEEN UTILIZED BY THOUSANDS OF
CONSUMERS.
SALON WORKERS SCIENTISTS AND
REGULATORS FROM THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
OUR BUDGET PROPOSAL SEEKS A ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION OF
EXISTING FUNDING FOR THE SAFE
BECAUSE MEDICS PROGRAM. FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY AND A HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO MODERNIZE THE
ANTIQUATED SAFE BECAUSE MEDICS
PROGRAMS.
ELECTRONIC REPORTING SYSTEM.
THAT COMPANIES USE TO REPORT THE
PRESENCE OF PROP SIXTY FIVE
CHEMICALS IN THEIR PRODUCTS TO
THE STATE. TO FUND ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT RESEARCH AND
OUTREACH STAFF TO ENSURE THE
SAFE COSMETICS PROGRAM.
HAS THE HUMAN RESOURCES IT NEEDS
SO THIS CRITICAL INFORMATION
GETS INTO THE HANDS OF
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND WORKERS.
AND TO ENSURE THAT COMPANIES ARE
FULLY COMPLYING WITH THE SAFE
BECAUSE MEDICS ACT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
THE INCREASE IN FUNDING WOULD
ALSO ALLOW THE SAFE BECAUSE
MEDICS PROGRAM TO ACTUALLY USE
ITS EXISTING STATUTORY AUTHORITY.
TO INVESTIGATE AND REFER UNSAFE
SALON WORKER EXPOSURES TO CAL
OSHA.
IN PROVIDE OTHER STATE AGENCIES
WITH THE INFORMATION THEY NEED
TO DO A BETTER JOB.
OF PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST UNSAFE CHEMICAL
EXPOSURES IN THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS AND BEAUTY PRODUCTS
THEY USE EVERY DAY.
OUR BUDGET PROPOSAL IS IDENTICAL
TO THE STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL THAT
WAS APPROVED BY YOUR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE.
IN THE SENATE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE THREE LAST YEAR.
AND WHICH WAS INCLUDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE BUDGET
BILLS APPROVED BY BOTH HOUSES.
IT WAS SADLY AND SURPRISINGLY
HOWEVER REJECTED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN.
IN HIS SWEEPING DISMISSAL LAST
YEAR OF NEW FUNDING AN
INITIATIVE.
WE HOPE THAT THE ESTEEMED
MEMBERS OF THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL ONCE AGAIN SUPPORT ARE
IMPORTANT STAKEHOLDER BUDGET
REQUEST TO INCREASE FUNDING AND
SUPPORT. FOR THE CALIFORNIA SAFE
COSMETICS PROGRAM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SING THEM I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
OUR HEPATITIS C. H. C. B. PER
PREVENTION CALIFORNIA HEPATITIS
ALLIANCE.
FROM THE MANUFACTURER AND THEN
THIS -- MY NAME IS STAND ON LAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEPATITIS LINES WERE HERE TO
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT. FOR TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING GENERAL
FUND FOR HEPATITIS C. PREVENTION
LINKAGE TO AND RETENTION AND
CARE AND TREATMENT -- CURRENTLY
THERE AN ESTIMATED FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS LIVING
WITH HCV MOST OF WHOM DON'T EVEN
KNOW THEIR STATUS.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
REPORTS THAT H. THAT --
HEPATITIS C. IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MORE DEATHS THAN THE NEXT FIFTY
NINE INFECTIOUS DISEASES
COMBINED.
WE ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE THE
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPANDED ACCESS
TO HEPATITIS C. TREATMENT IN ALL
OF ITS PUBLIC SYSTEMS.
HOWEVER THE ATTENTION TO AND THE
FUNDING FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEMS THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
ACTUALLY GET PEOPLE TO THAT
TREATMENT AND CARE.
ARE SERIOUSLY LACKING -- WE HAVE
THE TOOLS TO ELIMINATE TO CURE
HEPATITIS C. NOW AND YET WE
CONTINUE TO SEE INCIDENTS RISE
IN THE STATE. THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND NEW HEPATITIS C. CASES
WERE REPORTED IN. 200-016-2011
TO TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE
RATES OF HEPATITIS C. INCREASED
BY 50% AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE.
DRIVEN PRIMARILY BY THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC.
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND WOMEN ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN HEPATITIS
C. INCREASE IN WOMEN OF
CHILDBEARING AGE BY A HUNDRED
AND 48%.
ALTHOUGH BLACKS ARE ONLY 6% OF
THE CALIFORNIA POPULATION THEY
MAKE UP 12% OF NEW AGE CV
INFECTIONS.
SO WE ARE SUGGESTING TO MICRO
ELIMINATION PROJECTS FOR
HEPATITIS C. IN THOSE ARE
PROJECTS FOCUS ON A PARTICULAR
POPULATION WHERE WE KNOW THAT WE
CAN CREATE.
A HUGE IMPACT.
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS FOR FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO CREATE
PROGRAMS TO ELIMINATE HEPATITIS
C. AMONG PEOPLE WHO USE DRUGS
AND THEIR PARTNERS.
THIS REQUEST IS INTENDED TO
BUILD ON A SUCCESSFUL
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS AND
UNFORTUNATELY HAD ENDED NOW.
ON THEY TESTED OVER THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS THEY FOUND
A SEVEN POINT 5% POSITIVITY RATE.
AND 95% OF THOSE WHO ARE LINKED
TO CARE WERE CURED.
IN ADDITION WE'RE ASKING FOR
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
ELIMINATE HEPATITIS C. IN PEOPLE
HER CO INFECTED WITH HEPATITIS
C. AND H. ID.
AND WE KNOW IN THIS CASE THAT
THE TWO DISEASES TOGETHER CREATE
A CONDITION THAT WE'RE BOTH
DISEASES ACT MORE AGGRESSIVELY
AND THAT LEADS TO MUCH INCREASED
MORE MORBIDITY.
SO WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY BUILD ON THE HIV CARE
AND PREVENTION -- SYSTEM HERE
AND IN CALIFORNIA. TO INSURE
THAT WE ELIMINATE H. CV AND
THOSE WHO ARE CO INFECTED.
SO WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
REQUEST [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
NO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
HIV PREVENTION CALIFORNIA HIV
[inaudible]
ALLIANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CRACKPOTS FOR
FROM A PURELY HEALTH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HIV ALLIANCE --
WE'RE REQUESTING TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT
COMPREHENSIVE HIV PREVENTION
SERVICES INCLUDING HIV TESTING
EXPANDED PREP ACCESS LINKAGE TO
CARE AND SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WHO
USE DRUGS.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS
TO AN HIV EPIDEMIC HAVE STALLED
DESPITE SIGNIFICANT SCIENTIFIC
AND MEDICAL PROGRESS.
THE STATE'S ANNUAL RATE OF NEW
HIV INFECTIONS DECREASE JUST 2%
FROM 200-013-22017.
CALIFORNIA'S NOW FALLING BEHIND
OTHER STATES WERE GOVERNMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE
IMPLEMENTING AGGRESSIVE EFFORTS
TO COMBAT THE VIRUS.
NEW YORK STATE FOR EXAMPLE HAS
COMMITTED MORE THAN TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO AN HIV
EPIDEMIC SINCE.
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND NEW
DIAGNOSES HAVE ALREADY DECLINED
20%.
SADLY CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS IS
NO SURPRISE TO PUBLIC HEALTH
LEADERS AND COMMUNITY ADVOCATES
CALIFORNIA SLASHED OVER EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM HIV
PROGRAMS IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND LITTLE HAS
BEEN RESTORED.
THOSE CUTS ELIMINATED STATE
FUNDED PREVENTION EFFORTS IN
MANY AREAS INCLUDING HIV TESTING.
AND MOST CBO SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES TO EFFECTIVELY
REACH VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AS A RESULT DISPARITIES ARE
INCREASING OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS THE RATE OF NEW INFECTIONS
AMONG WHITES DECLINE NEARLY 13%
WHILE DECREASING ONLY 2% AMONG
BLACKS.
AND INCREASING RATES AMONG TRANS
WOMEN ARE THE HIGHEST FOR IN FOR
ANY GROUP.
THESE DISPARITIES UNDERSCORE THE
URGENT NEED TO IMPROVE AND
EXPAND HIV PREVENTION EFFORTS IN
THESE COMMUNITIES.
OVER THE LAST DECADE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE TOOLS HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED THEY CAN LITERALLY
STOP HIV IN ITS TRACKS BUT TOO
FEW PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
TOOLS.
PROP UP TAKING CALIFORNIA
REMAINS EXTREMELY LOW AND
PROBLEMATIC GEOGRAPHIC AND
RACIAL ETHNIC DISPARITIES ARE
PLAYING NOW.
NEARLY HALF OF PEOPLE LIVING
WITH HIV IN CALIFORNIA LACK
CONSISTING CARE HER ACCESS TO
TREATMENT.
CALIFORNIA CAN AND MUST DO
BETTER.
THE PROPOSED PROPOSED FUNDING
WILL PROVIDE GRANTS TO LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS IN CBO'S TO
SUPPORT COMPREHENSIVE HIV
PREVENTION SERVICES.
THESE EFFORTS WILL BE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED. TO REDUCE
NEW HIV DIAGNOSES AMONG MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS INCLUDING
PEOPLE OF COLOR GAME AND TRANS
WOMEN IN PEOPLE WHO USE DRUGS.
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
SO THAT THE STATE IS NOT
CONTINUE TO FALL FURTHER BEHIND.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
I WILL SHARE THAT ONE OF THE
CONCERNS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE IS
THAT.
MUCH OF THE FUNDING IS BASED ON
THE DIAGNOSIS AND MANY OF THOSE
WHO ARE AFFECTED TO GO TO PALM
SPRINGS WITH THEIR SERVICES OR
TO LOS ANGELES.
SO WHEN THERE'S AN EFFORT TO TRY
TO DETERMINE HOW THE FUNDING IS
GOING TO BE DONE.
THE INLAND EMPIRE DOESN'T GET IT
BECAUSE THE DIAGNOSIS WAS DONE
OUTSIDE OF OF OUR DISTRICT.
IS THAT A CONSIDERATION THAT
WILL BE -- IS THAT SOMETHING YOU
WOULD CONSIDER -- YEAH.
WHEN YOU'RE DOING THE FUNDING
SHOULD YOU RECEIVE THIS?
YEAH WE HAVE -- WE HAVE HEARD
THAT CONCERNED HAVE DISCUSSED
THAT WITH SOME OF THE
CONSTITUENTS IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND I THINK THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN.
THE INFORMATION THAT THE CDC
COLLECTS REPORTS IN THE
INFORMATION THAT THE STATE HAS
SO HAPPY TO GATHER MORE
INFORMATION SHARE WITH YOU BUT
WE HAVE DISCUSSED THIS WITH THE
OFFICE OF BATES AND THEY DO HAVE.
ACCURATE INFORMATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE FUNDING IS
TARGETED TO WHERE IT'S NEEDED
MOST SO HAPPY TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION WITH YOU.
PRETTY GOOD AYE AYE WHEN YOU
HAVE A MOMENT I WOULD LIKE. TO
TO HAVE YOU SHARE THAT SO THAT I
CAN SHARE WITH MY MY COMMUNITY
YEAH ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
FARMWORKERS FARMWORKER HEALTHY
HEALTH STUDY.
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOE OLD
DERRINGER I'M HERE WITH NO EIGHT
BOTTOM OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE.
IN SUPPORTING IN FAVOR OF A
REQUEST FOR A PRIMARY HEALTH
STUDY WE HAVE OVER TWENTY FIVE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS.
INCLUDING SEE PAN THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE PEARL STUDIES UC
BERKELEY LABOR CENTER AND THE
DOLORES HUERTA FOUNDATION AS
WELL AS MANY OTHERS -- I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ROBERT
REEVE US AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS FOR SIGNING ON IN A
SUPPORT LETTER IN FAVOR OF THIS.
SO AGRICULTURAL WORKERS IN THE
BACKBONE OF THE STATE'S FIFTY
BILLION DOLLAR HEALTH --
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY.
HOWEVER WE'VE KNOWN FROM PAST
STUDIES TWENTY YEARS AGO ABOUT
SOME VERY POOR HEALTH STATUS.
AS WE WERE DEVELOPING POLICY
PROPOSALS ARE STARTED DEVELOPING
POLICY PROPOSALS TO PRESENT TO
THE LEGISLATURE WE REALIZE
THERE'S A COMPLETE DATA GAP.
IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS AND IS
DOCTOR WOULD WAS SUGGESTING
WITHOUT DATA IT'S REALLY HARD TO
MAKE EFFECTIVE AND TARGETED
POLICY -- THE LAST AND ONLY
FARMWORKERS HEALTH STUDY AS I
SAID WAS TWENTY YEARS AGO --
DONE BY THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE
FOR RURAL STUDIES WHAT WE DON'T
KNOW IS WHAT HAPPENED SINCE THEN
HOW IS THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
ACTUALLY HELPED OR NOT -- FOR
FARMWORKERS QUEST 70% WERE
UNINSURED THAT TIME.
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW MANY
MORE INSURED AT THIS POINT FOR
MANY REASONS RELATED TO
IMMIGRATION.
AND EMPLOYMENT STATUS -- HOW HAS
ALL THE FUNDING AN EXPANDED ROLE
CAPACITY IN CLINICS -- ACTUALLY
HELP FARMWORKERS HOW WITH ALL OF
OUR PREVENTIVE HEALTH EFFORTS
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF
PRESENTATIONS TODAY HOW THEY
ACTUALLY REACHING FARMWORKERS.
AND THEN LASTLY HOW WOULD THE
MEDIC HOW FOR ALL OF THE HELP
FOR ALL PROPOSALS.
IN THE IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY AFFECT
FARMWORKERS SO THESE ARE ALL
THINGS WE WERE PROPOSED TO LOOK
AT TWO OR THREE PARTS STUDY. ONE
WOULD BE AN ACTUAL SURVEY OF
PROBABLY CLOSE TO A THOUSAND
FARMWORKERS INCLUDING PHYSICAL
EXAMS AND BLOOD TESTS WHICH WAS
DONE IN THE ORIGINAL STUDY.
ANOTHER ONE IS -- WORKING WITH
THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY TO
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
TERMS OF OFFERING HEALTH
INSURANCE AND LESS IS REVIEWING
POLICY -- IN ALL THIS WILL
REALLY HELP US UNDERSTAND WHAT
PROPOSALS AND WHAT POLICIES TO
BRING BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
TO APPROVE -- THE HEALTH OF ALL
APART FROM.
WELL IT WOULD BE UP TO THE
FINDING WOULD GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THAT
WOULD CONTRACT OUT AND I DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT PROCESS.
TAKES SAID IT'S THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR RURAL STUDIES THAT
DID THE PREVIOUS STUDY IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE I KNOW
THERE CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN
LOOKING AT IT AGAIN.
I'VE TALKED TO THE UC BERKELEY
LABOR CENTER WHICH HAS THE
EXPERTISE IN THE HEALTH COVERAGE
AREA. TO REALLY HELP WITH THAT
AND THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSAL.
WONDERFUL.
QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH PROPOSAL.
PUBLIC HEALTH LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE [inaudible]
HELLO.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR.
MY NAME IS TRADER MODEL BUT I'M
THE PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTOR FOR
SAMBAR DINO COUNTY AND I'M HERE
TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BUDGET REQUEST.
A FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ARE YOU GOING TO IMPROVE
AND REBUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE
OF LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
PREVENT AND CONTROL THE SPREAD
OF DISEASE.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH WE
ARE EXPERIENCING AN
UNPRECEDENTED UPTICK IN
INFECTIOUS DISEASE OUTBREAKS.
WE SEE THE EVIDENCE EVERY DAY IN
THE NEWS WHETHER IT'S THE
MEASLES OUTBREAK ARISE IN A CD
RATES.
ARE RISE AND VALLEY FEVER AS
WELL TO MEASLES OUTBREAK OR THE
HEPATITIS OUTBREAK OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN UNFORTUNATELY LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE WOEFULLY
UNDER RESOURCE.
IN ORDER TO CARRY OUT WHAT IS
ESSENTIALLY ARE UNIQUE AND VERY
CRITICAL ROLE IN TERMS OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASE CONTROL.
AND IT IS A RESPONSIBILITY THAT
NO OTHER ENTITY IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR AT THE INFECTIOUS DISEASE
FUNDING THAT COMES FROM
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
WHEN YOU EXCLUDE THE FUNDING
SPECIFIC TO HIV AND AIDS?
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
SLATED TO RECEIVE EIGHT AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS LESS THAN
WHAT THEY RECEIVED IN
200-072-0008.
IN ADDITION WHEN YOU COMPARE
220-007-2000.
EIGHT LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
ARE SLATED TO RECEIVE OVER ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS LESS IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE HEALTH
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS.
IN SEVENTY NO COUNTY ALONE THAT
AMOUNTS TO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
IT'S VITAL THAT ANY FUNDING THAT
COME TO LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
BE FLEXIBLE AND NOT DISEASE
SPECIFIC.
SO THAT WE COULD ADDRESS EITHER
THE DISEASES IN ISSUES FACING US
TODAY AS WELL AS ANY EMERGING
DISEASES THAT COULD FACE US IN
THE FUTURE.
WE NEED THE FLEXIBILITY IN ORDER
TO MEET THE DIVERSITY OF ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES.
THIS FUNDING WOULD ALLOW LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS LIKE MINE. TO
INCREASE CRITICAL STAFFING
WHETHER IT'S EPIDEMIOLOGIST.
COMMUTE CALL DISEASE
INVESTIGATORS OR FRANKLY TO
INCREASE OUR LAB CAPACITY.
THESE FUNCTIONS HELP TO INCREASE
MY ENTIRE ABILITY TO ADDRESS ALL
DISEASES IRRESPECTIVE OF WHAT
THEY MIGHT BE.
WITHOUT INVESTMENTS INTO OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS FRANKLY
ARE JUST GOING TO BE ON ABLE TO
PROTECT THE RESIDENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IN YOUR COMMUNITIES.
AND SO FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET ASK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES DOCTOR WITH.
QUESTION YOU YOU SAID -- EARLY
IN YOUR COMMENT YOU SAID TO
REBUILD -- IS THAT.
CORRECT.
YES SO IT TOO IN 200-022-22000
SEVEN EIGHT IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU
HAD SIGNIFICANT CUTS -- OVER
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE AND WE
USE THAT TWO THOUSAND TWO SAID --
200-072-0008 AS A BASELINE
BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY THE PERIOD
RIGHT BEFORE THE GREAT
DEPRESSION AND THAT'S WHEN WE
SAW THAT IT DRAMATIC DECREASES
IN REALIGNMENT DOLLARS -- AND
I'D LIKE TO USE REALIGNMENTS
BECAUSE THAT IS AN AREA OF
FLEXIBLE FUNDING FOR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
IT'S WHAT WE USE IN ORDER TO
CARRY OUT A LOT OF OUR CORE
FUNCTIONS.
I THINK ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE FACE IS OFTEN TIMES IF YOU
SEE INCREASES.
IN A FUNDING FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IT'S UNFORTUNATELY
IT'S CATEGORICAL SO IT ALLOWS US
TO ONLY ADDRESS A VERY SPECIFIC
DISEASE -- IN A VERY SPECIFIC
POPULATION WITH POSSIBLY A VERY
UNIQUE INTERVENTION -- WE
TYPICALLY OF USE REALIGNMENT
THOUGH TO PERFORM ALL OF OUR
CORE FUNCTIONS AND TO BE ABLE TO
PIVOT.
SO THAT WE CAN ADDRESS MEASLES
AT ONE POINT -- HEPATITIS A
HEPATITIS.
C. ARE INCREASING RATES AND STDS
AND THE LIKE.
SO HAVE YOU HAVE YOU NOT SEEN --
IMAGE DURING THE RECESSION WERE
YOU WERE YOU WERE YOUR WAS YOUR
LEVEL FUNDING CUT.
SIGNIFICANTLY AND NOT SEEN.
HAVE YOU NOT SEEN A RESTORATION --
WE HAVE NOT SO AS WE'VE LOOKED
AT A NINETEEN NINETY ONE HEALTH
REALIGNMENT THAT'S THE ONE I'M
SPECIFICALLY SPEAKING TO WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE AVAILABLE THE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE HEALTH
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS -- FREE THE
RECESSION AND WE COMPARE IT TO
THE AVAILABLE DOLLARS TODAY WE
HAVE NOT SEEN A RESTORATION OF
THOSE DOLLARS.
WOW.
THAT'S PRETTY AND SO
CONSEQUENTLY I BE THROUGH THE
COURSE OF THE LAST TEN ELEVEN
YEARS -- WHAT YOU'VE SEEN IS AND
I SAY REBUILD BECAUSE WHAT
YOU'VE SEEN IS A DEGRADATION?
OF LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS --
SOME OF OUR CORE FUNCTIONS AND
FRANKLY -- IT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU KNOW WE'RE THE ONLY ENTITY
RESPONSIBLE FOR DOING THESE
PARTICULAR THINGS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
SO WITH THIS FUNDING THEN BE --
IN A WAY IT IS. TO FIND THE
FUNDS THAT WOULD BE FLEXIBLE.
FOR SO THAT INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES
AND THEIR THEIR UNIQUE I MEAN
THIS IS A DIVERSE STATE SO NOT I
COUNTIES NEEDS ARE THE SAME
EXACTLY -- TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE I RECENTLY SAT WITH MY
CHEMICAL DISEASE INVESTIGATORS.
AND THE ISSUE THAT WE WERE
SPEAKING TO WAS CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS -- JUST SO YOU KNOW IN
SUMMER DINO ARE CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS RATES INCREASED BY 70%.
BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE ISSUES THAT
WE WERE DEALING WITH WERE A LOT
OF WOMEN THAT WERE HOMELESS --
AND A LOT OF WOMEN THAT WERE
ALSO DRUG USING.
AT THE SAME TIME -- JUSTIN THIS
EARLY PART OF TWENTY NINETEEN WE
SEE NINE HEPATITIS EIGHT CASES.
SPREAD OUT THERE ARE TWENTY
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES -- AT IN
COMPARISON WE HAD TWELVE TOTAL
HEPATITIS EIGHT CASES LAST YEAR --
AND THEN AND TO TOP IT ALL OFF --
WE ARE A KIND OF ON PINS AND
NEEDLES RIGHT NOW I'M JUST
WAITING TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT WE
WILL END UP WITH THE MEASLES --
CASE BECAUSE OF THE CASES THAT
WE'RE SEEING IN ORANGE COUNTY.
AND SO THE IDEA OF PROVIDING
FLEXIBLE FUNDING IT WOULD GIVE
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO DIRECT
STAFF OUT INTO THE FIELD TO
ADDRESS THE CONGENITAL SYPHILIS
CASE -- AT THE SAME TIME LOOK TO
SEE HOW I CAN MITIGATE -- THE
HEPATITIS EIGHT HOW IT CASES
THAT I'VE GOT BUT ALSO
CONSEQUENTLY BE PREPARED IN THE
EVENT THAT I GET A MEASLES
OUTBREAK -- WE I KNOW THE
INCREASES IN VALLEY FEVER -- ARE
AN ISSUE THAT HAS OCCURRED IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE AND SO.
OUR REQUEST IS THAT THE FUNDING
BE FLEXIBLE ENOUGH SO THAT
INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITIES
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES.
CAN ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC NEEDS
THAT THEY'VE GOT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AYE AYES WAS
I'VE FOUGHT I WANT TO SUPPORT
THIS REQUEST ON OF A COUPLE OF
THE COUNTIES.
THAT I'M AWARE OF IT -- THAT I
REPRESENT THAT ARE THAT ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS REQUEST AND I
THINK -- FOR ME THE IMPORTANCE
IS THE FLEXIBILITY -- I
REPRESENT A VERY DIVERSE
DISTRICT AND WITHOUT THAT
FLEXIBILITY THAT THE CATEGORY
BECAUSE AS YOU DESCRIBED --
DON'T HELP IN MANY IN MANY OF
THESE CASES BECAUSE OUR SOME OF
THE COUNTIES MAY NOT HAVE.
THAT PARTICULAR NEEDS SO -- THIS
JUST FEELS LIKE AN EXAMPLE OF OF
THE WERE THOSE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF A BUDGET CUTS.
THAT AND AS WE'VE HEARD EARLIER
THE THE THE RAPID AND AND
SIGNIFICAN SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
IN STDS -- THIS IS THESE ARE THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT HAPPEN WE
DON'T GO BACK AND RE FUND.
PROGRAMS WHEN WE HAVE BUDGET
CUTS AND REBUILD THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
WAS MY NOTE CORRECT THAT
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS INCREASED
70% NUMBER TO DINO COUNTY
CORRECT.
BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN YEAH SOME OF
THE REASONS ARE MEDINA COUNTY
ARE ALARMING -- ONE THAT STANDS
OUT IN MY MIND IS CHLAMYDIA WE
ACTUALLY STAND NUMBER.
FOURTEEN IN THE UNITED STATES.
FOR CHLAMYDIA CASES.
IT'S NOT THE SORT OF THING THAT
WE WANT TO BE KNOWN FOR WELL NO
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR PRESENTING THIS NOT ONLY ON
BEHALF OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
BUT ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS.
IN CALIFORNIA.
DOCTOR WHAT IS CORRECT THIS IS
IT IS ALARMING WE HAVE SEEN A
NUMBER OF PRESENTATIONS.
REGARDING THE INCREASE AND
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES AND THERE
HAS TO BE SOMETHING DONE.
AND INVESTMENT.
INTO THOSE ORGANIZATIONS OR
THOSE DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE ABLE
TO GET A HANDLE ON THIS AND HELP
TO REDUCE THE NUMBERS.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU HONOR TO
BE HERE THANK YOU.
HARM REDUCTION CARE NAVIGATORS.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I HAVE THE NEXT TWO ITEMS
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO PRESENT
THEM TOGETHER OR SEPARATELY.
DO THEM SEPARATELY PLEASE CHECK.
THE FIRST AT I'M LARA THOMAS AND
THE DEPUTY STATE DIRECTOR FOR
THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE AND THE
FIRST REQUEST IS.
TO ADD STAFF TO THE SYRINGE
ACCESS PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE
AS A NO -- YOU'RE WELL AWARE --
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE MIDST OF AN
OVERDOSE CRISIS WERE OVERDOSE IS
NOW THE LEADING CAUSE OF
ACCIDENTAL DEATH IN THE STATE AS
IT IS -- IN THE COUNTRY AS A
WHOLE.
AND IN RESPONSE TO THAT WITH
BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE DOLLARS
CALIFORNIA IS EXPANDING ITS
TREATMENT CAPACITY ESPECIALLY
FOR METHADONE OR BUPRENORPHINE
ACROSS THE STATE.
ARE PROPOSAL TAKES ADVANTAGE OF
THAT TREATMENT CAPACITY BY
PUTTING TREATMENT NAVIGATORS IN
OUR HARM REDUCTION AND SYRINGE
ACCESS PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE.
SO THAT THEY CAN HELP US RANGE
ACCESS PARTICIPANTS NAVIGATE AT
AND SUCCESSFULLY CONNECT WITH.
THIS NEW EXPANDED TREATMENT
CAPACITY I'M MORE ASKING FOR A
TOTAL OF FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO BE SPENT OVER FOUR YEARS.
AND IT WOULD ADD STAFF -- IN
EACH OF THE PROGRAM'S AROUND THE
STATE -- THE STATE OFFICE OF
AIDS IS IN THE PROCESS OF
EXPANDING THE NUMBERS RANGE
ACCESS PROGRAMS -- TO ENSURE
THAT WERE REACHING SOME OF THE
MORE RURAL AREAS THAT HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN REACHED -- BY
THESE IMPORTANT HARM REDUCTION
INTERVENTIONS AND SO WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT NOT ONLY
ARE WE AFFECTIVELY PREVENTING
HIV AND HEPATITIS C.
TRANSMISSION.
BUT THERE WERE ALSO ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS
TO OVERDOSE -- AWARENESS
INFORMATION AND THE LOCKS ON AND
IMPORTANTLY THAT THEY CAN BE
SOME OF THE FOLKS WERE FIRST IN
LINE TO ACCESS THE EXPANDED
TREATMENT CAPACITY -- FOR OPIATE
USE DISORDER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTION THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST A
QUESTION AS YOU AS WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE DID A DISH YOU KNOW
INCREASES IN SYRINGE PROGRAMS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I HEAR --
PRETTY CONSISTENTLY IS -- WITH
MORE SYRINGES BECOMES MORE
SYRINGES IN THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
IS CAUSING -- CONCERNED BY MY
CONSTITUENTS.
ARE THERE PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE
WORKING WITH TO HELP WITH WITH
REGARDS.
TO RETRIEVING AS MANY OF THOSE
SYRINGES AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
THAT IS BECOMING AN INCREASE
THAT IT THAT THAT IS THOUGH.
WITHOUT THAT YOU'RE THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT INCREASED RESISTANCE
TO THESE PROGRAMS WHICH WHICH
WERE WHICH ARE VITAL TO BEING
HELP HELP HELP.
PREVENT DISEASE SO.
IF IT'S NOT THERE IT'S SHOULD
MISS OF A HOBBY CONSIDERING I
THINK.
YES AND THAT'S ABSOLUTELY ONE OF
THE FUNCTIONS THAT -- STAFF ITS
RANGE ACCESS PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE ABLE TO DO IS TO
ASSIST WITH COMMUNITY LEVEL
DISPOSAL EFFORTS AND TO WORK
WITH PARTICIPANTS -- TO COLLECT
SYRINGES IN THE ENVIRONMENT --
MANY OF OUR SYRINGE ACCESS
PROGRAMS ARE ENTIRELY VOLUNTEER
RUN AROUND A VERY SHOE STRING --
BASIS AND DON'T HAVE MUCH
FUNDING FOR STAFFING SO ONE OF
THE WAYS TO IMPROVE SYRINGE
COLLECTION AND DISPOSAL IS TO
INCREASE THE STAFFING LEVELS AT
THESE PROGRAM SO -- PEOPLE CAN
BE OUT IN THE COMMUNITY -- AND
BE RESPONSIVE WHEN COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
IMPROPERLY DISPOSED OF SYRINGES
THAT THEY CAN GO OUT AND HELP
WITH PICK UP AND DISPOSAL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- LET'S DO THE
SUPPLIES CLEARING HOUSE.
SO AT THIS IS -- RELATED --
CURRENTLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS A FUNDING
CLEARING HOUSE SUPPLY CLEARING
HOUSE FOR THIS ORANGE ACCESS
PROGRAMS.
AROUND THE STATE IT'S CURRENTLY
FUNDED AT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
AND WE ARE REQUESTING AN
INCREASE TO SIX MILLION DOLLARS --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
SEEN OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS IS
THIS EXPANSION OF SYRINGE ACCESS
PROGRAMS AND AS A RESULT THERE
ARE RUNNING THROUGH -- SUPPLIES --
QUICKLY AND WE'VE SEEN -- IN A
TWO YEAR PERIOD FOR EXAMPLE A
50% INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS THAT SYRINGE ACCESS
PROGRAMS AROUND THE STATE AND
WITH THAT INCREASE IN NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS.
IS A INCREASE AND DEMAND FOR
SUPPLIES SO -- WE KNOW THAT
SYRINGE ACCESS IS ONE OF THE
SINGLE MOST EFFECTIVE HIV AND
HEPATITIS C. PREVENTION
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE HAVE.
AND THESE PROGRAMS DESPERATELY
NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPLIES -- THE
FUNDING GOES TO THE STATE OFFICE
OF AIDS WITH CENTRALIZED
PURCHASING TO ENSURE THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE GETTING THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE.
SUPPLY AS POSSIBLE AND THAT THE
SMALL SHOESTRING OPERATIONS
DON'T HAVE TO DO THEIR OWN
PURCHASING BUT CAN GO THROUGH
THE STATE AND IT'S REALLY HAD
ENORMOUS ENORMOUS IMPACT ON THE
SUPPLIES AND THE WAY IS THAT
THESE PROGRAMS CAN ENGAGE WITH
THE PARTICIPANTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
LITTLE BY LITTLE LITERACY
PROGRAM EXPANSION [inaudible]
WELCOME.
IT WILL TURN ON AS SOON AS YOU
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
IS IT ON ITS OWN OKAY GREAT.
ALL RIGHT -- CHAIR WOMEN RACE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DOCTOR BLING COLOR.
I AM A PHYSICIAN AND PRESIDENT
OF THE NONPROFIT AGENCY CALLED
SALUTE A HEALTH.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REQUEST FUNDING IN SUPPORT OF A
PROPOSED STATEWIDE EXPANSION OF
THE LITTLE BY LITTLE SCHOOL
READINESS PROGRAM.
LITTLE BY LITTLE IS AN EVIDENCE
BASED EARLY LITERACY PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED THROUGH WICK
CENTERS THAT HAS DEMONSTRATED
GREAT SUCCESS AND A HIGH RETURN
ON INVESTMENT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
THE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION I
LEAD CALLED BALLOON HEALTH
DECIDED TO DEVELOP LITTLE BY
LITTLE BECAUSE IN EARLY RESEARCH
STUDY BY HEART AND RECENTLY.
FOUND THAT BY THREE YEARS OF AGE
THERE IS AN ESTIMATED THIRTY
MILLION WORD GAP IN LANGUAGE
HEARD BETWEEN CHILDREN FROM THE
WEALTHIEST IN THE POOREST
FAMILIES.
THAT LANGUAGE GAP TRANSLATES
INTO LIFELONG EDUCATIONAL
DISPARITIES.
WITH THE SUPPORT SUPPORT FROM
FIRST FIVE LOS ANGELES HELLO TO
HELP LAUNCH LITTLE BY LITTLE IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE IS A PILOT
PROGRAM.
AND OPERATED IN SIX SITES IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
IN ITS FIVE YEAR PILOT PHASE
FROM 200-032-2000 EIGHT LITTLE
BY LITTLE REACHED A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND CHILDREN.
BETWEEN THE AGES OF BIRTH TO
FIVE IMPROVE REMARKABLY
EFFECTIVE.
A STUDY FROM THIS PILOT PHASE
REVEALED THAT WEEK CHILDREN WHO
RECEIVE LITTLE BY LITTLE
SERVICES HAD HIGHER SCHOOL
READINESS AND LANGUAGE SCORES
THAN THOSE WITH CHILDREN WHO HAD
NOT.
WE'RE SUBMITTING A COPY OF THE
RESEARCH PUBLISHED IN PEDIATRICS
FOR YOUR REVIEW.
GIVEN THE EVIDENCE THAT LITTLE
BY LITTLE WORKS FIRST FIVE LA
REFUNDED THE PROGRAM IN TWENTY
TWELVE FOR TEN YEARS.
IN THIS PROGRAM WEEK STAFF ARE
TRAINED AND PROMPTED BASED ON
THE CHILD'S AGE TO EDUCATE
PARENTS PARENTS ON APPROPRIATE
DEVELOPMENTAL MILESTONES AND TO
ENCOURAGE PARENTS TO READ TO AND
WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
FREE HIGH FREE HIGH QUALITY
BOOKS ARE PROVIDED AT EACH VISIT
SO THAT BY THE TIME THE CHILD
ENTERS KINDERGARTEN THEY HAVE
ALREADY RECEIVED A SMALL HOME
LIBRARY OF APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
BOOKS.
BY USING THE WAKE PLATFORM FOR
PROGRAM DELIVERY PROGRAM COSTS
REMAIN LOW AVERAGING ONLY FIFTY
TWO DOLLARS PER CHILD PER YEAR.
WHICH SITES ARE ONE OF THE FEW
PLACES THAT YOUNG FAMILIES VISIT
REGULARLY FROM A MOTHER'S
PREGNANCY THROUGH THE CHILD'S
FIFTH BIRTHDAY.
MAKING THEM UNIQUELY SUITABLE
FOR AN EVIDENCE BASED EARLY
LITERACY PROGRAM LIKE THIS.
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE LITTLE BY
LITTLE HAS SERVED OVER A HUNDRED
NINETY SIX THOUSAND UNIQUE
INDIVIDUALS AND DISTRIBUTED
NEARLY A MILLION BOOKS.
HELLO TO HEALTH BELIEVES THAT
WHEN PARENTS BECOME ENGAGED
EARLY IN THEIR CHILD'S EDUCATION
AND WHEN CHILDREN ARE GIVEN
EQUAL ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY THEY
WILL THRIVE.
AND WE ALL BENEFIT FROM A MORE
EDUCATED AND MORE PRODUCTIVE.
OF SOCIETY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
LET ME JUST SAY THAT YOU'LL SEE
A RANGE OF FUNDING SUBMITTED
FROM ONE POINT SEVEN TO THIRTY
SIX POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR.
WHAT WE SUPPORT SCALING
STATEWIDE IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE OF
NEED WHICH WOULD BE THE TOTAL
COST OF THIRTY SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION BEING MINDFUL OF COST WE
HAVE SUBMITTED ALTERNATIVE
BUDGETS? TO FUNDED PLANNING YEAR
OR A PLANNING YOUR WITH AN
INITIAL SCALE TO FIVE SITES
THROUGHOUT THE SITE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FOR THREE
POINT EIGHT MILLION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I LIKE
TO THINK ASSEMBLY WOMAN BLANCA
RUBIO WHO HAS SHARED A LETTER OF
SUPPORT AND BEEN A CHAMPION OF
THIS PROGRAM AS WELL I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
I TO SAY THAT -- WE'RE WE'RE
VERY LUCKY THAT WE HAVE FAR
SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON WHO PUT
TOGETHER THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION CHILD CARE.
AND ALSO OUR GOVERNOR WHO IS
TAKING A GREAT INTEREST IN OUR
CHILDREN.
AND THE THE FACT THAT THERE'S A
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR THIRTY
MILLION WORD TO GAP BY AGE THREE
BETWEEN.
THOSE CHILDREN WHO HAVE AND
THOSE WHO HAVE NOT -- IS
SOMETHING THAT TO I APPRECIATE
THE TO HAVE WORKED VERY HARD AT
LEAST IN A LA COUNTY.
I'M GLAD FOR THE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE FIRST FIVE
THAT HAVE.
STEPPED UP IN SOME OF THE OTHER
AREAS.
IT'S A IT'S A SERVICE THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY NEED IT I THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR WHAT YOU DO THANK
YOU IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE
THANK YOU.
L. V. Q. WOMEN'S HEALTH
.
GOOD EVENING.
MY NAME ISTERRA RUSSELL SLAVE
AND I'M DIRECTOR OF POLICY AT
THE LOS ANGELES LGBT CENTER.
AND I'M REPRESENTING A BROAD
COALITION OF LGBT ORGANIZATIONS
SOCIAL SERVICE AND HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES WE ARE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE FOR FAR TOO LONG.
LESBIAN BISEXUAL QUEEN QUEER
WOMEN'S HEALTH HAS BEEN
INVISIBLE WITHIN HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS DESPITE FACING
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH DISPARITIES
AND BARRIERS TO CARE. ONE INTO
LESBIAN BISEXUAL QUEER WOMEN
EXPERIENCE DISCRIMINATION AND
HEALTH CARE. 30% HAVE DELAYED
CARE IN THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS
EVEN WHEN THEY HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE.
YET RESEARCH SHOWS THAT LESBIAN
BISEXUAL QUEER WOMEN HAVE
INCREASED RATES OF DISABILITY.
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
DEPRESSION.
ARE MORE LIKELY TO SMOKE AND
DRINK IN FACT I'LL BE CUTE GIRLS
ARE FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
YOU HAVE SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES.
HAVE INCREASED PREDICTIVE
FACTORS FOR CANCER AND BECAUSE
OF DILL PLAYED SCREENING HIGHER
MORTALITY ONE CLAN AT THE CENTER
AFTER HOMOPHOBIC EXPERIENCE
DURING A PAP SMEAR.
AT A AT HER FIRST OBGYN.
DIDN'T GO BACK FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS UNTIL SHE FINALLY CAME TO
THE CENTER SHE NOW HAS STAGE
FOUR CANCER CERVICAL CANCER.
THE SITUATION IS EVEN MORE DIRE
FOR LESBIAN BISEXUAL QUEER WOMEN
OF COLOR OLDER ADULTS ENTRANCE
L. B. Q. WOMEN.
WE ARE ASKING CALIFORNIA TO LEAD
THE NATION BY ALLOCATING
SEVENTEEN AND A HALF MILLION IN
GENERAL FUNDS TO CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA LESBIAN BISEXUAL
QUEER WOMEN'S HEALTH EQUITY FUND.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH THIS WILL BE
THE FIRST EVER TARGETED EFFORT
TO DRESS WHAT IS OFTEN BEEN A
VERY INVISIBLE POPULATION WITH
AND HEALTH CARE SETTINGS.
THE CORE COMPONENTS INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR INNOVATIVE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS WITH A
VALUATION LOCALIZE COMMUNITY
NEEDS ASSESSMENT COMMUNITY
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND RESEARCH.
WE'VE PROVIDED A SIGN A LETTER
WITH MORE THAN FORTY
ORGANIZATIONAL SUPPORTERS IN
YOUR SURVEY YOU SHALL BE
RECEIVING A LETTER FROM THE LGBT
CAUCUS.
AND WE HAVE DROPPED UP HUNDREDS
OF POSTCARDS FROM COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AS WELL AS LETTERS WE'VE
COLLECTED THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
I THANK YOU ISN'T TATIAN.
LIQUID SUGAR RESEARCH GRANTS.
GOOD EVENING GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS DOCTOR FAUCHON CO FOR
AND I'M A SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
POLICY WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES.
AND WE ARE PLEASED TO REQUEST A
ONE TIME ALLOCATION OF SIX POINT
NINE ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH DIVISION OF CHRONIC
DISEASE AN INJURY CONTROL.
UP TO ISSUE AND ADMINISTER A
RESEARCH REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS
TO CALIFORNIA BASED ACADEMIC AND
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS.
THE RP WILL SOLICIT PROPOSALS TO
CONDUCT A RANDOMIZED CLINICAL
TRIAL TO DETERMINE WHETHER SUGAR
IN LIQUID FORM CAUSES MORE
DETRIMENTAL HEALTH EFFECTS THAN
SUGAR IN SOLID FORM.
EXAMINING SOME OF THOSE
INTERMEDIATE CHANGES THAT
EXISTING BIOMARKERS.
NEARLY ALL OF THE CLINICAL
STUDIES THAT EXISTS TO DATE HAVE --
DOCUMENTED ADVERSE HEALTH
EFFECTS OF SUGAR CONSUMPTION
THAT HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON SUGARY
DRINKS HOWEVER A SUGARY DRINKS
ARE NOT THE ONLY FORM OF SUGAR
IN OUR DIETS APPROXIMATELY 60%
OF ADDED SUGAR IS CONSUMED FROM
SOLID FOODS.
AND THIS PROPORTION MAY INCREASE
WITH RECENT PUBLIC HEALTH
INITIATIVES FOCUS ON DECREASING
CONSUMPTION OF SUGARY DRINKS.
AND SO ALTHOUGH THERE'S EVIDENCE
OF THE HARMFUL EFFECTS OF SUGARY
DRINKS THAT'S WELL DOCUMENTED
THERE ARE NO WILL PUBLISH
DIETARY INTERVENTION STUDIES
LASTING MORE THAN ONE DAY THAT
HAVE DIRECTLY COMPARED THE
EFFECT.
OF SOLID SUGAR AND LIQUID SUGAR
ON RISK FACTORS FOR
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE AND TYPE
TWO DIABETES AND SO THIS
PROPOSAL SEEKS TO REMEDY THAT
GAP IN THE LITERATURE BY
CONDUCTING A RANDOMIZED CLINICAL
TRIAL.
COMPARING THE TWO YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU AND IT MAY HAVE BEEN
IN THE YOUR OTHER.
INFORMATION BUT WHO WILL BE
DOING THE STUDY.
THE STUDY WOULD BE CONDUCTED BY
CALIFORNIA BASED ACADEMIC --
INSTITUTIONS SO BE A REQUEST FOR
PROPOSALS THAT WOULD BE OVERSEEN
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
Q..
THE QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PROPOSAL.
SOMETHING THE NEXT ONE YES I AM.
THANK YOU BEVERAGE AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN.
YES.
THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THE DIVISION OF CHRONIC
DISEASE AND INJURY CONTROL
NUTRITION EDUCATION AND OBESITY
PREVENTION BRANCH.
RECEIVE A ONE TIME ALLOCATION OF
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO BE SPENT OVER
THIRTY SIX MONTHS. TO ISSUE A
STATEWIDE COMMUNITY GRANTS -- TO
CALIFORNIA ORGANIZATIONS FOR
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGE
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN.
WE HAVE LOTS OF EVIDENCE --
DEMONSTRATING THE CONSUMPTION OF
SUGARY DRINKS IS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE MERE IDEA OF HEALTH
CONDITIONS -- THE TOTALITY OF
EVIDENCE HAS LED TO MAKE MAJOR
CHANGES IN THE US DIETARY
GUIDELINES AND FOOD THE FOOD
LABELING REGULATIONS -- TO
PROMOTE LOWER SUGAR CONSUMPTION
HOWEVER MANY CONSUMERS ARE
UNAWARE THAT STUDENTS ARE JACK
ARE AWARE THAT SOLDIERS ARE
GENERALLY AND HEALTHY -- YET
THEY MAY BE UNAWARE OF THE
EXTENT OF THE HEALTH IMPACT --
SUCH AS THAT ONE SUGARY DRINK A
DAY INCREASES THEIR RISK OF
CAVITIES TO FULL DIABETES 26%
AND OBESITY BY 55%.
AND FURTHER MORE -- MANY
CONSUMERS INCLUDING PARENTS ARE
UNAWARE THAT THERE'S A BROAD
CLASSIFICATION OF DRINKS THAT
ARE SUGARY DRINKS BEYOND JUST
OTIS -- INCLUDING ENERGY DRINKS
AND SPORTS DRINKS AND OTHER
TYPES OF DRINKS AND SO WE'VE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DETERMINE
THROUGH THE RESEARCH THAT I'M
PROVIDING THIS INFORMATION
ACTUALLY HELPS PARENTS MAKE
DIFFERENT DECISIONS.
AND SO THE CAMPAIGN WOULD EMPLOY
A MULTI PRONGED APPROACH
COMBINING SOCIAL MEDIA AND
TARGETED GRASSROOTS MESSAGING TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE AWARE
OF THE HEALTH IMPLICATIONS OF
SUGARY -- DRINKS THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY DRINKS WITH
ADDED SUGAR AND THAT -- THEY'RE
ABLE TO ALSO APPROPRIATELY READ --
NUTRITION CONTENT LABELS AND SO
THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR IT -- AGAIN
COMPETITIVE GRANTS TO EXIST FOR
CALIFORNIA ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE DOING OUTREACH TO
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO
EDUCATE THEM ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF SUGARY DRINKS HOW
TO IDENTIFY THEM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
NO I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
THIS CONCLUDES ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE WILL OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
MADAM CHAIR DR WOULD RANDOM ARE
NOT BE HAVE THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF BOTH
THE HIV AND AIDS CV PREVENTION
PROPOSALS THANK YOU.
TOM RENT FREE WITH COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT OF THE
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE AND THE
HARM REDUCTION COALITION --
REQUESTS FOR HARM REDUCTION CARE
NAVIGATORS AND THE HARM
REDUCTION SUPPLIES CLEARING
HOUSE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE GIVENS AT THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HERE AT IN SUPPORT OF
THE FIFTY MILLION FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PUBLIC HEALTH LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BUDGET ASK WANTED
TO JUST UNDERSCORE THE COMMENTS
OF MY MEMBER AROUND THE CRITICAL
NEED FOR THIS FUNDING AND
FLEXIBILITY THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
LARA THOMAS DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FULL
ENDING EPIDEMICS PACKAGE --
ESPECIALLY THE HEPATITIS C. N.
H. A. B. PREVENTION COMPONENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO MY IN HER HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN MATEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELENE MAZHAR MAY HAVE TO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES WE SUPPORT BOTH THE
HARM REDUCTION -- NAVIGATOR OF
POSTAL AS WELL AS THE HARM
REDUCTION SUPPLY --
CLEARINGHOUSE PROPOSED BY THE
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOE HEY WOULD WITH
THE NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE HARM REDUCTION CARE
NAVIGATORS.
THE HARM REDUCTION SUPPLY
CLEARING HOUSE AND THE FULL AND
THE EPIDEMICS PACKAGE HIV
HEPATITIS C. AND S. T. D.
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT BUDGET
REQUEST.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS OUR FELLOW MERA IN
THE CO FOUNDER AND PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF INLAND EMPIRE HARM
REDUCTION OUT OF RIVERSIDE.
IN SUPPORT OF THE HARM REDUCTION
NAVIGATOR -- ASK THE HARM
REDUCTION THAT SPIKE CLEARING
HOUSE ASKING ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE AND THE EPIDEMICS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DENISE LOPEZ
AND I'M WITH HIV EDUCATION AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM.
OF ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THAT HARM REDUCTION
CARE NAVIGATORS.
AND THAT HARM REDUCTION SUPPLIES
CLEARINGHOUSE AND I'M ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THAT.
HABSI PREVENTION AND HIV
PREVENTION.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOLLARS
BLANCHARD I'M A VOLUNTEER
DIRECTOR OF THE FRESNO NEEDLE
EXCHANGE PROGRAM.
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CARE NAVIGATORS AND THE SUPPLY
CLEARING HOUSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MANUALLY ON BEHALF
OF THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL REGISTERING OUR
OPPOSITION FOR ISSUE NUMBER.
TWELVE THE BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS -- BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR THE SAFER COSMETICS
PROGRAM ALSO REGISTERING
OPPOSITION FOR THE C. MTA.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH IN STRIP
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
HI AMY CAME HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE PROVIDER FOR THE
LOS ANGELES LGBT CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF THE L. B. Q. BUDGET
OFFICE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING ADAM RIGHTLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SAFER -- COSMETIC PROGRAM BUDGET --
PROPOSAL ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE FRAGRANCE CREATORS
ASSOCIATION ALSO OPPOSED TO THAT
SAME MEASURE THINGS. FOR MY
DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH BUDGET
INFRASTRUCTURE ASK.
THANK YOU.
THE ACTUAL MAC WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE HYPERTENSION
PILOT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
SURE IT IS CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM
OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT OF THE
HARM REDUCTION CARE NAVIGATORS
OF PROGRAM AND THE HARM
REDUCTION SUPPLIES CLEARING
HOUSE.
AND IN SUPPORT -- ON BEHALF OF
THE OF NOW GOT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF LGBT Q. ADDICTION
PROVIDERS IN SUPPORT OF THE LP
HUGH WOMEN'S HEALTH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALEX TO CAPRI ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THE LITTLE BY LITTLE EARLY
LITERACY PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
VICTOR CHRISTY WITH CALIFORNIA
OFFICE ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF
COMMITTEE HEALTH CENTERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE FARM WORKER
HEALTH STUDY.
AND THE HYPERTENSION CONTROL
PILOT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING PROPOSAL
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF LOS ANGELES.
RIVERSIDE SANTA CLARA SANTA CRUZ
AND VENTURA COUNTIES
ADDITIONALLY OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SUPPORTS THE FUNDING FOR STD
PREVENTION HABSI PREVENTION.
HIV PREVENTION AND THE L. B. Q.
WOMEN'S EQUITY FUND.
ERIN FOX LOS ANGELES LGBT CENTER
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE S.
U. V. PREVENTION ASK THE PEPSI
PREVENTION ASKING ME.
HIV PREVENTION ASK CONSTANTLY
ENDING THE EPIDEMICS BUDGET ASK
WERE ALSO IN FAVOR OF BOTH OF
THE HARM REDUCTION PROPOSALS.
AND ALSO THE L. B. Q. WOMEN'S
HEALTH BUDGET PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
AND ONLY ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA HEPATITIS
ALLIANCE WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
AND THE EPIDEMICS PACKAGE FOR
STDS HIV.
AND HEPATITIS C. PREVENTION.
WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE FARM
HEALTH FARM WORKER HEALTH STUDY
AND BOTH OF THE HARM REDUCTION
PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU.
CAN YOU MUST BURKE WITH CENTRAL
ACCESS HELP SUPPORTING THE STD
PREVENTION PROPOSAL TO HELP SEE
PROPOSAL AND THE HIV PREVENTION
PURPLES.
THANK YOU.
LINDA TENER WHAT'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN I THINK HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF THE FARM
WORKER -- HEALTH STUDY AS WELL
AS THE L. B. Q. WOMEN'S EQUITY
FUND.
THANK YOU.
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGE AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN AS PRESENTED BY PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT OF
THE FARM WORKER HEALTH STUDY.
THANK YOU.
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
OF THE AND THE EPIDEMICS
PROPOSALS INCLUDING BLEEDING TO
STD PREVENTION HEPATITIS C.
PREVENTION AND HIV PREVENTION.
AS WELL AS THE I'LL BE Q.
WOMEN'S HEALTH PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
RESET BENTLEY BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SAVE FOR A
CONCERT -- COSMETICS PRODUCTS
PUT A BUDGET ALSO. FOR OUR
SUPPORTERS WE HAVE FORTY ONE
NGOS AND TWENTY COMPANIES
INCLUDING THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS -- COMPANIES
BEAUTY COUNTER CALIFORNIA BABY.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC INTEREST
RESEARCH GROUP CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ASTHMA COLLABORATIVE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
CRUNCHY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP EO PRODUCTS.
AND UPS THE THAT AN RTC REGIONAL
ASTHMA MANAGEMENT PROGRAM AND
WORK SAFE AND MY NAME'S
KATHERINE BEACH I'M ALSO FROM
BASIC PP.
THANK YOU.
ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF HAS HE I
YOU CALIFORNIANS.
IN SUPPORT OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
LANGUAGE PROPOSAL AND ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE BOTH A HARM
REDUCTION PROPOSALS TO PEER
NAVIGATORS AND THE CLEARING
HOUSE.
THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM ALL SPEAKING FOR
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT OF THE FORMER
TO HEALTH DATA PROPOSAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING AMANDA MCALLISTER
WONDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LGBT
Q. HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF THAT THREE
ENDING THE EPIDEMICS --
PROPOSALS TO AND HIV OR
HEPATITIS C. AND STDS -- THE TO
HARM REDUCTION PROPOSALS AND THE
LESBIAN BISEXUAL AND CLEAR
WOMEN'S.
HEALTH EQUITY FUND.
CAT TO BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUND THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
KAREN FARLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WITH ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE WHOLE LUNA HEALTH LITTLE BY
LITTLE EARLY LITERACY PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
WHEN SPENCER BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OBGYN IS JUST
NINE IN SUPPORT OF THE STATE
BECAUSE MEDIC PROGRAM PROPOSAL
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS?
IN SPORT EIGHT CB PREVENTION
PROPOSAL THE H. I. V. PREVENTION
PROPOSAL AND THE COMPANY HEALTH
IS ACTIVE SO SHE'S IN CALIFORNIA
HOA PROPOSAL FROM PROOF PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING GOING BACK IS FOR
HER REDUCTION SERVICES IN
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT OF THE
HARM REDUCTION PROPOSALS AND THE
ANY EPIDEMICS PROPOSALS THANK
YOU.
I AM STEVEN MARTIN CHRONIC
CANCER HEALTH ADVOCATE AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THE STD
PREVENTION AND HEPATITIS C.
PREVENTION HIV.
PREVENTION -- HOT BOTH HARM
REDUCTION CARE NAVIGATORS THAT
I'LL BE Q. -- COALITION A
PROPOSAL -- I ALSO WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SAY PROGRAM SAVE MY LIFE
THE BLOOD TEST THAT THEY GAVE ME
IDENTIFIED A CHRONIC CANCER THAT
I HAD. TO THESE PROGRAMS ARE
VERY VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND
ALSO THE PRESS -- THE SORRY.
THERE'S SOME AT THE STATE
BECAUSE MEDICS PROGRAM USED TO
WORKING I WORK.
I HAVE WORKED IN GREEN BE THE
FOR A LONG TIME IT'S HIGH TIME
THAT THE COSMETICS INDUSTRY BE
TAKEN ON BURKE THE CHEMICAL YOU
THINK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
LET'S GO [inaudible]
TO ISSUE
.
THIRTEEN AND I'M RELATED TO THIS
SPECIFIC ISSUE -- BUT SINCE DH
CS DIRECTORS HERE -- I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK YOU AND
DH CS. FOR PROVIDING INFORMATION
AND A PLAN FOR DRESSING THE
PROBLEMS WITH THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BUT BASED ALTERNATIVES
WAIVER.
THESE CONCERNS WERE RAISED AT
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S HEARING ON
APRIL TWENTY SECOND.
AND THE SUBCOMMITTEE REQUESTED
DH CS TO SUBMIT A CORRECTIVE
PLAN ACT CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN.
BY TODAY.
AND DH CS DID EXACTLY THAT.
WELL I HAVE NOT HAD A CHANCE YET
TO REVIEW THE INFORMATION
THOROUGHLY.
IT APPEARS A DH CS IS TAKING
THESE ISSUES QUITE SERIOUSLY AND
ADDRESSING THEM AGGRESSIVELY
WHICH IS EXACTLY.
WHAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE HOPED YOU
WOULD DO I THANK YOU?
OUR DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES -- AND JUST TO FOLLOW
UP ON YOUR COMMENTS WE
APPRECIATE -- THE FACT THAT YOU
GUYS GOT THE REPORT -- AND AS OF
TONIGHT WE HAVE MADE CONTACT
WITH TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THREE OUT OF TWO HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT OF THE CHILDREN THAT ARE
ON THE WAIT LIST SO WE HAD 95%.
CONTACT AND HAVE ASSESSMENT SO
WE'RE WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS
THANK YOU -- SO US.
TALKING ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S I
VALUE BASED -- PROGRAM PROPOSAL
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET -- THIS IS
A REALLY EXCITING -- OPPORTUNITY
FOR US USING APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
FUNDING -- SO FOR THE FIRST TIME
WE ARE PROPOSING -- TO GO DOWN
TO THE PROVIDER LEVEL IN WHICH
WE'RE PROVIDING SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS TO PROVIDERS THAT MAKE --
DEMONSTRATED CHANGES IN CERTAIN
CATEGORIES OF OPPORTUNITY THAT
WE REALLY WANT TO SEE PROGRESS
MADE IN TERMS OF TREATING
PATIENTS AND SO REFLECTIVE.
OF SOME OF THE PRIORITIES THAT
THE GOVERNOR FELT WERE IMPORTANT --
TO IN CAPS LEE IN HIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL WE HAVE FOUR MAIN
CATEGORIES -- WHICH OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INTEGRATION
PRE AND POSTNATAL CARE --
CHRONIC DISEASE MANAGEMENT AND
EARLY CHILDHOOD INITIATIVE AND
SO BACK IN MARCH WE HAD RELEASE
FOR STAKEHOLDER -- FEEDBACK AND
REVIEW -- SEVERAL DIFFERENT
MEASURES -- IN EACH OF THOSE
CATEGORIES SO FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
PRENATAL AND POST PARTUM CARE --
TALKING ABOUT -- VACCINES --
DOING PRENATAL PROCESSES
VACCINES PRENATAL CARE VISITS
POST PARTUM CARE VISITS.
POST PARTUM DEPRESSION SCREENING
AND POST PARTUM BIRTH CONTROL --
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD WELL CHILD
VISITS -- FOR CERTAIN SEGMENTS
OF THE PROPOSED -- PERIODICITY
SCHEDULE IN WHICH WERE LOOKING
TO INCREASE UTILIZATION IN THOSE
AREAS.
ALL CHILDHOOD VACCINES FOR TWO
YEAR OLD SUPPORT LED SCREENING
AND DENTAL FLUORIDE VARNISH. FOR
CHRONIC DISEASE MANAGEMENT WE
IDENTIFIED CONTROLLING HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE SO TO THE
TESTIMONY EARLIER AROUND
HYPERTENSION PROGRAM -- DIABETES
CARE CONTROL OF PERSISTENT
ASTHMA TOBACCO USE SCREENING AND
ADULT INFLUENCE OF VACCINES.
AND THEN LASTLY -- THE ONE
THAT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
CHALLENGING FOR US THAT I THINK
WE REALLY DO FEEL -- THERE'S A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITY THERE IS
AROUND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INTEGRATION -- SOME OF THE
CHALLENGE IN THIS IS THAT
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF CLINICAL
MEASURES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED IN THIS AREA.
BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT SCREENING
FOR CLINICAL DEPRESSION
MANAGEMENT OF DEPRESSION
MEDICATION SCREENING FOR
UNHEALTHY ALCOHOL USE AND THEN
CO LOCATION OF PRIMARY CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES --
THE RESPNSES WHEN WE RELEASED
BOTH THESE PROPOSED MEASURES AS
WELL AS THE TRAILER BILL WE GOT
A LOT OF REALLY THOUGHTFUL
FEEDBACK -- THERE WAS SOME
ADDITIONAL -- ITEMS THAT WE
THINK HAVE VALUE AND WILL MOST
LIKELY BE -- MAKING SOME CHANGES
THAT WILL BE REFLECTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S ME REVISIONS AROUND
SOME OF THE MEASURE SO WE REALLY
DO ACKNOWLEDGE -- SOME OF THE
THOUGHTFUL FEEDBACK THAT WE GOT
FROM STAKEHOLDERS ESPECIALLY
AROUND CERTAIN CHRONIC DISEASES --
AS IT PERTAINS TO THE TRAILER
BILL PROPOSAL -- IT'S IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL WANT TO
HAVE FURTHER ONGOING DIALOGUE
WITH BOTH THE STAKEHOLDERS BUT
ALSO WE HAVE TO BACK INTO THESE
PAYMENTS -- THROUGH OUR MANAGED
CARE CAPITATION RATES SO WE
DON'T HAVE DOLLAR AMOUNTS
PROPOSED AT THIS TIME JUST
BECAUSE WE STILL NEED TO KIND OF
LOOK THROUGH THE DIFFERENT
MEASURES THAT WE SETTLE ON AND
THEN THERE'S A MUCH MORE -- KIND
OF FINANCIAL PAYMENT PROCESS
THAT WE HAVE TO WORK WITH OUR
HEALTH PLANS AND OUR ACTUARIES
AND THEN THAT ALL HAS TO GET
APPROVED.
THROUGH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS ATTRACTED PAYMENT SO THE
TRAILER BILL REALLY DOES REFLECT
SOME OF THE NEED FOR FEDERAL
APPROVAL BUT ALSO KIND OF THE
BROAD.
YOU KNOW WAY IN WHICH WE INTEND
TO APPLY THESE PAYMENT SO --
WITHOUT I'M I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- BEN JOHNSON WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WE REALLY WELCOME THE EFFORT TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES AND IN WITHIN
THE MEDI CAL SYSTEM INCLUDING
AND IN IN MANAGED CARE WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
OVERLAP BETWEEN THE VALUE BASED
PAYMENTS AND THE MEASURES THAT
WE'VE GOT BE PAYING SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS.
ON BEHALF AND MANY OF THE
MEASURES THAT -- DH CS IS
PLANNING TO INCREASE ENFORCEMENT
ON THROUGH ITS OVERSIGHT OF
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND SO WE DO
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
COST EFFECTIVENESS OF PROVIDING
BOTH SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS.
AND INCREASED OVERSIGHT ON
BEHALF OF MANY OF THE SAME
MEASURES -- AND THAT THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS BUT HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY MORE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WEATHER PERMITTING HIS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
LET'S OPEN IT UP TO THE PUBLIC.
ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTEEN LINDA TENER WHAT'S OF
THE CALIFORNIA OF HANNAH THINK
HEALTH NETWORK -- WE JUST WANNA
APPLAUD THE DEPARTMENT -- THE
COMMITMENT TO ADOPTING A VALUE
BASED PAYMENT PROGRAM -- HOWEVER
WE WOULD REQUEST OF THE
DEPARTMENT INCLUDE --
DISPARITIES SENSITIVE METRICS --
THAT DEMONSTRATE.
A REDUCTION IN HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND THAT AND THAT
TEACH YES CONSULT WITH THE BROAD --
SET OF STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
MECHANICS OF WHAT THAT COULD
LOOK LIKE -- SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AND WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO COME TO
A WORKABLE SOLUTION TO ACHIEVE
THOSE BENCHMARKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- VICTOR CHRISTY WITH
CALVIN HELPLESS ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS --
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THEY SURE
IS FULL -- ELVIS PAYMENT
PARTICIPATION FOR ALL MEDICAL
PROVIDERS AS FOR THE NOTE AS THE
AGENDA NOTES WELL IT IS TRUE
THAT AFTER HE SEES DO RECEIVE.
A UNIQUE PPS RATE -- THAT
RECOGNIZES THE INTEGRATED CARE
THEY PROVIDE THIS RATE WAS NEVER
MEANT TO BE NOR SHOULD IT BE A
BARRIER TO HEALTH CENTERS
PARTICIPATING IN INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS.
IT'S A MATTER EQUALITY FOR ALL
MEDICAL PATIENTS IN THE
PROVIDERS THAT SERVE THEM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
EFFORT AROUND THE IVIES
PURCHASING AN EYELINER COMMENTS
WITH THE PEN.
RELATED TO HEALTH DISPARITIES
AND THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
THANK YOU.
KELLY BE MY BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU FOR THAT FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS I'M ALLOWED SO OF
FEEDBACK TO BE PROVIDED AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL
OF YOU IN CHOOSING THIS MEASURES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SMALLER OF SOME OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES CALIFORNIA
THIS IS UNRELATED TO THE VALUE
BASED PROPOSAL BUT RELATED TO
PROP.
FIFTY SIX I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THAT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD CONTINUES TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DOUBLE
PROP FIFTY SIX THING.
BUT AS DISCUSSED DURING FEBRUARY
TWENTY FIFTH HEARING WE SUPPORT
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT BUT REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S
ALLOCATION OF THE FUNDS --
PROPOSING THAT IT ALSO WOULD BE
INVESTED IN FAMILY PLANNING
RELATEDPROCEDURES EDUCATION AND
COUNSELING AND OTHER SPECIFIC
HIGH SERVICE NEEDS LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
THE DEPARTMENT ON THIS ISSUE.
AND JUST WANTED TO PROVIDE A
QUICK UPDATE SINCE I WAS HEARD
SO.
SO EARLY IN THE PROCESS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THAT CONCLUDES ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN I THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION -- ON ISSUE NUMBER
FOURTEEN DH CS STOCKHOLDER
PROPOSALS.
WHY DON'T WE HEAR FROM APPS ME
THE MEDI CAL?
ICAL INTERPRETERS PILOT PROGRAM.
MADAM CHAIR MISTER WOULD --
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WHO ARE NOT HERE RIGHT NOW --
BRIAN NELSON ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES --
AND WE ARE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL --
TO YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR H. AND ON
THE TH AND IN THE EYES AND THIS --
CRITICAL STATE CALLED A REQUEST
FOR DISCUSSION -- WE WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE FOR MANY YEARS
TO LAUNCH A PILOT PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA STUDY THE
COMPREHENSIVELY ASSESS -- WELL
KNOWN DEFICIENCIES IN LIVERY OF
MEDICARE -- MEDICAL
INTERPRETATION SERVICES -- IN
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM -- DOING OUR
WORK DURING THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN BUDGET PROCESS ON THIS
ISSUE.
A NUMBER OF LEGISLATIVE LEADERS
AND CONSTITUENCY CAUCUSES --
WERE CLEARED AND NOT ONLY DID
STAGE STATE LEGISLATORS --
UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE BUT
INTENDED TO ACTIVELY WORK WITH
US AND OTHERS IN THE STAKEHOLDER
COMMUNITY.
TO STUDY THE EXTENT OF LACK OF
ACCESS TO INTERPRETATION
SERVICES AND TO WORK TO
IMPLEMENT POLICY.
AND HIGH NEED COMMUNITIES THAT
WOULD PROVIDE AND EVALUATE THE
PROVISION OF IN PERSON MEDICAL
INTERPRETER SERVICES -- WILD
THIS STATUE SLATED TO GO INTO
EFFECT ON JAN WHERE ONE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES DID NOT
RELEASE AN RP INTO APRIL -- TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND THE THE
PARCHMENT WASN'T ABLE.
TO SELECT A VICE A VENDOR TO
CONDUCT THE STUDY UNTIL DECEMBER
OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THEY
FINALIZE AN AGREEMENT EARLIER
THIS YEAR -- BUT GIVING THE
GIVEN THE STATUES EXPLORATION IN
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY WE
RECENTLY CONCERNED AT THIS LEAVE
VIRTUALLY NO TIME TO CONDUCT AN
ADEQUATE AND LEGITIMATE PILOT
PROJECT -- ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THE DEPARTMENT'S
INTERPRETATION OF THE ORIGINAL
LANGUAGE PREVENTS US FROM
ESTABLISHING A PILOT PROJECT
UNTIL THE STUDY IS COMPLETE --
WE WERE SURPRISED TO LEARN
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF OUR WORK
EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AS EXHAUSTED ALL OF THE
FUNDS FOR BOTH THE STUDY AND THE
PILOT PROJECT THAT WAS ALLOCATED
IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ON THE
STUDY PORTION OF THE STATUTE
ALONE -- SO WE ARE BEFORE YOU
TODAY WITH THE REQUEST FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME THAT
FOR FEELS WE BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT -- WITH THE
PREVIOUS STATUE AND ENSURE THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE A MEANINGFUL
PILOT PROJECT THAT IS PROPERLY
FUNDED -- WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE ADEQUATE --
FUNDS AVAILABLE -- TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN DO A PROPER
EVALUATION OF LACK OF ACCESS IN
THIS COMMUNITY SO -- WE WERE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION -- TO
BEGIN -- TO IMPLEMENT POLITICS
AND STATE CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
QUESTION COMMENT.
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR CALL WAY
YET.
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING
THIS TO TO TO THE COMMITTEE.
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT WHAT'S
IS IT FOR THE THE MONEY WAS PUT
THERE FOR THE STUDY AND OF THE
PILOT IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN THERE
FOR BOTH THE STUDY IN THE PILOT.
AND I KNOW THAT -- PRESIDENT PRO
TEM ATKINS IS A BIG ADVOCATE OF
THIS MAKING SURE THAT THE
INTENTION WITH THE INTENT.
OF HER LEGISLATION BECOME WE CAN
BE COMPLETED AND THAT THE PILOT
TO BE FUNDED SO THAT.
WHATEVER WAS FOUND IN THE STUDY
CAN BE IMPLEMENTED SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
AND NARCOTIC TREATMENT PROGRAMS
REIMBURSEMENT CODES.
THAT'S A MOUTHFUL KEY PIECE.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT THAT MEANS
YOU ACTUALLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT LESS DOESN'T HAPPEN ALL
THE TIME WHEN WHEN WE TESTIFIED
BEFORE THE GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M ABLE GRANT
I'M WHICH ALCHEMY IS WE ARE THE
MAKER OF LONG ATING INJECTABLE
NOT TRACKS ON ORDER THE TROLL --
THE PROS PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU IS
FOR BUDGET CONTROL LANGUAGE THAT
DOES TWO THINGS.
NUMBER ONE IT PROVIDES AUTHORITY
AND DIRECTION FOR DH CS TO
PROVIDE.
REIMBURSEMENT CODE CREATION AND
RATE SETTING FOR NECESSARY
PATIENT SUPPORT SERVICES FOR ALL
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENTS
IN NARCOTIC TREATMENT PROGRAMS
AND T. PIECE.
SOMETHING THE DEPARTMENT
SPECIFICALLY ASKED FOR LAST YEAR.
NUMBER TWO EIGHT REQUEST DH CS
TO IDENTIFY FUNDING NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT PATIENT SUPPORT SUCH A
PSYCHO SOCIAL SERVICES ESTING
AND PROVIDER FEES AND ADVISED
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE ON
HOW MUCH FUNDING IN IN FACT IS
NEEDED TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
PROCESS.
INITIAL ESTIMATES WERE FOR
NOMINAL FINDINGS BUT DH CS HAS
SUGGESTED THAT LACK OF FUNDING
IS THE SECOND REASON THAT THIS
HAS NOT MOVED FORWARD.
WE BELIEVE THIS PROPOSAL ALIGNS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT STATED GOAL
OF EXPANDING MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT THE DEPARTMENT
SPECIFICALLY HAS AWARDED A STATE
OPIATE RESPONSE GRANT FOR ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
TRAINING. TO AND TEEPEES THE
FACILITIES WERE SPEAKING OUT
TODAY TO EXPAND THE CAPACITY TO
USE MATT AND SPECIFICALLY
REFERENCING NOT TRUCKS ON THE
GOAL OF EXPANDING CAPACITY TO
USE THE MEDICATION WHEN THERE'S
NO REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE
SERVICES ASSOCIATED SIMPLY DOES
NOT MAKE SENSE.
WE NEED THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IF THE DEPARTMENT IS TRAINING
PROVIDERS TO USE NO TRACKS ON
AND SPENDING STATE DOLLARS TO
EXPAND CAPACITY FOR THE HOUSTON
ALL TRUCKS ON THAT PROVIDERS ARE
REIMBURSED FOR THE SERVICES THEY
PROVIDE RELATED TO PRESCRIBING
UP TRUCKS ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
ANY QUESTIONS NOT IT WAS A GREAT
PRESENTATION LOOK NO QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION.
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS C.
R. C.'S
.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
SORT OF ANALOGOUS TO A DAY IN
THE LIFE OF THE FAMILY CARE
GIVER IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ALONG WITH MANY TASKS BEFORE
THEM -- MY NAME IS KATHY KELLY
I'M DIRECTOR OF FAMILY CAREGIVER
ALLIANCE AND ALSO THE BAY AREA
CARE GIVER -- RESOURCE CENTER
AND I'M SPEAKING.
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCE CENTERS.
ARE TO SUPPORT -- THIS REQUEST --
OF FOR UNPAID FAMILY CARE GIVERS
ADULTS WITH ALZHEIMER'S
PARKINSON'S STROKE AND OTHER
BRAIN IMPAIRMENTS. FOR A ONE
TIME BUDGET INCREASE OF TEN
MILLION PER YEAR OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS TO EXPAND.
AND RETOOL THE SYSTEM TO
RECOGNIZE THE CHANGING
DEMOGRAPHICS AND COMPLEXITY OF
CARE THAT FAMILY CARE GIVERS ARE
ALREADY PROVIDING.
FAMILY CAREGIVERS REALLY ARE THE
BACKBONE OF LONG TERM CARE
SYSTEM.
BUT WE SEE SOME SUN SETTLING
TRENDS ON BEFORE US THEY'RE
GETTING YOUNGER MORE DIVERSE I'M
MORE LIKELY TO BE EMPLOYED AND
HAVE CHILDREN IN THE HOME.
MOST OF THE FAMILIES THAT WE SEE
ARE REALLY THE ONES THAT ARE
STUCK IN THE MIDDLE THERE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR INCOME ELIGIBLE.
FOR A SERVICES FOR THE EITHER
THEMSELVES OR FOR THEIR LOVED
ONES -- BUT NOT RICH ENOUGH TO
PAY FOR THE SERVICES PRIVATELY.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
3250% OF THE FIVE FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION FAMILY CARE GIVERS
THAT ARE PROVIDING COMPLEX CARE
ESSENTIALLY PROVIDING.
SKILLED ASSISTED LIVING AND
NURSING HOME CARE IN THEIR HOMES
BUT WITHOUT THE TRAINING
GUIDANCE INSURANCE THEY THAT
THEY ARE DOING AT THE CARE TASK
CORRECTLY AND THAT WE SUPPORT
THEM EMOTIONALLY AND DOING THEM.
THIS REQUEST DOES TWO THINGS
FIRST THE DRAMATICALLY RAMPS UP
DIRECT SERVICES TO FAMILY CARE
GIVERS.
BY WORKING TOWARDS TRIPLING THE
NUMBER OF CARE GIVERS RECEIVING
CAREPLANNING AND COACHING
EDUCATION COUNSELING SKILL
TRAINING EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
INTERVENTIONS.
AND CONSUMER DIRECTED RESPITE
SERVICES AND THIS IS FOR A POINT
FROM OUR CURRENT BASELINE OF A
LITTLE BIT UNDER FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ENTIRE.
A STATE SYSTEM OF ELEVEN I CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS.
WE ARE PROPOSED DOING THIS
THROUGH A HYBRID OF PERSONAL
CONTACT IN SMART USE OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN SCALE
SERVICES ONLINE AND THREE
TELEHEALTH MEANS TO CREATE
EFFICIENCIES.
BUT ALSO MAKE ACCESSING SERVICES
EASIER FOR WORKING AN ISOLATED
CARE GIVERS.
AND MAKING IT MORE
GENERATIONALLY APPROPRIATE FOR
THOSE ARE YOUNGER CARE GIVERS
THAT WE SERVE.
THE PROPOSAL BUILDS IN THE DATA
CAPABILITIES TO TRACK CARE GIVER
AND YOUR RECEIVER NEEDS.
THROUGH UNIFORMS SAUCE WITH THE
PROVIDES DATA DATA TO TAILOR
TRAINING SUPPORT INTERVENTIONS.
AND RESULTING IN MEASURES --
THAT -- POSITIVE OUTCOMES THAT
ARE MEASURABLE.
WE HAVE THIS PROGRAM RUNNING IN
LOS ANGELES ON ALSO IN THE BAY
AREA SO IT IS ALREADY PILOT
TESTED AND IS READY FOR
REPLICATION.
THIS REQUEST IS TO BUILD REBUILD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CAPABILITIES OF THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTER SYSTEM TO
SUPPORT.
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE --
THAT HAS REALLY BEEN MISSING
SINCE -- TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
IS A KEY RECOMMENDATION -- FOR
OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA CARE GIVER
TASK FORCE REPORT AND IS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE PROPOSED
MASTER PLAN ON AGING -- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTION SIX JUST A COMMENT I
JUST WANT TO SAY I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT YOU'RE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING THERE I THINK --
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE AREAS HAS
BEEN OVERLOOKED IN ONCE AGAIN
AND ONE OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES.
OF OF THE BUDGET CUTS THAT WE
WENT THROUGH -- PROVIDING
TRAINING AND SUPPORT AND RESPITE
AND ALL THE THINGS THAT PEOPLE
NEED TO BE ABLE.
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES
TO THEIR FAMILIES -- KEEP THEM
OUT OF MORE EXPENSIVE CARE IS
THIS IS JUST THE KIND OF THING
THAT WE NEED MORE MORE OF THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S SERVICES
PROGRAM AUDIOLOGY POSITION.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT'S THE LEGACY --
CRANKS WITH SACRAMENTO ADVOCATES
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF AUDIOLOGY WHICH
REPRESENTS STATE LICENSE
AUDIOLOGIST.
CALIFORNIA AUDIOLOGIST HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN THE H. C. S. S.
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S SERVICES
OR CCS PROGRAM FOR NEARLY FIVE
DECADES DECADES PROVIDING
DIAGNOSTIC AUDIOLOGY AND HEARING
AID FITTING SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN WITH HEARING LOSS --
WHOSE PARENTS ARE UNABLE TO PAY
FOR THE SERVICES THEMSELVES.
UNFORTUNATELY A SERIES OF LONG
STANDING CONCERNS WITH C. C. AS
PROGRAMS HAS CREATED AN
ATMOSPHERE IN WHICH AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF AUDIOLOGIST
HAVE BEEN FORCED TO WITHDRAW AS
PROVIDERS FROM THE PROGRAM.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS FOR THIS
AMONG THEM FOR AN INSUFFICIENT
REIMBURSEMENT RATES DELAYS AN
AUTHORIZATION FOR CERTAIN
TREATMENTS JEOPARDIZING VITAL
EARLY INTERVENTION EFFORTS.
AND INEFFICIENCIES BETWEEN
AUDIOLOGIST AND PERSONNEL AT THE
CCS PROGRAM THE IMPACT IS VERY
REAL.
LOSING QUALIFIED CCS PROVIDERS
EXACERBATES EXISTING PROBLEMS
AROUND ACCESS. TO APPROPRIATE
CARE FOR YOUNG CHILDREN IN THE
FAMILY MANY OF THE CCS PROVIDER
OFFICE.
OFFICE IS THAT CAN PROVIDE
SERVICES DO NOT.
WE CONDUCTED A REVIEW OF THE
DATA AND CALLED ALL SEVENTY TWO
CCS LISTED OFFICES THAT HAVE
AUDIOLOGY TESTING AND HEARING
AID SERVICES FOR CHILDREN FIVE
YEARS AND OLDER.
WE LEARNED THAT OF THE SEVENTY
TWO CURRENTLY LISTED PROVIDERS
ONLY TWENTY ARE STILL
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM.
THIS UNSUSTAINABLE SHORTAGE OF
IDEOLOGICAL SERVICE PROVIDERS IN
PARTICULARLY IS TROUBLING
BECAUSE THERE ARE NEARLY SEVENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CHILDREN WHO
SUFFER FROM HEARING LOSS WITHOUT
ADEQUATE INTERVENTION HEARING
LOSS CAN NEGATIVELY IMPACT
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT.
AND ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT FOR
THESE REASONS THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF AUDIOLOGY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST BE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A POSITION WITH
ANTI.
H. C. S. TO SERVE AS A LIAISON
BETWEEN DEPARTMENT PROBE PROGRAM
OUT.
AN AUDIOLOGIST PROVIDING
SERVICES TO THE PROGRAM
BENEFICIARIES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEDI CAL.
AIR AMBULANCE RATE INCREASE
[inaudible]
YOUR TURN. TO TAKE A BREAK.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL BRYANT --
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE AIR
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE.
WHO -- PROVIDE A KEY -- ELEMENT
TO THE EMS AND DISASTER RESPONSE
SYSTEM -- OUR PROPOSAL IS TO ASK --
FOR THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN ON
GOING FUNDING FOR AIR AMBULANCE
MEDI CAL FUNDING.
THIS WILL REPLACE THE CURRENT
AMADA PROGRAM -- THAT'S EXPIRING
THIS YEAR THE AMOUNT OF PROGRAM
IF YOU RECALL PLACED A FOUR
DOLLAR PENALTY ON MOVING
VIOLATIONS -- AND THAT PROGRAM
IS -- SET TO EXPIRE AT THE END
OF THIS YEAR -- THE PROPOSAL --
RE BASES.
THE ERR AMBULANCE RATES TO BE
THE EQUIVALENT OF THE RURAL
MEDICARE RATE.
WHICH REPRESENTS ROUGHLY -- TWO
THIRDS OF THE ACTUAL ROCK ACOSTA
PROVIDING THE SERVICE.
THE REASON THIS IS SO NECESSARY
IS THAT THE UNDERLYING BASE RATE
FOR AIR AMBULANCES WAS LAST
UPDATED IN -- NINETEEN NINETY
THREE DUE TO ONE OVERSIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT -- AND THEN TO ADD
INSULT TO INJURY IT WAS FURTHER
REDUCED BY 10%.
IN THAT TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN
SO -- WITHOUT THE AMOUNT OF
PROGRAM WE REVERT BACK TO
NINETEEN NINETY THREE RATES --
FINALLY AIR CARRIERS ARE -- ERR
AMBULANCES ARE AIR CARRIERS.
AND SO WE ARE PROHIBITED FROM
DOING A QUALITY ASSURANCE FEAR
PROVIDER TAX -- AND WE ALSO ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR DISH PAYMENTS
EVEN THOUGH LIKE HOSPITALS ARE
EVEN THOUGH UP 270% OF OUR
PATIENTS -- CAN BE COVERED BY
MEDICARE.
SO WITH THAT I A WILL --
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT AND CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
COULD I HAVE NO QUESTIONS AT
THIS TIME SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
COUNTY OF RESIDENCE PROCESS.
MADAM CHAIR AND PULLING MEASURE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES WE HAVE FOUR
PROPOSALS HERE AND I WOULD LOOK
TO YOU TO ADVISE AND HOW YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROCEED WITH THEM.
WHY DON'T WE DO BRIEF
PRESENTATION ON EACH?
ONE SO THE FIRST ONE IS THE
COUNTY OF RESIDENCE -- COUNTY OF
SERVICE -- AND THIS IS A
PROPOSAL WHERE WE'RE ACTUALLY
ASKING THE COMMITTEE TO USE ITS
OVERSIGHT -- FUNCTION -- TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THIS ISSUE WHICH HAS
BEEN A DISPUTE BETWEEN -- THE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE ADD THAT
HAVE.
RESULTED IN A REDUCTION TO
ACCESS TO CARE -- AND THIS IS A
DISPUTED IS CENTERED AND
BARRIERS CREATED BY THE
REALIGNMENT ROLLS.
PROGRESS IS BEING MADE -- IN
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
HAVING -- SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS
REMAIN WHICH CREATE BARRIERS TO
CARE. FOR EXAMPLE EVEN IF A
COUNTY ESTABLISHES A CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PROVIDER
OUTSIDE THE COUNTY BORDERS.
THOSE WHO SEE CARE FOR AS YOU DE.
IN ANOTHER COUNTY STILL
CONNECTED THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
AND PRIMARY CARE OR MEDICATION
NEEDS MET IN THAT CASE IN COUNTY.
SO IN IT SO THAT WHICH MEANS
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO BE IN
TWO COUNTIES AND EVEN THOUGH A
PROVIDER MIGHT BE CLOSER.
THE ACCOUNT THE PROVIDER THIS IN
ANOTHER COUNTY THEY'D STILL HAVE
TO GO BACK TO THEIR OWN COUNTY.
WHICH AND TRAVEL FURTHER AND IN
SOME CASES TO OBTAIN THE SERVICE.
WE'RE ASKING YOU TO HELP US SO
RESOLVE THIS SO WE'VE HAD MANY
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND WITH
THE COUNTIES ABOUT THIS.
AND OUR RECOMMENDATION IS
PERHAPS A SOME SORT OF EITHER
BUDGET BILLING WHICH A TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
WITHHOLD FUNDS FROM COUNTIES.
AND CONDUCT A SETTLEMENT PROCESS
OR SETTLEMENT AT THE END OF EACH
FISCAL YEAR OR REQUIRE COUNTIES
TO RECOGNIZE AND PAY FOR OUT OF
COUNTY SERVICES SO -- THAT'S OUR
PROPOSAL.
DO WE KNOW IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- I'D LIKE TO THEM ON
THE BACK TO THE SECOND PROPOSAL.
THE TALKS SERVICE HEART RATE ON
THREE FOR MANY YEARS -- THE
STATE PAID -- FOR DETOXIFICATION
SERVICES IN BOTH US DECERTIFIED
PROGRAMS AND IN FREE STATE
STANDING PSYCHIATRIC.
HOSPITALS -- WITH THE ADVENT OF
THE DRUG MEDI CAL ORGANIZED
DELIVERY SYSTEM -- THE STATE
INDICATED THAT THEY WERE ONLY
GOING TO PAY -- FOR
DETOXIFICATION SERVICES IN --
STATE CERTIFIED HOSPITALS -- AND
THAT THE COUNTY SHOULD PAY FOR
THE PSYCHIATRIC FREESTANDING
SAID FOR THE D. TAX IN THIS THE
VIETNAM FREESTANDING PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALS -- AND THE COUNTY SAID
IT WAS A PART OF THEIR DRUG MEDI
CAL ODS -- ALLOCATION --
THEREFORE THEY REFUSE TO PAY FOR
IT -- SO -- THE REQUESTED
FUNDING IS -- BASED ON A
CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATE THAT THERE
ARE FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS ABUSING
OPIATES ALONE. 1% REQUIRES THAT
A SAM THREE POINT SEVEN LEVEL
HOSPITAL DETOXIFICATION WHICH
CAN BE PROVIDED IN -- ALL ALL
THESE SO -- HOSPITAL SITUATIONS
THAT I'VE BEEN MENTIONING.
THESE ARE LARGELY INDIVIDUALS A
WHOLE -- WITH SIRIUS CO
OCCURRING DISORDERS AND OR
MEDICALLY COMPROMISED AND THEY
TEND TO BE THE HIGHEST UTILIZES
EMERGENCY ROOM CARE AND A HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF OVERDOSE CASES.
IF ALCOHOL IS INCLUDED THE
NUMBER WOULD -- DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE.
AT AN AVERAGE LENGTH OF STAY OF
FIVE DAYS IN AN AVERAGE RATE PER
DAY OF SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS -- PER DAY THE FUNDING
REQUEST IS FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS -- THE ONE OPTION IN
MANAGING THESE FUNDS WOULD BE TO
ALLOCATED RETAIN THE FUNDS AT
THE STATE LEVEL BY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND COUNTIES COULD
DRIVE DOWN ON A REIMBURSEMENT
BASIS.
BASED ON THE THIS DRIVE DOWN
COULD BE FURTHER COULD EITHER BE
COUNTY BY COUNTY BASED OR
PROVIDER CLAIM OR DH YES COULD
PAY.
CLAIMS DIRECTLY -- TO PROVIDERS.
THE OTHER OPTION IS TO ALLOCATE --
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND IN TURN HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT -- ALLOCATE THE FUNDS
DIRECTLY TO COUNTIES FOR THEM TO
MANAGE -- IN ANY EVENT THE
DEMAND IS BELOW THE FUNDING IF
THE IF THE DEMAND IS BELOW THE
FUNDING LEVEL REQUESTED THE
BALLOTS COULD BRAWL FORWARD.
AND BE REASSESSED BASED ON
INCREASING AND OR DECREASING THE
SO THAT IS OUR OUR REQUEST --
FOR I HAVE TO SAY THAT THERE ARE --
BECAUSE OF THIS REALLY BLOCKAGE
TO ACCESS TO CARE.
A SOME OF OUR PROVIDERS HAVE HAD
PEOPLE DIED WAITING -- FOR IT A
BIT TO GET INTO DETOXIFICATION.
SO -- VERY CRITICAL AND IT'S A
IT'S CRITICAL IN TERMS OF THE
FIRST STEP IN ACCESSING
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT AND
HAVING PEOPLE GET OUT TO THE
ROAD TO RECOVERY SO THAT
CONCLUDES THAT.
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
ARE THERE PROPOSAL AGAIN IS A A
PROPOSAL -- MORE OF ASKING THE
COMMITTEE -- TO ADVOCATE FOR
BRIDGE HOUSING -- THAT IS NOT
INCLUDED IN OUR DRUG MEDI CAL
ODS -- SERVICES -- AND WE ARE
LOOKING FOR A RECOVERING HOUSING
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO MEET THE
DEFINITION OF HOMELESS.
THESE -- THIS INCLUDES
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED SUPPORT OF
HOUSING AS A TUITION TRANSITION
FROM PRISON RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES AND THOSE
WHO ARE PRESENT IN THE COMMUNITY.
WE AND WE WOULD REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE I SURE THAT THE BRIDGE
HOUSING FUNDING AS YOU.
GO THROUGH AND DO THE ALLOCATION
OF THE HOMELESS FINDING THAT
BRIDGE HOUSING IS INCLUDED IN
THAT HOUSING AND SOMETIMES IT
GETS FORGOTTEN SO THAT THEIR
SECOND PROPOSAL AND THERE HAS
BEEN.
PARDON THERE HAS BEEN MUCH
DISCUSSION.
OF ABOUT BRIDGE YOU HOUSING.
IN.
IN MANY SITUATIONS AND I THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS UP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THEN OUR
FOURTH PROPOSAL IS -- WORK FOR
AS EXPANSION.
AND IT'S A LITTLE MORE EXPANDED
THEN THE PROPOSAL'S YOU HAD
pEARLIER UNDER THE I SHOULD
PROPOSAL -- OUR WORK FIRST
PROPOSAL IS FOR A THIRTEEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
AS YOU'VE HEARD -- EARLIER AND
AS HAS BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED ANOTHER
COMMITTEE HEARINGS THAT.
THE SUBSTANCE USE WORKFORCE IS --
A TOTALLY -- AND IN NEED OF BOTH --
A RECRUITMENT AS WELL AS
TRAINING AND IMPROVING AND
STRENGTHENING THE WORK FOR
SYSTEM.
WE WOULD -- FUNDING SHOULD BE --
YOUR MARKED UP FOR TUITION
SUPPORT TO INCREASE WORKFORCE
FOR CERTIFIED COUNSELORS AND
EXPAND.
A TRAINING FOR CURRENT WORK FOR
START UP FUNDS TO CREATE
ADDITIONAL ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE.
AS YOU DECALS ARE EDUCATION
TOWARD CERTIFICATION -- THERE
ARE -- ONLY THREE ARE CERTIFIED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
COUNSELOR CERTIFICATION RIGHT
NOW.
AND WE WOULD -- PARTLY ASK FOR
AN ASSESSMENT OF THE FEASIBILITY
OF BRINGING DOES CERTIFICATION
PROCESS BACK IN UNDER THE
AUTHORITY OF THE STATE RATHER
THAN DELEGATING IT -- TO OUTSIDE
NON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS --
SHOWS THE DISTRIBUTION OF THE
THIRTEEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
WOULD BE FIVE MILLION FOR
TUITION SUPPORT.
OF FIVE MILLION FOR CURRENT
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
NEEDS.
A THREE MILLION UP POSSIBLY
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE BID
PROCESS TO PROVIDE START UP
RESOURCES FOR ADDITIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS. TO ENTER AND MEET
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES REQUIREMENTS. TO BECOME
APPROVED COUNSELOR EDUCATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS AS NON
GOVERNMENTAL -- CERTIFICATION
UNTIL SUCH TIME THAT WE COULD
GET THE MAKE AN ASSESSMENT IS TO
BRING THAT CERTIFICATION PROCESS
BACK INTO THE AUTHORITY OF THE
STATE -- THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND TO EVALUATE HOW -- TO
REDUCE THE DUPLICATIVE
UNCOORDINATED.
AND OFTEN UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS AND
BURDENS PLACED I'M PROVIDERS --
WE OFTEN HAVE DUBBED DUPLICATE
WORK TO DO DOUBLE DUPLICATE
ENTRY -- BY -- COUNSELORS -- DO
WOULD HAVE TO MAKE A DUPLICATE
ENTRIES AND OF VARIOUS FORMS --
TO MEET FEDERAL STATE AND COUNTY
REQUIREMENTS SO -- SOMEHOW OR
OTHER TO DO AN ASSESSMENT OF
THAT WOULD BE GREAT AND THEN
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND TO
ASSESS AND EVALUATE A SINGLE
STATE AGENCY TAKING OVER THE
CERTIFICATION AND DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS OF AS YOU G. COUNCIL
CERTIFICATION.
WITH A REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
I THANK THANK YOU.
FROM THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
ASSOCIATION HIGH COST DRUGS D.
R. G. CARVE OUT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MAYOR
MARTIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS ASSOCIATION
I HERE WITH KIND OF A NEW ONCE
ISSUE RELATED TO HOSPITAL
REIMBURSEMENT -- WHEN YOU HAVE A
FEE FOR SERVICE MEDICAL PATIENT
WITH THE HIGH COST DRUG?
SO CURRENTLY WHEN A FEE FOR
SERVICE MEDICAL PATIENT IS
ADMINISTERED A PRESCRIPTION DRUG
ON AN INPATIENT BASIS THE
HOSPITAL IS REIMBURSED WITH A
BUNDLE PAYMENT CALL THE DRG.
WHICH IS MEANT TO COVERAGE THE
AVERAGE COST ASSOCIATED WITH
TREATING SOMEONE WITH THAT
CONDITION INCLUDING THE COST OF
ANY MEDICATIONS.
HOWEVER WHEN A VERY NEW HIGH
COST PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
ADMINISTERED TO A PATIENT ON AN
INPATIENT BASIS THAT THE R. G.
DOES NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
COST OF THE DRUG BECAUSE IT'S
LOOKING AT THE AVERAGE COST.
OF THE PREVIOUS STANDARD OF CARE.
IN ADDITION SOMETIMES YOU HAVE
HIGH COST PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
THAT ARE GENERALLY ADMINISTERED
ON AN OUTPATIENT BASIS BUT
OCCASIONALLY A CHILD WILL HAVE
TO BE HOSPITALIZED.
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS THE
REIMBURSEMENT DOESN'T TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT -- THE COST OF THE DRUG
AS PART OF THE DEAR G. PAYMENT
IN BOTH CASES A HOSPITAL WILL
LOSE SIGNIFICANT -- FINANCIAL.
EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
LOSSES. TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
CURRENTLY YOU CAN GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND SEE CO -- ONE OFF
CARVE OUT OF THE DRUG PAYMENT
AND WE ACTUALLY DID THIS LAST
YEAR FOR A DRUG CALLED HIM RIGHT
TO TREAT A RARE TYPE OF LEUKEMIA --
ONLY ABOUT TWENTY KIDS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RECEIVED IT
I THINK ABOUT TEN OF THEM WERE
IN MEDI CAL -- BUT ANY TIME
HOSPITAL HAD ONE OF THOSE KIDS
GET ADMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL WAS
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
LOSS TO THE HOSPITAL THE
DEPARTMENT AGREED THAT THAT WAS
UNACCEPTABLE THE AGREE TO CARVE
THE DRUG OUT OF THE DRG PAYMENTS.
ABOUT THAT PROCESS TOOK FIFTEEN
MONTHS FROM THE MOMENT WE FIRST
MENTIONED IT TO THE DEPARTMENT
SO WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING.
IS TO CREATE A DEFINITION OF A
VERY HIGH COST DRUGS AND TO ASK
THE DEPARTMENT JUST CREATE A
PROCESS.
TO GO AHEAD AND PROVIDE THESE
CARVE OUTS IN THE FUTURE RATHER
THAN WAITING FOR A STAKEHOLDER
TO COMMON RAISE THE ISSUE -- SO
THAT THAT HAPPENS FASTER AND YOU
DON'T HAVE HOSPITAL'S
EXPERIENCING THE LOSS IN THE
MEANTIME.
THANK YOU AND BUT NO DON'T GO
AWAY.
BECAUSE I DID -- TO MISTER
PATTERSON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON DID HAVE.
SOME COMMENTS THAT HE WANTED TO
SHARE -- HE DID HAVE TO LEAVE.
AND SO ON HIS BEHALF THESE ARE
HIS WORDS OKAY.
THEY'RE ALL GOOD WORDS BUT THESE
ARE HIS WORDS -- MOST PATTERSON
SAYS IT FROM HIS UNDERSTANDING
WE'RE EXPOSING HOSPITALS TO ALL
KINDS OF UNANTICIPATED FINANCIAL
LOSSES IF WE DON'T CARVE OUT
THESE DRUGS.
HE GOES ON TO SAY THAT THE LAST
THING WE SHOULD.
BE DOING IS TO PUT HOSPITALS IN
A POSITION WHERE THEY'RE
FACTORING THE HIGH COST OF THESE
DRUGS.
WHEN DETERMINING IF THEY SHOULD
ADMINISTER SOMETHING THAT IS
POTENTIALLY LIFE SAVING TO A
PATIENT?
MR PATERSON CONCLUDES BY SAYING
THIS CAR ABOUT PROCESS IS
ALREADY BEING DONE AND THE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO BE PROACTIVE
ABOUT IDENTIFYING.
THESE DRUGS SO THAT HOSPITALS
AREN'T LEFT FOOTING THE BILL.
SOMETIMES FOR LONGER THAN A YEAR
ON SOMETHING THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN RESOLVED QUICKLY.
THOSE ARE MISTER PATTERSON'S
COMMENTS THAT HE WANTED TO SHARE.
ON THIS ITEM BUT HAD TO LEAVE.
THANK YOU SO THANK YOU FOR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU.
MEDICAL COVERAGE OF SILVER DYE
MINE FLUORIDE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON BRANDED HIM IN
SPENCER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION -- CD IS
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING BUDGET --
BUDGET FUNDING TO MAKE SILVER
DINING FLUORIDE EIGHT MEDI CAL --
COVERED BENEFIT STF IS A TOPICAL
LIQUID AND THAT IS ESSENTIALLY
PAINTED ON TEETH AND IT'S USED
TO SLOW DOWN OR STOP.
DECAY IN BOTH BABY AND PERMANENT
TEETH.
IT'S A NON INVASIVE NON INVASIVE
WAY TO TREAT DENTAL CARIES KNOWN
AS CAVITIES AND IT CAN REDUCE
THE NEED FOR FURTHER FILLINGS OR
THE USE OF GENERAL ANESTHESIA.
AND IT'S PARTICULARLY BENEFICIAL
IN THE CARE OF PEOPLE
DISABILITIES FRAIL ELDERLY
PATIENTS YOUNG CHILDREN AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS --
IN ORDER TO REALLY FOCUS ON THE
POPULATIONS THAT WOULD MOST
BENEFIT FROM STF WE REALLY DID
FOCUS ON THOSE POPULATIONS THAT
I JUST LISTED.
IT DOES LEAVE A DARK STAIN ON
THE CAVITY -- AND THE I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW AND I
CAN STAY IN THE STOP SOFT TISSUE
LIKE THE GUMS TEMPORARILY WHICH
IS WHY ALL OF OUR DENTIST USE
I'M STRONG INFORMED CONSENT AND
REALLY TALK THROUGH.
SOME OF THE OPTIONS IT REALLY IS
AN ALTERNATIVE TREATMENT THEY
TALK TO THE OPTIONS WITH THEIR
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
MAKE SURE THEY UNDERSTAND.
SORT OF WHT THEY'RE CHOOSING
I'M IN DESPITE THE AESTHETIC
CONCERNS IT'S REALLY BECOMING
VERY WIDELY USED IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE AND COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE IS PAYING FOR IT.
AND WHEN IT'S NOT COVERED
FAMILIES ARE P. CHOOSING TO PAY
OUT OF POCKET -- BECAUSE IT'S
NOT COVERED BY MEDICARE ALL --
IT MAYBE FINANCIALLY OUT OF
REACH -- FOR FOR THOSE
BENEFICIARIES.
AND WE'RE REALLY HEARING FROM
OUR MEMBER DENNIS THAT THEY'RE
USING IT ON A WIDE RANGE OF
PATIENTS AND IN A WIDE RANGE OF
SETTINGS. ONE OF OUR DENTIST
SAID RECENTLY THAT SHE USED IT
I'M IN THE SAME DAY ON A TWO
YEAR OLD AND A NINETY TWO YEAR
OLD.
THE TWO YEAR OLD HAD A BABY
BOTTLE TO K. BETWEEN THIS TO
UPPER FRONT TEETH.
AND WHILE HIS PARENTS WERE
INITIALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
BLACK SIDE EFFECTS WHEN THEY
REALLY CONSIDERED BOTH THE COST
DIFFERENCE AS WELL AS AND
ALTERNATIVE TREATMENT THE SORT
OF TRADITIONAL TREATMENT.
THAT WOULD HAVE INCLUDED IT
NITROUS OXIDE GAS INJECTABLE
ANESTHETICS AND POSSIBLY SERVE A
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE -- THE
PARENTS DECIDED THAT I STAFF WAS
REALLY THE THE WAY TO GO AND THE
DENNIS IS GOING TO BE WORKING ON
SORT OF AESTHETIC COVER UP SAYS
AS HE HAS THE CHILD GETS OLDER.
THE NINETY TWO YEAR OLD HAD
DEMENTIA AND AND HAD DIFFICULTY
KEEPING HIS TEETH CLEAN AGAIN
SIMILAR DECISIONS WERE MADE TO
SORT OF AVOID THAT THE
DIFFICULTY OF COMPREHENSIVE
TREATMENT -- AND SO.
ESSENTIALLY THIS BUDGET ASK
WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW THIS --
ALTERNATIVE TREATMENT TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR PATIENTS AND DONE
A CAL AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE FINAL BUDGET.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PROPOSAL.
PACE MODERNIZATION ACT TRAILER
BILL.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR OF THE
COUNCIL WITH CAL PACE WE
REPRESENT THE PROGRAMS OF ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY --
THIS PRO PROPOSAL WOULD MAKE
CHANGES TO THE PAYMENT
METHODOLOGY FOR PACE PROGRAMS --
AS YOU KNOW PACES A
COMPREHENSIVE CARE MODEL SERVING
FOR ALL SENIORS AND OLDER ADULTS.
IT ASSUMES -- THE ENTIRE RISK OF
PROVIDING THE ALL THE SERVICES
THAT THE SENIORS NEED TO STAY
SAFE WHEN THE COMMUNITY SO THAT
INCLUDES ACUTE CARE SERVICES AS
WELL AS LONG TERM CARE SERVICES
AND HOME CARE AND SO FORTH --
THE PROPOSAL WOULD BETTER ALIGN
THE METHODOLOGY WITH -- SOME OF
THE UNIQUE ASPECTS OF PACE ONE
IS THAT IT'S A VERY CAPITAL
INTENSIVE PROGRAM THAT REQUIRES
A LOT OF INVESTMENT ON THE FRONT
END I PAY CENTER GENERALLY COST
TEN MILLION DOLLARS OR MORE --
TO START UP IN A COMMUNITY.
AND THE CURRENT METHODOLOGY
UNFORTUNATELY DOESN'T REALLY
PROVIDE A MECHANISM TO RECOGNIZE
THOSE COSTS AND ALLOW THEM TO BE
RECOUPED IN A REASONABLE PERIOD
OF TIME.
THIS IS ALSO A VERY BALL LITTLE
PROGRAM -- SERVING A FAIRLY
SMALL NUMBER OF REALLY HIGH NEED --
BENEFICIARIES SO -- THE PROGRAMS
NEED A LITTLE BIT HIGHER MARGIN
TO HANDLE THE SITUATION THAT
ARISES WHEN.
THEY HAVE A HIGHER THAN EXPECTED
NUMBER OF CASES THAT ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE SUCH AS HEPATITIS C.
OR OR ORGAN TRANSPLANTS AND SO
THE METHODOLOGY CHANGES WOULD
ADDRESS THAT AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE.
SOME PROBLEMS WITH THE
METHODOLOGY RECOGNIZING THE
ACTUAL COSTS OF STARTUP PROGRAMS --
AND UNFORTUNATELY METHODOLOGY
TENDS TO USE COST EXPERIENCE OF
ESTABLISHED PROGRAMS -- FOR NEW
PROGRAMS BUT THEY THEY JUST HAVE
HIGHER OVERHEAD COSTS -- WHEN
THEY STERN SO THAT THERE ARE
SOME PROBLEMS THERE ARE SO?
THE METHODOLOGY -- CHANGES WOULD
MAKE A SEVERAL CHANGES THESE
WOULD HELP ENSURE SUSTAINABILITY
OF PACE THIS IS A VERY PROMISING
MODEL I KNOW YOU'RE AWARE OF IT
IN YOUR AREA -- IT WILL ENSURE
THAT THE MODEL CAN BE CARRIED ON
INTO INTO THE FUTURE.
AND I GUESS I WOULD SAY EVEN
WITH THESE CHANGES -- INCLUDING
A MINIMUM PAYMENT STANDARD --
BECAUSE THE PAYMENTS HAVE TO BE
SET BELOW THE AMOUNT THE STATE
WOULD OTHERWISE PAY -- PACE WILL
REMAIN WOULD REMAIN ACOSTA
DOCTOR PROGRAM FOR THE STATE --
WE ARE ENGAGED AND FAIRLY
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT -- WE'RE WE
DEFINITELY ARE LOOKING AT
REFINING THE PROPOSAL -- WE'VE
HAD SOME PROGRESS AND I THINK
THE DEPARTMENT DOES AGREE WITH
US AND CONCEPT ON A FEW THE FEW
THE CONCEPTS ANYWAY.
SO WE ARE HOPEFUL AT SOME POINT
WILL HAVE -- A MORE REFINED
PROPOSAL AND HOPE YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT IT AT THAT TIME.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PRESENTING.
HOUSE MY PREVENTION AND MEDI CAL.
I DO WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PRESENTERS -- FOR KEEPING UP TO
TWO MINUTES. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE TO BEING REMINDED.
YOU BROKE IT.
CAN YOU HEAR ME THAT'S COMING
OFF THE YOUR REQUEST RIGHT THERE.
HELLO MY NAME IS EMILY LOPEZ AND
I'M A COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
PROVIDING US MY HOME VISITS FOR
DAY CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ASK MY
COLLABORATIVE.
THIS IS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
PROVIDES AND MY MANAGEMENT
SERVICES IN A NUMBER OF
COMPANIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK THAT YOU
INCLUDE AS MY PREVENT ANY
SERVICES MEANING ASK MEDICATION
A HOME ENVIRONMENTAL. THREE
ASSESSMENT AS A COVER BENEFIT
FOR THE MEDI CAL.
BENEFICIARIES WITH POORLY
CONTROL ASTHMA.
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE ASKING FOR
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT MINOR TO
MODERATE REMEDIATION UP
ENVIRONMENTAL TRIGGERS SUCH AS
PROVIDING MATTRESS AND PILLOW
CASE COVERS.
IN USING.
TRIGGER **** DREAM VACUUMS ALL
OF THESE SERVICES MAY BE
PROVIDED BY QUALIFY NOT LICENSE
PROFESSIONALS UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF LIFE AND
PROVIDERS.
I HAVE THE HONOR TO REGULARLY
VISIT FAMILIES IN THEIR HOMES
WHERE SOMEONE IS THE STRUGGLING
WITH FORTY CONTROL US MY MANY
MANY CASES THERE.
HAVE FRIGHTENING VISITS TO THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT OR BEEN
HOSPITALIZED. FOR US MY HEART
OUT OF MY HOUSE BECAUSE IN TO ME
SCHOOL WORK I ALSO PROVIDE AN
IMPORTANT LINK TO PATIENTS
DOCTORS.
ARE FOR EXAMPLE OF A PATIENT
FILLS HER ASTHMA IS GETTING
WORSE I'LL HELP HER CONNECT
RECONNECT WITH HER DOCTOR FOR
ADDITIONAL HELP.
I RECENTLY I RECENTLY HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WAR WITH --
FAMILY MERCED THE FATHER AND HIS
THREE CHILDREN HAVE ASTHMA
THAT'S AS MY WASN'T CONTROL HAD
NO MEDICATIONS FOR HIMSELF.
ADDITIONALLY HE HAD MISSED THREE
WEEKS OF WORK TO DO HE'S DUE TO
HIS EYES MINE EVEN THOUGH HE
VISITED THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
IN ORIGIN KERR -- HE WAS UNABLE
TO EXPRESS HIS CONCERN AND
SYMPTOMS TO TO LANGUAGE BARRIERS --
SO HE WAS TREATED BY MEDICATION
FOR ASTHMA WAS NOT PRESCRIBED
AFTER ENROLLING IN OUR PROGRAM.
I WAS ABLE TO PROVIDE THE FAMILY
WITH US MEDICATION.
AND HELP THEM OVERCOME LANGUAGE
BERRIER BY ACCOMPANY HIM TO THE
DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENT THE
FOLLOWING DAY AND INTERPRETING
DURING THE VISITS.
THE DOCTOR UNDERSTOOD HIS
CONDITION AS PRESCRIBED THE
NECESSARY MEDICATIONS I WAS ABLE
TO SHOW HIM HOW TO PROPERLY TAKE
HIS MEDICATION FOLLOWING THE
DOCTOR'S ORDER.
AS A RESTORED THE FAMILY AND
PATIENT HAVE NOTICED IMPROVEMENT
IN THEIR HEALTH CONDITION HOME
ENVIRONMENT IN COMMUNICATION
WITH HIS POSITION THE PATIENT
HAS RETURNED TO WORK.
HE SAYS MY IS FULLY CONTROL.
I'M PROUD OF MY WORK TO HELP HIS
FATHER HIS FAMILY GET BETTER I
THINK EVERYBODY EVERY PERSONALLY
POORLY CONTROL US MY THE SURF TO
GET THE HELP THEY NEED TO LIVE A
HEALTHY LIFE.
YOUR SUPPORT -- FOR AS MY
PREVENT THAT THE SERVICES WILL
HELP TREMENDOUSLY THAT'S WHY I'M
HERE PRESENTING -- THIS INTO
CALIFORNIA AS MICHAEL NUMBER TO
SUPPORT FOR SB TWO OH SEVEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU I WILL ELL YOU THAT
IN MY COMMUNITY.
THE INCIDENCE OF ASTHMA HAS
INCREASED TREMENDOUSLY.
A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
DIESEL PARTICULATE -- IN IN OUR
AREA WE'VE SEVEN OUT OF TEN
CHILDREN WITH ASTHMA.
SO THANK YOU FOR GIVING THIS
PRESENTATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LOAD FACTOR REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGY
.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DOCTOR IN HEALERS -- OF
PHARMACISTS AND THE DIRECTOR OF
PHARMACY TO SPECIALTY PHARMACY
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT CARE FOR PATIENTS SO IF WE
MISS ORDERS FOR THE PAST TWELVE
YEARS.
AS OPPOSED TO ALL THE OTHER
PROPOSALS TODAY WE'RE NOT HERE
TO ASK FOR INCREASE THE MEDIC
HOW PROVIDER REIMBURSEMENT.
AND SAID WE ARE HERE TO ASK FOR
YOUR HELP IN PREVENTING DH CS
REIMPOSING AN APPROXIMATE 75%
CUT. TO MEDI CAL ESPECIALLY
PHARMACY REIMBURSEMENT FOR BLOOD
FACTORS.
THESE SIGNIFICANT CUTS WOULD NOT
ALLOW SPECIALTY PHARMACIES TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE MEDI CAL
PATIENTS WITH THE OUT REACH.
EDUCATION AND PATIENT CARE
SERVICES THAT WE CURRENTLY DO.
PATIENTS WOULD BE FORCED TO DEAL
UTILIZED EMERGENCY ROOMS WHICH
ARE NOT EQUIPPED WITH A VARIETY
OF BLOOD CLOTTING FACTORS IN
THEIR INVENTORY.
NECESSARY TO TREAT THESE
PATIENTS.
AS A PHARMACIST I'M AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE BLEEDING DISORDER
PATIENT CARE TEAM AND ROUTE I'M
RESPONSIBLE FOR INSURING
PATIENTS ARE FOLLOWING THEIR
TREATMENT PLANS.
WITHOUT ANY ISSUES AND HAVE AN
ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF BLOOD FACTOR
ON HAND AT ALL TIMES.
BY WORKING TO MINIMIZE THE
BLEEDING RELATED COMPLICATIONS --
PLANTAE OUR VISITS AND HOSPITAL
ADMISSIONS PATIENTS HAVE A
HIGHER QUALITY OF LIFE AND THE
STATE SAVE HEALTHCARE DOLLARS.
ESPECIALLY THE PHARMACIST
TRAINING BILLION DISORDERS
TAYLOR CARETO EACH PATIENT
BASED ON INDIVIDUAL NEEDS GOALS
AND CHALLENGES.
PATIENTS NEED TO BE 1100%
CONFIDENT THAT EYES ARE
PHARMACISTS UNDERSTAND THEIR
EXACT NEEDS AND KNOW THAT IT
ACTED WE'D REQUIRE SWIFT ACTION
WITH NO ROOM FOR ERROR.
THEIR LIFE TRULY DEPENDS ON IT.
THE DAMAGING EFFECTS ARE REAL
WHEN PATIENTS DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO AN EXPERT PHARMACY CARE TEAM
MY PATIENT IN HIS EARLY FORTIES
UNDERWENT THREE TOTAL HIP
REPLACEMENT SURGERIES DUE TO
REPEATED MISMANAGED BLEEDS IN
HIS TEENS AND TWENTIES.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
ASSISTANCE IN URGING DH CS TO
CREATE A NEW PROPOSAL FOR
REIMBURSEMENT TO MEDI CAL
SPECIALTY PHARMACY PROVIDERS OF
BLOOD FACTORS. TO RENT THEM FROM
IMPOSING THE 75% CUT
REIMBURSEMENT WHICH WOULD LIKELY
RESULT IN BLEEDING DISORDER
PATIENTS LOSING ACCESS TO THEIR
CURRENT MEDI CAL PROVIDER.
THANK YOU SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PRESENTING THAT THANK YOU.
RATE INCREASE FOR PSYCHOLOGISTS
IN NURSING HOMES
.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
ASSEMBLY -- MY NAME'S MICHAEL
LAWLER AND I REPRESENT -- C. H.
E. B. EVER HEALTH AND WERE
ASKING FOR SIX MILLION DOLLARS
AND RATE ADJUSTMENT TO PROVIDE --
RATE STRUCTURES TO ACCOMMODATE
PSYCHOLOGY AND LOS LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS IN
SPECIFICALLY FOR NURSING HOMES.
WHAT WE FOUND -- ACCORDING TO
CALF OVER THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
UNIQUE PATIENTS HAVE -- MADE
THIS VISIT IN A SNIFF HERE IN
STATE CALIFORNIA --
APPROXIMATELY 60% OF THOSE RELY
ON MEDI CAL SOLELY FOR THEIR
COVERAGE -- THAT INCLUDES DUAL
ELIGIBLES MEDICARE PATIENTS THAT
AFTER HUNDRED DAYS -- BECOME MY
1100% MEDI CAL RECIPIENTS --
TODAY. ONE IN TWENTY FOUR IN
CALIFORNIA ARE CONSIDERED
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL AND
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS RESIDE IN
SMITH'S ON A ANNUAL CALENDAR
BASIS.
OF THOSE ONE IN SIX EXPERIENCED
TRAUMA CHILDHOOD ABUSE NEGLECT
OR DEMENTIA RESULTING IN ANXIETY
DEPRESSION PS TV.
AND SOMETIMES SUICIDAL THOUGHTS.
TODAY IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
45% OF THE POPULATION GO
UNTREATED THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER WHEN WE LOOK AT THOSE WHO
ARE ELDERS WHO HAVE BEEN SERVING
OUR COMMUNITY.
AND END UP IN AND LONG TERM CARE
FACILITY SETTING.
THAT 45% POPULATION OFTEN
RESULTS IN -- A SIZEABLE
POPULATION OF HOMELESSNESS
APPROXIMATELY 66% OF THE
MEDICARE RECIPIENTS IN NURSING
HOMES ARE ON THE LOG FOR
HOMELESS AND ARE MOVING IN AND
OUT BETWEEN.
THE ACUTE SETTING -- UNDER THE
NEW LAW THAT CAN THE PLACE FOR
THE NURSING ARTS COMMITTEE
EMERGENCY ROOM MUST REQUIRE AND
PROVIDE CHAIR FOOD WATER AND
CLOTHING.
THEN THE DISCHARGED IN THE
NURSING HOME THE NURSING HOME
THEN BECOMES A TEMPORARY HOUSING
ARRANGEMENT FOR THOSE PATIENTS
AS OPPOSED TO GOING BACK TO THE
STREET -- ANOTHER ALTERNATIVE
THAT -- RESULT IS INCARCERATION
WE SEE SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
ALMOST PATIENTS WHO ARE IN THE
NURSING HOME LINING UP
INCARCERATIONS.
EPISODES OF VIOLENCE UP TO
SUICIDE AS WE MENTIONED EARLIER
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE DAY
SUICIDE RATES ARE CLIMBING IN
ABOUT TWO POINT 2% OF THE
NURSING HOME POPULATIONS.
ARE NOW SEEING A INCREASE AND
THERE SIR -- SUICIDE ARRAY.
THIS ALSO RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT
COSTS AS A MENTION EMERGENCY
ROOM RATES ARE INCREASING
BECAUSE THE PATIENTS ARE GOING
TO THE NURSING HOME WITH NO
ALTERNATIVE -- EMT AN AMBULANCE
RATES ARE BEING INCURRED --
POLICE EXPENSES CORE CLASSES AND
SOCIAL SERVICES.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS KAISER
JUST COMPLETED A SIX MONTH STUDY --
THAT SIX MONTH STUDY SO THAT
OLDER AMERICANS ARE QUIETLY
KILLING THEMSELVES.
A SUICIDE RATES AS I MENTIONED
HAVE INCREASED OVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS FROM -- TWENTY PER
FIFTY FIVE PER HUNDRED THOUSAND
PATIENTS IN THAT CONTINUES TO
INCREASE -- LASTLY THE
CHALLENGES AND SNIFFS ARE
SIGNIFICANT FACED WITH BEHAVIOR
HEALTH ISSUES THE STAFF ARE NOT
ADEQUATELY TRAINED TO HANDLE
PSYCHIATRIC ILLNESSES -- AND
REQUIRE OUTSIDE SERVICES
PRESSURE TO REDUCE DOSAGES AND
PSYCHIATRIC MEDICATIONS ARE HIGH
AND FACILITIES ARE FORCED
OPERATE OUTSIDE THEIR EXPERTISE
IN THE SCOPE OF PSYCHIATRY OR
PSYCHOLOGY -- ARE ASKED WE
BELIEVE WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
SUPPORT THE PSYCHOLOGIST TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT AND PROVIDE THAT
CARE IN THE NURSING HOMES WHICH
IS GREATLY NEEDED THIS TIME.
I LOOK FOR TO YOU SUPPORTING OUR
REQUEST AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
SCREENING BRIEF INTERVENTION AND
REFERRAL TO TREATMENT
[inaudible]
EXPANSION.
YES BERT.
OR SOME BIRDS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE COUNTY BE
ABLE HELP DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
ARE WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE NEXT TO
PROPOSALS I'M GOING -- TO
PRESENT ON THE FIRST ONE AND
THEN MY COLLEAGUE ROBERT LET ROB
LANE IS GOING TO OUR PRESENT ON
THE ON THE FOLLOWING.
ONE SO THIS IS ON THE THE
EXPANSION OF SCREENING BRIEF
INTERVENTION I'M REFERRAL TO
TREATMENT WE ARE REQUESTING.
OF TWO POINT FIVE EIGHT MILLION
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO EXPAND THE MEDI CAL
BENEFIT FOR ON FOR ALCOHOL
MISUSE SCREENING AND COUNSELING.
TO INCLUDE SCREENING FOR MIS USE
OF OPIOIDS AND OTHER ILLICIT
DRUGS ARE RIGHT NOW IT'S ONLY
COVERS ALCOHOL AND WE WANT THIS
TO COVERED TO BE EXPANDED TO
COVER -- OF DRUGS AS WELL.
THE IN THE INTENT OF THE
PROPOSAL IS TO STRENGTHEN
LINKAGES AND REFERRAL PATHWAYS
BETWEEN PRIMARY CARE AND
SPECIALTY SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT. TO CONFRONT THE
OPIOID CRISIS THAT CLAIMED THE
LIVES OF MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ANNUALLY.
ARE STATES PUBLICLY FUNDED
HEALTH SYSTEMS MUST IDENTIFY
MORE PEOPLE WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS AND CONNECT THEM TO
CARE.
EXPANDING ADULTS SCREENING TO
DETECT MISUSE OF OPIOIDS AND
OTHER DRUGS IS ONE COST
EFFECTIVE STRATEGY TO ACHIEVE
THESE GOALS AND WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
PROPOSAL NOW.
TURN IT OVER TO ROB.
THANK YOU.
NO I DON'T OKAY [inaudible]
PROBABLY WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION CVH DAY IS
REQUESTING THAT THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE A GRANITE TECHNICAL
CHANGE TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FOR THE FINANCING
OF INNOVATION PROJECTS.
UNDER OR THE CURRENT LAW
COUNTIES HAVE LIMITED TIME TO
FULLY SPEND APPROVED DOLLARS FOR
AND THEY JUST SAY INNOVATION
PROJECTS OFTEN TIMES SIMPLE
THINGS LIKE CONTRACTING.
NAME ME AS I'M LOCAL POLITICS OR
ROBUST COMMUNITY PLANNING
PROCESS WILL CREATE UNAVOIDABLE
DELAYS TO THESE PROJECTS THAT
COUNTIES ACTUALLY SIMPLY CANNOT
CONTROL.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS WERE ASKING
THAT THIS CURRENT PROVISION BE
REMOVED AND THAT EACH TOP
PROJECT TIMELINE BE LINKED TO
THE APPROVAL PROCESS WHEN IT'S
HEARD AT THE COMMISSION.
WITH THIS CHANGE COUNTIES WILL
BE ABLE TO CREATE COST COUNTY
COLLABORATIONS AND HELP FURTHER
THE INTENT OF THE ACT LIKE I
SAID BEFORE THIS WILL BE DONE
DURING EXISTING COMMISSION PROP --
THAT DURING THE EXISTING
COMMISSION PROCESS IN PUBLIC
MEETINGS WITH INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND COMMISSION
STAFF.
AT A FEW EXPENSIVE EXAMPLES OF
THE PROJECT BUT IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS DOCTOR WOULD.
ALL RIGHT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION [inaudible]
MAD MAX.
MR WHICH WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SCOTT
WHICH ON BEHALF OF LEAD NECKS.
MINIX IS ONE OF THE STATE'S
LARGEST IF NOT LARGEST GROUP OF
NEONATOLOGY IS.
IN PEDIATRIC INTENSIVE IST'S
THOSE OF THE NEARLY TAL JUICE IN
PEDIATRIC INTENSIVE VESTED STAFF
ARE NEIL NATAL INTENSIVE CARE
UNITS.
IN OUR PEDIATRIC PEDIATRIC
INTENSIVE CARE UNITS IN OUR
HOSPITALS.
THESE ARE THE FOLKS THE
CLINICIANS THE MEN AND WOMEN
THAT TAKE CARE OF THE STATE'S
VERY MOST FRAGILE AND AT RISK --
CHILDREN.
THESE ARE OUR BABYSITTER AS
YOUNG AS TWENTY TWO WEEKS --
HIGH MORTALITY RATES AND EVER
GROWING INCIDENCE OF OPIOID
ADDICTION. ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE FACING IS IT'S 60% OF
THAT POPULATION IS.
IS FOR FULLY FUNDED THROUGH
THROUGH MEDI CAL.
IN BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S
REIMBURSEMENT RATES -- ARE SO
LOW COMPARED TO OUR NEIGHBORING
STATES IT'S CREATED AT A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN RETAINING
QUALIFIED AND EXPERIENCED --
PROFESSIONALS IN THE NICK YOU IN
IN THE PICK YOU.
CURRENTLY -- BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THIS -- THESE PP YOUR ATTIC
SERVICES ARE HOSPITAL BASED.
NONE OF THESE PHYSICIANS --
SOCIETY OF THE INCREASES THROUGH
THE PROPS -- FIFTY SIX BUMP.
BECAUSE ALL OF THEIR OFFICE
HOURS ARE IN THE HOSPITAL.
IN AS RESULT -- WE WE HAVE RATES
THAT ARE 2100% LOWER.
THAN OUR MOST OUR CLOSEST
NEIGHBORING STATES AND THE
STATES IN WHICH WE COMPETES TO
RETAIN THESE FOLKS.
I PERSONALLY SPENT TIME IN NICK
HUGHES WE HAVE ONE CLINICIAN --
Q. ONE THE OWNER COLLEGES CARING
FOR EFFORTS OF FORTY OR FIFTY
PREEMIES.
THAT'S EXTREMELY STRESSFUL
SITUATION WHEN THEY CAN MOVE TO
NEVADA OR ARIZONA AND LITERALLY
MAKE TWO AND A HALF TO THREE
TIMES WHAT THEY'RE MAKING.
IN CALIFORNIA IS PRETTY STRAIGHT
ON THE SYSTEM.
RESCUE FOR FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDS
BE DEDICATED.
TO NOT JUST TO PICK YOU IN THE
NICK YOU BACK TO ALL PEDIATRIC
SERVICES THAT ARE HOSPITAL BASED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU AND I'VE GOT TO TELL
YOU THAT WHEN I SEE THAT WE ARE.
THE SECOND LOWEST.
PAYING WITH SECOND LOS PAYMENT
LEVEL -- IT.
RANKED RANKING FORTY NINTH IT'S
JUST.
I TRULY IS UNBELIEVABLE.
UNACCEPTABLE SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS PRESENTATION.
MENTAL HEALTH WARM LINE.
THE MANAGER WOMAN -- AND AT
OTHER ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME'S
PETER MURPHY I'M WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH ASSOCIATION OF SAN
FRANCISCO -- I WANT TO WISH YOU
HAPPY MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS
MONTH -- AND I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT -- TO DISCUSS OUR PROPOSAL --
FOR CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE
WARMLY -- WE'RE ASKING FOR THREE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO
FUND THE WIND -- FOR FOR ONE
YEAR.
AND THIS IS BASED ON OUR
EXPERIENCE WITH OUR LOCAL SAN
FRANCISCO WARM LINE WHICH BEGAN
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN AND HAS TAKEN
ROUGHLY A HUNDRED THOUSAND CALLS
SINCE -- SINCE ITS BEGINNING IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY FOURTEEN ARE
FUNDING FOR THAT LINE -- RAN OUT --
AT THE END OF LAST FISCAL YEAR
AND SINCE THEN WE'VE BEEN ONLY
WE'VE BEEN LIMITED TO FORTY
HOURS PER WEEK AND ONLY SERVING
THE NINE VERY COUNTIES.
AND WE'RE WE'RE HOPING TO RE
EXPANSIVE WE CAN SERVE THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
ARE WARMLY IS BASED ON PURE
RECOVERY WHICH IS ONE PERSON
WITH MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
HELPING IN THE OTHER.
AND CAN PROVIDE SERVICES -- LIKE
WHAT I'VE HEARD A LACK HERE
TODAY SORT OF THOSE AREAS WHERE
PEOPLE KIND OF FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS -- YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT A
SUBSTITUTE -- FOR FOR THAT.
BEFORE -- PSYCHOTHERAPY OR
COUNSELING BUT WE CAN BE THERE
IN ADDITION TO THAT -- WERE WERE
PLANNING TO BE OPEN TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN WHICH MEANS THAT A PERSON
COULD REACH OUT TO US -- ANYTIME
OF THE DAY AND WHEN WHEN ATHER
SERVICES MIGHT NOT BE AVAILABLE
WE'RE PREVENTIVE SERVICE SO
WE'RE TRYING TO KEEP -- KEEP
ANYONE THAT CALLS INTO US OUT OF
CRISIS AND THE IDEA THAT WOULD
BE TO HELP SAVE LIVES AND ALSO
TO SAVE MONEY TO THE COMMUNITY.
AND THE SENSE THAT -- THEY THE
PERSON WOUL NOT NEED MORE
EXPENSE OF EMERGENCY -- AT
REGENCY ROOM OR CRISIS
INTERVENTION OR OR
HOSPITALIZATION SO THAT WOULD BE
A SAVINGS TO THE COMMUNITY -- I
PERSONALLY HAVE -- EXPERIENCE
WITH THE WARM LINE I'VE BEEN
ACCOUNTS ARE ON THE WARM LINE --
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN AND WE'VE
TAKEN AROUND A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALLS AND I'VE TAKEN ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND OF THEM.
AND SO IDENTIFY I'M IDENTIFIES
AN ALCOHOLIC AND ADDICT IN
RECOVERY AND ALSO A PERSON WITH
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
RECOVERY.
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO TO SHARE THE
WITH YOU TODAY -- WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE BEING SUPPORTED BY THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE AND NOW
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE THE WHOLE
STATE AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU WHAT COUNTIES ARE YOU
SERVING NOW -- WE'RE SERVING THE
NIGHT YOU SERVE WELL -- THROUGH
THE END OF LAST FISCAL YEAR WE
WERE WE WERE WE WERE ABLE TO
SERVE THE ENTIRE STATE -- RIGHT
NOW WE'RE SERVING THE NINE VERY
COUNTIES -- IMMEDIATELY AROUND
SERVICES GO LIKE SAME MATTEO --
UP -- TO NAPA COUNTY AND SONOMA
COUNTY IN SOUTH TO BUY MONTEREY.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PRESENTATION FREE TIME.
S. CI YOU CALIFORNIA.
WHAT NO BABY [inaudible]
AB [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TIFFANY WINE
WITH AT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA --
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST WE
AUTHORIZATION OF AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY NINE THE MEDIC HOW LONG
TERM CARE ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR AND BUDGET YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT'S
CURRENTLY SET TO EXPIRE JULY
THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
AND WE WOULD REQUEST A
COMPLAINING OF A WORK GROUP.
IN THE CURRENT BUDGET YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY A
REST AND UNCHECKED
REAUTHORIZATION ROB THE STATE OF
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL IMPROVEMENTS ON A
BROKEN SYSTEM THAT CONTINUOUSLY
BILLS TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF VULNERABLE RESIDENTS.
LIVING IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
WE HAVE A ROBUST DIALOGUE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS AND
CAN THE CONCERNS IN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM.
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY NINE WAS
INTENDED TO DEVISE A REAP
MORE EFFECTIVELY ENSURES
INDIVIDUALS IS ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE LONG TERM CARE
SERVICES PROMOTE QUALITY
RESIDENT CARE ADVANCES DECENT
WAGES AND BENEFITS FOR NURSING
HOME.
WORKERS SUPPORTS PROVIDER
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS AND
ENCOURAGES ADMINISTRATIVE --
EFFICIENCY DISCUSSIONS REGARDING
THE INTENSE AND IF IT IS IN FACT
BE AN ACTUAL LIES NEEDS TO
HAPPEN PRIOR TO ANY RE
AUTHORIZATION.
AND LASTLY AT A TIME WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE IS DISCUSSING THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING AND AS OUR
AGING POPULATION CONTINUES TO
GROW WE MUST TALK ABOUT NURSING
HOMES AND HOW TO ADDRESS THE
CONTINUED POOR QUALITY.
AND THE OVERALL SPENDING --
STRUCTURE OF THE SYSTEM SO FOR
THESE REASONS WE WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NOW  THINK IT'S TIME FOR THE
BABY TO GO HOME AND GET SOME
REST.
OR MAYBE IT'S JUST BECAUSE WE'RE
JEALOUS THAT WE CAN GO WITH THE
BABY.
ALL RIGHT SEED FUNDING FOR
OFFICE OF SCHOOL BASED HEALTH.
I'M HELEN ROCKED OUT IN WITH ME
IS -- LYDIA BORN -- FROM SCHOOL
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND JUST
BRIEFLY -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT
BURN BERMAN WE WANT TO THANK HIM
AS A WONDERFUL BILL ON THIS.
IS A NO COST PROPOSAL WHICH
WOULD ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
TRANSFER MONEY THROUGH THEY GET
BACK.
THROUGH G. D..
DH CS TO CD BUT TO START UP THE
PROGRAM WHICH IS AN OFFICE OF
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH THIS WOULD
BE ONE TIME APPROPRIATION -- TO
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT A WHOLE
OTHER BUDGET CYCLE FOR THIS.
CALIFORNIA IS FORTY EIGHT IN THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY WE GET BACK FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
SCHOOL BASED SERVICES.
WE ARE AS FAR AS WE CAN TELL THE
ONLY STATE IN THE COUNTRY THAT
DOES NOT HAVE AN OFFICE.
FULL HEATH WITHIN THEIR
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WE CAN'T
FIND ANOTHER STATE THAT DOESN'T
HAVE SOME COORDINATION.
SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE SAYING THEY
NEED THIS SO THEY HAVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO IMPLEMENT THESE
SOMETIMES VERY TECHNICAL
PROGRAMS IN THE SCHOOLS.
AND LASH OF LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
THE LAST FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN AN AUDIT OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDS.
AND THEY REALLY THOUGHT THAT
THERE WAS A THERE WAS A WAY THEY
AND HELP FROM.
WITHIN THE EDUCATION STRUCTURE
THAT WOULD -- REALLY ALLEVIATED
AND WE'RE JUST MOVING NOW
TOWARDS A STATE PLAN AMENDMENT
THAT WILL ALLOW THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO DELIVER SERVICES
FOR KIDS THAT DON'T HAVE
INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION PLANS
WITHIN THE SCHOOLS.
AND THE SCHOOLS REALLY NEED SOME
ASSISTANCE AND WITH THAT.
LYDIA WILL FINISH MY THIRTY ONE
WITHOUT CALTRANS THIRTY ONE
SECONDS -- OKAY FINE THIS THIS
WE SEE THIS AS A NEED FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AS WELL
AS THE PRIMARY HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO SET UP A
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP.
CURRENTLY AS HELEN ST WE DO NOT
HAVE ONE WE ALSO BELIEVE WITH
THAT COLLABORATION WE WILL START
TO SEE.
OUR TECH MORE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OUT REACH AND
COORDINATION OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES PROVIDED IN THE SCHOOLS --
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT WITH THIS --
MEAGER AMOUNT THAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR WE CAN GET THE SEED MONEY TO
PUT IN PLACE THIS DEPARTMENT.
ARE WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION -- AND SO WE ASKED WE
SUPPORT FOR THIS SONG THIS
REQUEST.
THANK YOU THAT I MAKING ANY ONE
SECOND. SIX TO RESET IT SO I
ASSUME YES OTHERWISE YOU WOULD
PUT A LITTLE SIGN.
THANK YOU FOR THE PROPOSAL I
WILL TELL YOU THAT IT'S IT'S
IT'S DOES APPEAR LIKE SUCH A
SMALL AMOUNT TO SET UP A
DEPARTMENT IN OFFICES SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH.
THIS ON GOING FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE WILLING TO PAY FOR TO HAVE
THIS OFFICE SO IT'S REALLY JUST.
GETTING THE STAFF IN PLACE YOU
CAN USE VISITING EDUCATORS WHO
WILL COME IN AND TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND THEN THEY WILL GO
BACK TO THEIR DISTRICTS TO SET
IT UP SO IT'S JUST THAT ONE YEAR
COST OF GETTING IN PLACE.
ON GOING IT'S PAID FOR IT'S NOT
THE BILL'S ALREADY OVER IN THE
SENATE BECAUSE IT DIDN'T GO
THROUGH A FISCAL COMMITTEE.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO SCHOOL.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP.
WEST HEALTH.
HI GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM MYRA ALVAREZ WITH
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP WHERE
STATEWIDE POLICY AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
WE ARE REQUESTING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO MAKE SPECIFIC THE
INTENT OF AB.
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR LEGISLATION
WE SPONSORED IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN THE LANGUAGE
WOULD MAKE CLEAR THAT FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS AND
RULE HEALTH CENTERS MAY
ESTABLISH A PATIENT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF BILLING THROUGH
STORE AND FORWARD TELE DENTISTRY.
WE SPONSORED AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR SO THAT THE SUCCESSFUL
VIRTUAL DENTAL HOME OR VT H..
COULD SPREAD TO REACH MORE
UNDERSERVED CHILDREN AND ADULTS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE ENROLLED IN
MEDICARE.
WE KNOW THAT ACCESS TO DENTAL
SERVICES IS IN ADEQUATE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN.
IN FACT AROUND 50% OF ENROLLED
CHILDREN IN MEDI CAL DON'T GET
ANY DENTAL SERVICES AT ALL.
THE V. H. SYSTEM ADDRESSES
BARRIERS SUCH AS A LACK OF
TRANSPORTATION.
AND AN ABILITY TO TAKE TIME OFF
OF WORK AND UNFAMILIARITY WITH
THE SYSTEM.
BY PROVIDING DENTAL CARE WHERE
PEOPLE ARE.
DIRECTLY IN COMMUNITY SETTINGS
PLACES AND NURSING HOMES. FOR
THE VIRTUAL DOWN HOME TO ACHIEVE
THE POTENTIAL INTENDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE CLARIFICATION OF THE
LAW IS NEEDED.
THE TECHNICAL FIX THAT WE SEE TO
ADVANCE WOULD MAKE CLEAR THE
INTENT OF AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
BY SPECIFYING THAT HEALTH
CENTERS CAN ESTABLISH A PATIENT.
USING STORE AND FORWARD TELE
DENTISTRY.
THIS CLARIFICATION WILL ENSURE
THAT THE V. D. H. CAN CONTINUE
TO MAKE AN IMPACT ON REDUCING
ORAL HEALTH DISPARITIES FAR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
PARTICULARLY OUR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST SO
THAT THE VIRTUAL DENTAL HOME
SYSTEM CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
THOUSANDS OF UNDERSERVED
CHILDREN FAMILIES.
IT HAS SUCCESSFULLY BEEN SERVING
FOR OVER A DECADE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
AND MAY I SAY FOR THE LAST
PRESENTATION.
AS A PARENTING SUPPORT BY TRIPLE
OR TRY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- I'M
RANDY ON HIM -- TELL CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST ON BASED IN ORANGE
COUNTY I WORK WITH ABOUT HALF OF
THAT THE COUNTIES IN THE STATE.
TO IMPLEMENTOR P. THE POSITIVE
PARENTING PROGRAM -- THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU WOULD
APPROPRIATE EIGHT MILLION TO
EQUIP COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
FQHCS RURAL HEALTH CENTERS.
WITH AN ONLINE EVIDENCE BASED
POSITIVE PARENTING PROGRAM IT'S
A WEB BASED APPROACH.
THAT CAN SCALE ACROSS THE STATE.
AS I MENTIONED I REPRESENT ONE
SUCH PROGRAM TRIPLE P. WHICH HAS
DEVELOPED A PROVEN EVIDENCE
BASED SYSTEM OF PARENT TEEN
SUPPORT.
DESIGNED TO CREATE BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN TEENAGERS
FAMILIES AT THE INDIVIDUAL
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY LEVEL.
WITH THE EIGHT MILLION WE
CONSERVE ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
FAMILIES OKAY SO ASSUMING TWO
KIDS PER FAMILY THAT'S TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND KIDS.
THAT CAN POSSIBLY BENEFIT FROM
THIS PROGRAM.
NOW FQHCS ARE AN IDEAL SETTING
DELIVER TO DELIVER PARENT TEEN
INFORMATION.
THEY HAVE INCREASED THEIR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
CHILDREN FAMILIES THAT ARE
ROUTINELY SEEN THERE AND THE
LOGIC IS THERE RIGHT WITH
TIGHTER INTEGRATION HE PROVIDE
ADDED VALUE TO PATIENT VISITS.
ABLE TO CATCH PROBLEMS BEFORE
THEY ESCALATE AND OF COURSE IT'S
ALWAYS MORE EXPENSIVE RIGHT TO
DEAL WITH COMMUNITY PROBLEMS
LATER TO DEAL A CHILD
MALTREATMENT LATER TO DEAL WITH
CHILD TRAUMA LATER.
IN PRACTICE FQHCS.
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO OFFER THE
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS TO
PARENTS AND THIS IS PRIMARILY
DUE TO A LACK OF RESOURCES.
THERE IS A WIDENING GAP BIG
BETWEEN BEST PRACTICES AND
STANDARDS OF CARE -- FOR EXAMPLE
FOR WORKING WITH THE KIDS WITH
ADHD OR SOME KIND OF DESTRUCTIVE
BEHAVIOR PROBLEM.
SO PEDIATRICIAN CELL
PSYCHOLOGISTS OR LAST FORTY
YEARS HAVE DEVELOPED NINE DRUG
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENTS FOR
THESE KINDS OF PROBLEMS THEY
WORK BUT WE ARE STILL FACED WITH
THE PROBLEM WITH ACCESS AND AND
AND THIS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
ACCESS IS A HUGE PROBLEM FOR THE
POPULATION THAT WE SERVE.
FAMILY SEE THEIR DOCTOR IN PETER
P. A. BECAUSE THEY TRUST THEM
THEY GET TREATMENT IN REFERRAL
INFORMATION AT THESE FQHCS
WITHOUT THAT TRUST.
THEY ARE LEFT TO SORT THROUGH
LIKE TWO HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
HITS ON GOOGLE ABOUT HOW TO GET
HELP FOR PARENT TEEN.
OKAY SO THIS PROPOSAL EQUIPS
PRIMARY CARE STOCKS WITH A GOOD
REFERRAL EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAM
THAT'S A HIGH STANDARD OF CARE
AND FEEL TODAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT CONCLUDES.
ISSUE NUMBER.
FOURTEEN AND I WE WILL OPEN IT
UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR DR
WHAT FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS YOUR STAMINA.
THE FIRST BEING MADE WITH A TRY
TO TAKE AFTER YOU HI I'VE GOT I
DON'T KNOW WHY BUT THIS LATER
HAVE TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
ANYWAY HAVING SAID THAT THE ON
AIR INNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR ELDERS INDEPENDENCE
WHICH IS A PROGRAM FOR ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE IN THE EAST BAY
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY ON
BEHALF OF THE JEWISH HOME ALSO
IN LOS NGELES TO PAY RUNS A
PACE PROGRAM.
I WANT TO SUPPORT THE PEACE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF CAL PASTE.
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR A PROGRAM
FOR ALL INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE
ELDERLY IN SUPPORT OF THAT CARE
GIVERS.
RESOURCES I REQUEST FOR
AUGMENTATION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT SPENCER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS A WE SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA PAN THAT THEY CAN
HELP NETWORK CHILDREN NOW AND
REGIONAL ASTHMA MANAGEMENT
PROVINCIAL PULLS ALL FOR ASTHMA
PREVENTION MEDI CAL -- ALSO ON
BEHALF OF WEST HEALTH WE'D LIKE
TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA DENTAL SO
SHE'S PROPOSAL FOR MEDICAL
COVERAGE FOR SILVER DAM AND
FLUORIDE AND THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP PROPOSAL TO CLARIFY
THE INTENT TO THE VIRTUAL DENTAL
HOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER SNYDER BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES REPRESENTING ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND STATE CALIFORNIA.
WANT TO SUPPORT THE A ONE
PROPOSAL THAT DEALS WITH -- AT
PROVIDING IT INCREASED MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR PSYCHOLOGISTS
OR MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS IN
NURSING HOMES WE AGREE IN PRO.
PHIL REALLY IMPORTANT AND THEN
SECOND WE'D LIKE TO I'M ACTUALLY
SUPPORT TO S. USE YOU AS YOUR
USE PROPOSAL RELATED TO
STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT IN THAT
REIMBURSEMENT STRUCTURE I
CHANGES TO SKILLED NURSING BUT
WE UP WE OPPOSE ACTUALLY WAITING
UNTIL NEXT YEAR TO RE AUTHORIZE
THAT -- REIMBURSEMENT STRUCTURE
WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET
THAT DONE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE TO
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO AT THE
TIME TO IMPLEMENT GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M VERY STATE TANG --
MY FIRST TASK IS -- I'M GOING --
TO TESTIFIED SUPPORT FOR THE
ASTHMA PREVENTION AND MEDI CAL
FOR THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA I'M
GONNA TESTIFY RIGHT -- THAT WELL.
AT IN SUPPORT YOU'RE NOT OKAY
YEAH NO NOT THAT ALL RIGHT IN
SUPPORT OF MY SECOND HAT OUT
THERE BUT THEY TUNING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I WANT
TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THE C.
B. H. THE A PROPOSAL. FOR THE
TECHNICAL CHANGE TO THE TIMELINE
FOR INNOVATION FUNDING THIS IS
CRITICAL FOR MANY COUNTIES
ESPECIALLY A LARGER COUNTIES.
AND THEN LASTLY I WANT TO
REGISTER -- SOME CONCERNS WITH A
CAB P. PROPOSAL ABOUT THE COUNTY
OF RESIDENCE AND DRUG TREATMENT
THAT'S THE FIRST I'VE HEARD OF
THAT ISSUE SO -- WILLING TO
COMMIT TO WORK ON THAT ISSUE
WITH THEM AND SEE VJ ANDY AT CS
THANK YOU.
MAYOR MARTIN HERE WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
RATE INCREASE FOR AIR AMBULANCE
SERVICES AND ALSO COVERAGE FOR
ASTHMA PREVENTION SERVICES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
SUSAN TO MORRIS ON BEHALF OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT THE CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTER AND THE PROGRAM FOR ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY
PACE PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE NEVINS DIRECTOR TELL OR
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF THE DAY CALIFORNIA
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER
PROPOSAL.
I SERVED THIRTEEN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES AND WE HAVE
A WAIT LIST OF MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED PEOPLE JUST TO BECOME A
CLIENT -- SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HOLY MEASUREMENT HAVE TO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL UNDER PROGRAM EXECUTIVES
WE SUPPORT THE ALCHEMIST
PROPOSAL FOR THE MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT AND THEN WE
SUPPORT.
THE CALIFORNIA BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION --
PROPOSALS FOR EXPANSION OF S. B.
I. R. T. -- TO DRUG SCREENING
AND ALSO THE INNOVATION FUND
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MEANWHILE THE
HARDWARE WITH A OR P. WE STAND
AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER
BUDGET ASK THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I CRISTINA IRVING WITH FAMILY
CAREGIVER ALLIANCE THE BAY AREA
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTER FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
JOHN BLUETOOTH HEALTH PROJECTS
CENTER THE DEL MAR CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTER I WANT TO
STRONGLY IMPLORE YOU.
TO SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS SO THAT
WE CAN SERVE MORE PEOPLE WITH
MODERN TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
NANCY POWER STONE I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF REDWOOD CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTER AND WE SERVE
SOLANO NAPA SAID NO MAMA.
HUMBOLDT DEL NORD LAKE AND
MENDOCINO COUNTIES AND I'M HERE
TO ON BEHALF OF OUR FAMILY CARE
GIVERS AND THOSE -- CHALLENGING
AREAS -- ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT
THE CARE GIVER RESOURCE ANY
CENTER FUNDING REQUEST THANK YOU.
SALIM TARGETS IN A SORRY LOSING
MY VOICE.
HI I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS A FAMILY
CAREGIVER ALLIANCE AND I HAVE
FAMILY CARE GIVER MYSELF.
ANNA STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
CHARACTER RESOURCE CENTER
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SHERRI DAILY WITH CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT AND OUR PRODUCT
TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
REIMBURSEMENT SCHEDULE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE HOSPITAL DETOX
RATE INCREASE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE SCREENING BRIEF INTERVENTION
AND REFERRAL TO TREATMENT --
PROPOSAL AND IN SUPPORT OF MANY
OF THE ASPECTS OF THE S. YOU DO
WORK FOR SO -- PRESENTATION AND
THE SECTION THAT WILL SEND A
LETTER FOR YOUR FOR THEIR
DELIBERATION LATER THIS WEEK ON
THAT.
ONE THANK YOU.
GALEANO CHILDREN NOW ONE OF THE
CO SPONSORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
ASTHMA -- PREVENTIVE SERVICES IN
MEDI CAL ALONG WITH IN SUPPORT
OF THE SILVER TIMING FLOOR RIGHT
FOR DENTAL -- ALONG WITH THEIR
PERSONAL DENTRE HOME.
PROPOSAL AND THE OFFICE OF
SCHOOL HEALTH FUNDING PROPOSAL
THANK YOU.
LINDA DINNER WITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK ALSO A STRONG SUPPORTER
IN CO SPONSOR OF THE ASTHMA
PROPOSAL -- STEVENS ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE VIRTUAL DENTAL
HOME AS WELL AS EXPANSION OF
ESPRIT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING JEWELERS WITH RAMP
REGIONAL ASTHMA MANAGEMENT
PREVENTION ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS FOR THE ASTHMA
PREVENTIVE SERVICES MEDI CAL
STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS SHOWN THAT
THESE TYPES OF SERVICES CAN
ACTUALLY REDUCE.
HEALTHCARE EXPENDITURES BY
AVOIDING MORE COSTLY EDIE AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS FROST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
VICTOR CHRISTY CALVET HELPLESS
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE VIRTUAL DENTAL
HOME CLARIFYING TRAILER BILL.
AND THE MEDICAL COVERAGE OF
SILVER DYE MINE FLOOR IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY HERE TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR THE ASK ME A MEDIC
HOW INTERPRETER PROGRAM AS WELL
AS THE MEDIC HOW ASTHMA
PREVENTION.
PROGRAM AS WELL AS THE VIRTUAL
DENTAL HOME TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GET THE MOST BURKE ON BEHALF OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT OF THE ASPEN PREVENTIONS
PREVENTIVE SERVICES A MEDI CAL.
THANK YOU.
ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF OF BRIE
THAT LAY OUT A CAT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S ADVOCATES FOR CLEAN
AIR AND HEALTHY LUNGS SINCE FOR
THE AS ONE PREVENTION -- ALSO ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
THE EFFORT EXPANSION TO INCLUDE
DRUGS OTHER NOW CALL.
AND ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE WORK
FORCE PROPOSAL WITH SOME MINOR
CHANGES.
AND ON THE ALSO WANT PERCY SAM
ON BEHALF OF THE BRIDGE HOUSING.
THING AND THEN FINALLY ON BEHALF
OF THE LC I YOU CALIFORNIA --
THE CARE GIVERS RESOURCE CENTER
WERE IN TOTAL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LOT ABOUT ON BEHALF OF ULTIMATE
IN SUPPORT OF THE CARAPACE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY ARE ALL RIGHT BUT THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT OF ASTHMA PREVENTION AND
MEDI CAL SEE FUNDING FOR THE
OFFICE OF SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
AND MEDICAL COVERAGE OF STF.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING AND WENDY CHAD FROM
TO MAKE YOUR CALIFORNIA I MEAN
IF I YOUR MOTHER DAUGHTER SISTER
I AM I ALSO HAVE MILD HEMOPHILIA.
AS WELL AS HAVING WORKED IN THE
ESPECIALLY PHARMACY INDUSTRY FOR
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS PROVIDING
CARE TO PEOPLE WITH HEMOPHILIA.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH'S TRAFFIC CUTS TO BACK
TO REIMBURSEMENT ESPECIALLY
PHARMACIES AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THIS EVENING
ALLOWING US TO EXPRESS OURSELVES
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
I MEAN NUMBERS LYSISTRATA.
HMM MANY THE CLASS IS --
REGARDING THE BLOOD FACTORED.
REIMBURSEMENT -- I HAVE A HIM OF
MEDIA EIGHT AND SEVERE -- YO YO
MAN -- UP WILL BUNGLE -- Là --
THIS BOOK RECORDS AS DID THE
ACTION IS A IS A ZERO KEEP
GETTING AS A LOWER COURT TO THE
MEDI CAL.
THE FOR MEASURE THIS BUSILY S.
OWN.
MOVIE INPUT CAMPUS BUT I MEAN IF
I MEDIA. FOR THE ALISON VISUALS
YEP WELL YOU CANYON IS BRING
THEM.
WE TELL YOU THAT HE'S GOT US
THIS IS THE FIRST IRAQI.
WHEN I STATUS WHEN IS THAT CAN
ASSIST ME NUMBER ONE I WE DON'T
USE?
YOU IN THE KNOW IT DOES NOT
BECAUSE HE'S ONLINE IS NO WAY OF
A YEAH I'M ON HEY GUYS.
YOU'LL MISS THEM A LOT IS THAT
HE THIS IS REGARDING THE BLUFF
FACTOR REIMBURSEMENT THE MAN YES
A SO YES POLLS ARE EQUIPPED WHAT
ARE THE NUMBERS WHEN I GET THE
NAME OF VIA.
THE MAIN COULD OCCUR PERCENT
BOTH US PERSON IS GOING TO PLEAD
ON THIS THAT IT WILL YEAH KEEP
ON WITH THE BUSINESS HONEST.
IF THEY LAST A COLONIA -- NEVA
MILLIONS UPON WAS WHAT THE
MENDOZA RECORD THIS.
ON THE PERSON WITH HEMOPHILIA
AND AN INHIBITOR I ALSO HAVE A
BROTHER WITH HEMOPHILIA --
AGAINST THE PROPOSED CUTS TO A
SPECIALTY PHARMACIES AND BLOOD
PRODUCTS -- BUT I AM FOR A MORE
REASONABLE AND LOGICAL --
REIMBURSEMENT FOR ALL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
HELLO MY NAME IS SHELLY JUDGE
JAY AND I HAVE MILD HEMOPHILIA.
I AM ALSO THE MOTHER OF A SON
TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD WHO
INFUSES BLOOD FACTOR DAILY.
I'VE BEEN A COMMUNITY MEMBER FOR
TWENTY FOUR YEARS AND A FORK FOR
SPECIALTY PHARMACY FOR NINE
YEARS.
I DROVE OVER THREE HOURS TODAY
TO TO STRONGLY EXPRESS MY
OPPOSITION OF THE PROPOSED TO S.
PA BY D. H. C. S. TO CUT
REIMBURSEMENTS TO MEDI CAL.
SPECIALTY PHARMACY PROVIDERS FOR
BLOOD FACTOR TREATMENTS.
SPECIALTY PHARMACIES ARE
INSTRUMENTAL IN PROVIDING
SUPPORT TO THE BLEEDING
DISORDERS COMMUNITY AND I
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL BY
SPECIALTY PHARMACIES TO PREVENT
THOSE CUTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU THOUGH.
SO I ALLOWED IT BECAUSE SHE
DROVE THROUGH MY THREE MONTH
THREE HOURS.
BUT REALLY I JUST WANT YOUR NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION.
WHICH OF THE PROPOSALS AND
EITHER YOU SUPPORT YOUR ARE YOU
OPPOSE IT.
SHE WAS SPECIAL THREE HOURS IS A
LONG TIME TO BE DRIVING.
MY NAME IS CLOUT EQUIP US AND I
HAVE A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD SON WITH
SEVERE HEMOPHILIA.
AND I OPPOSE THE PSA BY DHS CS --
REIMBURSEMENT CUT TO MEDICAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
FULLER PRESENTING YOUR SON.
HELLO MY NAME IS HUGO ARM A
PERSON LIVING WITH HEMOPHILIA.
I HAVE A FATHER AND A BROTHER
WITH HEMOPHILIA AS WELL.
AND I WORK IN SPECIALTY PHARMACY
AND AYE AYE OPPOSED THE PROPOSED
SPOCK.
MY DH CS TO CUT REIMBURSEMENT TO
MEDI CAL ESPECIALLY PHARMACY
PROVIDERS FOR BLOOD PRODUCT
FACTOR PRODUCTS TREATMENTS AND I
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
BY SPECIALLY PHARMACIES TO
PREVENT TO PROVE VENT THOSE CUTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
[inaudible]
MADAM CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY PANEL MY NAME IS JEFF
GRIFFITH FROM SAN DIEGO I'VE
BEEN IN THE ROOM FOR ABOUT SEVEN
HOURS.
JOE OF TWO AND A HALF HOURS TO
THE AIRPORT I'M TEASING YOU.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE CHANGES SO
HAVE WE BUT NO NO.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE YOU
KNOW THANK YOU I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE CHANGES THAT -- 75% CHANGES
AND SPECIAL THANKS TO YOU --
DOCTOR WOULD FOR ALL YOUR
ASSISTANCE IN -- PARADISE THE
FIRES MY AUNT WAS ONE THE LAST
ONES THAT MADE IT OUT ALIVE.
SO I APPRECIATE ALL YOU GUYS DO
AND AND AND PLEASE THESE
HEMOPHILIA PATIENTS HAVE BEEN
THROUGH A LOT WE'VE COME A LONG
WAY.
THANK YOU HAVE A GOOD EVENING.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS JOHN
MARTINEZ MY FATHER WITH THREE
CHILDREN IS PEOPLE FEELING.
I'M FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I
WORK AS A PEER NAVIGATOR FOR
SPECIALTY PHARMACY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE CUTS
THAT DHS THE CHS OPPOSING THIS
GONNA CUT ACCESS TO CARE FOR MY
CHILDREN LIKE MINE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NAME IS TERRY RICE AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY AND
EDUCATION FOR A LARGE NATIONAL
SPECIALTY PHARMACY CONCERN.
AND I'M ALSO A FIFTY SEVEN YEAR
OLD PERSON WITH SEVERE
HEMOPHILIA A VERY RARE COMMODITY --
AND I STRONGLY SO -- OPPOSE THE
THE SPA IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN BY
DH CS WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SOMETHING.
MORE REASONABLE ACCOMPLISHED
HERE AND LET'S PRESERVE ACCESS
TO CARE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CINDY GOES MAN I'M
COMING FOR MARINA CALIFORNIA I
AM A MOM WITH THE SOUND WITH HIM
OFFICIALLY AT AGE -- THIRTEEN I
ALSO WORK FOR SPECIALTY PHARMACY
AND I'M HERE TO A POST THAT THE
AGES PROPOSAL CUTS TO MEDICARE
BECAUSE IMPACT MY FAMILY AND
ALSO IMPACT A LOT OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I CAN SPEAK UP
FOR THEMSELVES OR CAN BE HERE.
TELL YOU WHAT THE IMPACT WILL BE
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS GABBY SOME
MORON.
I'M A MOM.
OF A DAUGHTER WITH BOND WITH THE
BROWNS AND MYSELF I WORK FOR
SPECIALTY PHARMACY AND STRONGLY
OPPOSED THE DH CS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
VERONICA IDEAS I'M A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THAT --
STA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND WELCOME FROM THE INLAND
EMPIRE.
GOOD EVENING.
MY NAME IS RICHARD REGULAR ARM
FROM HIGHLAND.
IN A PHARMACIST WHO HAS PROVIDED
SPECIALTY PHARMACEUTICAL CARE.
FOR THE HEMOPHILIA BLEEDING
DISORDER COMMUNITY FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS.
I STRONGLY PRO OPPOSED TO
PROPOSE SPA.
CUTS BY DH CS THANK YOU FROM
HIGHLANDS OVER IN SAN BERNADINO.
WELL WELCOME MIGHT I'M SORRY
THAT MY COLLEAGUE MISTER RAMOS
WAS NOT HERE.
I WILL CHASTISE HIM FOR NOT
HAVING BEEN HERE TO WELCOME YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ADRIAN
FLORIDA'S I HAVE SEVERE
HEMOPHILIA A WHICH IS A FACTOR
EIGHT DEFICIENCY -- I'VE DEBT
DEDICATED MY PROFESSIONAL LIFE
TO HELPING OTHERS SUCH AS MYSELF --
IN MY ROLE WITH A SPECIALTY
PHARMACY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS -- THIS PROPOSED CUT TO
MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT FOR LEAD
ACTOR PRODUCTS THANK YOU THANKS
FOR YOUR DEDICATION TO THE ISSUE.
HI MY NAME'S KEVIN SHAUGHNESSY I
HAVE HEMOPHILIA OF THREE CARRIER
DAUGHTERS AND ENOUGH WITH HIM
WITH LEYVA.
I LIVE IN HIGHLAND CALIFORNIA
AND I'M AN OWNER OF A SPECIALTY
PHARMACY THE SERVICES.
CAN FULLY PATIENTS AND THAT IS
MY PASSION.
DUE TO YOU KNOW LOSING A LOT OF
FRIENDS HIV AND HAVE SEEN THE
EIGHTIES WHICH I COULD QUITE
HABSI.
MYSELF EIGHT YEARS OLD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE MEDICARE
CUTS MEDICAID CUTS THANK UP FROM
HIGHLAND ALSO SAMBAR TO DO YOU
KNOW.
ALL RIGHT WE GOTTA TALK TO JAMES
RAMOS FOR INFO NOT BEING HERE.
BUT ON HIS WE HAVE WELCOME TO
THOSE OF YOU FROM HIGHLAND.
YES TELL HIM WHEN YOU SEE HIM.
HELLO I'M KELLY CARTY AS A
SPECIALTY PHARMACY NURSE FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH CALIFORNIA I AM
HERE NOT ONLY REPRESENTING OUR
PATIENTS.
BUT ALSO MY DAUGHTER AND HAS
BEEN WHO HAVE ALSO HAVE
HEMOPHILIA.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF ALL
SPECIALTY PHARMACIES AND THE
SERVICES THEY PROVIDE TO
FAMILIES INCLUDING IN ON NURSING
SUPPORT SERVICES IN EDUCATION.
I AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
DEPARTMENTS DRASTIC CUTS TO
FACTORY AMHERST MEANT TO
SPECIALTY PHARMACIES THAT WOULD
CUT THESE VITAL IN HOME SERVICES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR IN FILM
COMMITTEE.
HI MY NAME SCOTT CARTY IN HERE
FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH CALIFORNIA.
THE CO OWNER OF A SPECIALTY
PHARMACY BROTHERS HEALTH CARE.
ALSO A PERSON LIVING WITH SEVERE
HEMOPHILIA.
AND A FATHER WITH A DAUGHTER THE
HOUSE USUALLY A AND ONE WILL
READ DISEASE AS WELL.
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THAT I
OPPOSE THE PROPOSED BOB BY DH CS
TO DRASTICALLY CUT PHARMACY
PROVIDER REIMBURSEMENT FOR
PUTTING A SORT OF CARE.
AND SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL BY
SPECIALTY PHARMACIES TO PRINT
THOSE CUTS.
LEGAL TAKE THE CARE THAT'S
PROVIDED THE HOME IS VITAL TO
OUR LONG TERM SUCCESS AND
KEEPING US OUT OF THE EMERGENCY
ROOMS.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
SHERMAN FROM LINKING CALIFORNIA
I HAVE A DAD AND TWO NEPHEWS
LAWSON IN PRESCOTT WAS SEVERE
HEMOPHILIA I'M A CARRIER.
I AM ALSO PEER NAVIGATOR FOR
SPECIALTY PHARMACY AND THE
FOUNDER OF MUSIC FOR THE COSTS --
I AM HERE TODAY TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
PROPOSED BOB IDEAS YES TO CUT
REIMBURSEMENTS MEDI CAL
SPECIALTY PHARMACY PROVIDERS.
FOR BLOOD FACTOR TREATMENTS
BECAUSE IT WILL TAKE AWAY ACCESS
TO CARE AND ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL BY SPECIALTY
PHARMACY STRIPPERS PREVENT THOSE
CUTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ALMOST OVER.
MY NAME IS ROBERT SETON WE'RE
SAYING.
TO YOU KNOW.
HEY SO ANYWAY MY NAME IS ROBERT
C. NINE HAEMOPHILIA SEVERE WITH
INHIBITORS.
I HAVE TWO GRANDSONS -- ALSO
WITH HEMOPHILIA I'M A BOARD
MEMBER OF HE WITH A FOUNDATION
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND IF
FOUNDER OF MUSIC FOR THE CAUSE --
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE PROPOSED
CUTS DH CS AS AS RECOMMENDED TO
OUR COMMUNITY ACCESS TO CARE IS
IMPERATIVE -- JUST WANNA LET YOU
KNOW THAT -- WE APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTS AND KEEP THINKING OF US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MY NAME IS MARK HELM WE CAME
FROM SINGER CALIFORNIA THIS
MORNING.
AND I HAVE SEVERE HEMOPHILIA
ALSO AND ALSO THE OWNER OF THE
SPECIALTY PHARMACY AND I'M HERE
TO OPPOSE THE PROPOSED CUTS FROM
DH CS.
MU CAM QUITE A WAYS THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS CRAIG
MIRRORS -- CAME FROM NASHVILLE
TENNESSEE THIS MORNING.
OKAY YOU WIN THE PRIZE -- WORK
WITH - ADVOCATING FOR ACCESS
SPECIALTY PHARMACY COALITION --
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
SHARING OUR PASSION INVOICES --
JUST WANT TO ASK YOU.
TO CONSIDER YOU KNOW OUR
PROPOSAL TO MAKE SURE THAT
PATIENTS CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE MEDICATIONS AND SERVICES
THAT SPECIALTY PHARMACIES
PROVIDE. TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS A
YEAR THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU I WILL TELL YOU THAT I
APPRECIATED THE COMMENTS OF SOME
OF YOU WH SAID.
THAT YEAH I MEAN EVERYBODY SAID
YOU POSE THAT THE CUTS THE
PROPOSED CUTS.
BUT SOME OF THE COMMENTS HAVE
BEEN WE WANT THERE TO BE MORE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS -- AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK THAT
CLEARLY IT LOOKS LIKE THAT'S
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SHARE
GONZALEZ I REPRESENT A VARIETY
OF SPECIALTY PHARMACIES AND THE
BLEEDING DISORDER SPACE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING OUR
PROPOSAL WE DO OPPOSE THE
PROPOSED SPOT BUT WE ARE NOT
OPPOSED EVEN TO CUTS.
WE JUST ARE OPPOSED TO A 75% CUT
AND WE WANT TO THANK DOCTOR
WOULD WHO HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
HE SENT A LETTER TO THE
DEPARTMENT EXPRESSING HIS
CONCERNS AND I'M HAPPY TO REPORT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS REACHED
OUT.
AND ASKED FOR A MEETING WITH US
SO WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT WITH THIS
SUPPORT AND YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT WE WILL HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL RESOLUTION OF THIS
ISSUE.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ON ISSUE
NUMBER.
FOURTEEN ALL RIGHT ISSUES
[inaudible]
FIFTEEN THROUGH [inaudible]
NINETEEN OUR NON DISCUSSION
ITEMS USER ANYBODY FROM THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE.
TO ADDRESSES SUBCOMMITTEE ON
THOSE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
THIS CONCLUDES TODAY'S HEARING
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WOW